hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we'll be
taking you through the jquery full
course
in this video tutorial will cover
everything you need to know and
understand about jquery and jquery ui
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribe to our youtube channel
and press that bell icon to never miss
any updates from simply learn so without
any further delay let's get started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial
we'll start this video with an
introduction to jquery we'll then move
on and cover topics like jquery
selectors events and effects callback
functions in jquery and how jquery is
used to manipulate document object model
following that we'll also go through a
brief introduction to jquery ui we'll
then cover certain topics like widgets
and interactions in jquery we'll also
see how jquery is used for theme
customization
at the end of this full course we'll
create some jquery projects like
creating a calculator app a to-do list
and a fully functional website using
html css and jquery
let's start this video with what is
jquery
introduced in the year 2006 when john
rezik a web developer became frustrated
with the issue of cross browser
javascript he found it so complicated
that he decided to develop the
javascript library of his own to
overcome this problem that same library
is known as jquery today
so jquery is an open source
fast tiny and rich feature library that
makes it easy to interact with html
documents and it allows its users to
manipulate and traverse storm handle
events animations and ejects in much
simpler ways with an easy to use api
that works in almost all modern browsers
in a nutshell jquery revolutionized the
way of using javascript to interact with
html documents
so let's move ahead and see how we can
include javascript in a html file
so here we are in the html file we have
created an entirely new folder for this
we'll save
all the jquery related files in this
particular folders we have two more
folders here one is for the images we'll
be using in further videos and other one
is to save the jquery library file and
we have a html and javascript files over
here fine
now there are two different ways of
including jquery in a html file
we can either use a cdn for that or
download the jquery file and save it
somewhere in a system and then we can
use it later so the former way needs an
active internet connection and for the
latter one the internet connection does
not matter
so let's download the jquery file and
then we'll see how to use jquery fine
we'll move to the jquery website so go
to google and write jquery.com this will
take you to this particular website this
is the jquery website we have you can
see over here the size of this jquery
file is just 30 kilobytes really small
right
to download jquery click on this
download jquery button over here
the current ongoing version is version
3.6.0
and the previous two versions which are
one point x and two point x no longer
receives update patches so if you are in
2021 then it's not worth using those
versions click on the button and it will
redirect us to a new page
fine so click on the download jquery
button
so here you can see we have different
jquery versions so you can download the
compressed version the uncompressed
development version the map file or you
can also download the slim build
so what happens in slim build is it
excludes the ajax and effect modules
for now what we are going to do is we
are going to click on this download the
uncompressed developmental jquery
version 3.6.0
and you can see we have some code
written over here
the code looks a bit familiar right it's
written in javascript only there are
more than 10 000 lines of code so this
is basically a library with code written
for events animations and many more
things now press control plus s
and save the file in your system we'll
keep it inside the jquery folder and
change the name we'll keep it inside the
jquery folder we'll go to desktop here
is a jquery file will keep it inside
this jquery folder and will change the
name to
jquery only will remove the version name
from here save it so the file is
downloaded and you can check it by going
through the folder in your system the
file is saved so let's move back to the
vs code and try to use this file in a
html document
to include this jquery file in a html
document we have to follow the exact
same steps that we follow with
javascript files use the script tag and
write type and src and we are good to go
so let's include it here we'll include
the jquery file at the bottom after the
body tag because we want the html file
to be rendered first so what we'll do is
we'll write here
after the body tag
script
src is equals
to so what we have to write here is we
have to write here
jquery we have the file present inside
the jquery named folder we'll write here
jquery.js so this is the path of a
jquery file we'll write it type
is equals to
text slash
javascript
and we'll close the script tag
we'll again do the same thing but first
let me close this for you and
now what we'll do is we'll
include the javascript file as well so
we'll write here script
and src is going to be
jq
dot
js so this is the name of a javascript
file we'll write here type
is equals to text
slash
javascript
fine
so we have included the jquery file to
html document as well as the javascript
file as well
fine
we are done with setting up jquery let's
go through a small and exciting example
of using jquery now we'll discuss the
syntax in the upcoming videos you don't
have to worry about it just giving you
an example of what jquery is capable of
doing so if you guys remember from the
previous videos wherein we used
javascript for fade in and fade out
animations we were fading in and out an
image on a button click right and we had
to write 10 to 15 lines of code for
those two tiny tasks so what we'll do is
we'll do the same thing with jquery in
just one line let's find out how
so first thing first what we'll do is
we'll add an image so we'll add an image
to a html file so here what we'll do is
after this h1 tag will write here img
src is equals to
images slash
jq dot png so this is the
path of our image wherein we have saved
our image already we'll write here alt
is equals to
js and
we'll use the id attribute so let's say
the id is img1 for this image
next up we'll add a button as well we'll
write here button
and we'll do the same thing we'll write
here on click it will call a javascript
function so let's say the function name
is func one
and we'll write here
the button name fine so let's say the
button name is
fade
save it
and here you can see
we have an image over here we can resize
the image by using image height and
image width property here but let's
leave it for now and we have a fade
button over here you can see the fade
button is not working it's just a fake
button for now
so we have been doing all this stuff for
quite some time now right it's easy the
most straightforward task in html we can
say we need to define the function
function now to make the image fade in
and fade out on a button click so what
we'll do is we'll move to our javascript
file
and we'll write here
function
func one so this is a function and then
we have the body of this function so
that's simple what we'll do is we'll
write here dollar
inside brackets
will access the id attribute so we'll
write a img1
before that we'll write hash
and after that we'll write here dot feed
toggle
and this is a function
and we'll write a semicolon so that's it
guys we are done with it you guys might
wonder about what we did here so let me
explain guys so this dollar sign over
here is called a selector and it is used
to access an element from the html
document
we'll discuss everything about it in the
upcoming videos so for now just think of
it as the
document.getelementbyid method we were
using in javascript
it has the same functioning
then we have a function named fade
toggle this fate toggle function is
already defined in the jquery file which
we saved earlier in our system this
function fades out the image if the
image is there on the screen and the
good part is it also reverts the picture
if we click on the button again isn't it
interesting we don't have to write
lengthy code for such small tasks so
let's find out how it works
save it
go to the browser and click on this fade
button
see the image is gone click on the fade
button again and here it is so guys this
is what jquery can do in just one line
the set interval method we were using
previously also has an alternate here in
jquery we have to write the time
interval inside the fade toggle function
and that's it what we have to do is we
have to write here inside the fade
toggle function so let's say we are
writing here 3000 milliseconds save it
and go to the browser here we are click
on the fade button and see the magic
easy and worth using right
so i hope you guys understood all of
this for now
now before we wrap up this video let me
show you guys the second way of
including jquery in a html file by using
cdn
so we have to do the same thing again so
go to jquery.com again and click on the
download button scroll down and you can
see here it says using jquery with cdn a
content distribution network or a cdn is
a distributed network of proxy servers
and their data centers it provides high
availability and performance by
distributing the service related to end
users provided that the user has an
active internet connection
so click on any of them from wherever
you want to download for example
we'll click on the
cdnjs.cdn so we'll click on this and it
will take us to a new website copy the
link from here with script text so if
you click on here it will say
copy with script tag right so what we
have to do is we have to copy the link
from here with the script tags and go to
the javascript file
place it in place of script tag here now
what we'll do is we'll paste it here in
instead of this script tag
now
we have written over here srcs
cdnjs.cloudfair.com and this is the
whole path and then we have integrity
cross origin
referral policy and all fine save it now
go to your program and let's see if it's
working or not click on the fade button
wait for three seconds and it's totally
working right
we are all aware of accessing an html
element in javascript we have three
different methods for that the get
element by id the get element by class
name method and the get elements by tag
name method
so these three methods we have been
using for a long time apart from these
three methods we can also use query
selectors for accessing css selectors
right so let's do the same task using
jquery today
now selectors allow us to manipulate or
access html elements as a group or
single element in jquery
the syntax for accessing any particular
element is so simple that we don't have
to remember all of it just go through it
once and you might remember it for life
all we have to do is to use a dollar
sign and pass the id or class name with
particular symbols to let the jquery
file know the type and that's all
the question that arises here is how it
is different from javascript if we are
doing the same thing in jquery then what
is the real difference between these two
so guys jquery selectors are used to
find or access html elements based on
their name id classes types attributes
values and much more in simple words
jquery provides us the flexibility to
access any element in different ways
jquery selectors are based on css
selectors and it contains some custom
selectors as well so let's start by
going through the simple syntax and you
guys will get an idea of what selectors
are in jquery
what we'll do is we'll create an html
element with specific id first and then
we'll try to access that element so what
we'll do is we'll move to the body part
and we'll write here
if
id is equals
to let's say div one
so we are creating a div tag now inside
this what we'll do is we'll write some
paragraphs so we'll use the p tag for
that we'll write here p let's say we are
writing here this is paragraph 1.
let's
add another paragraph here what we'll do
is we'll again use the p tag and we'll
write here
this is
paragraph
two fine so what we'll do next is we'll
copy this whole div tag and we'll paste
it again basically what we are doing is
we are creating two div tags here fine
we'll write the id as div 2 and here
we'll write this is paragraph 3 and this
is paragraph 4 just for your convenience
guys
now what we'll do is we'll create a
button and we'll call a function on
clicking that button so the same part
with javascript as well what we'll do
here is we'll write here
button
and here we'll write on click
so after this we'll write
let's say we are creating a function
named funk one this button click will
call this function and let's say
the button name is click me fine
what we did here was simple we have used
two div tags and four paragraph tags
over here now we'll make some styling
changes here in both the div tags so
that they'll look different from each
other we have already added the style
sheet here we have the link as
stylesheet and the href is style.css so
this is a css file we'll make some
styling changes to our div tags from
here so before that let's save this
program once and check the output so
here are our paragraphs we have
paragraph one two three and four so all
of these paragraphs are present inside
two different div tags
we are not able to see those div tags
but we have used them here so what we'll
do is we'll make some styling changes to
make them look different
so you can see the click me button is
not working as of now
now what we'll do next is
we'll go to style.css and
we'll start styling those div tags we'll
write here
hash div one
so we'll style d1 first we'll write here
margin
as auto
let's say
text align at the center
border we are going to add we'll write
your border as
three pixels black and
dot it fine
next up we'll write here
font size as 50 pixels let's say and the
background color is going to be
let's say credit blue fine
next up we'll write here
height so
let's define the height of this div tag
we'll write a height as
300 pixels
and
width has 300 pixels fine now we have to
write one more thing here the position
is going to be
relative
and save it here you can see we have a
div tag over here so you can see the
font size is quite large what we'll do
is we'll reduce the font size here let's
say the font size we are going to write
here as 30 pixels so now you can see
it's working totally fine we have two
paragraphs inside a particular div tag
we have two paragraphs inside a
container what we'll do next is we'll
copy this piece of code
and we'll do the same thing for the
second div tag right we'll write here
div two save it and here you can see we
have two div tags over here
now what we'll do is we'll change the
color of this div tag fine
let's say the color of this div tag is
yellow save it and here you can see we
have two div tags over here right here
margin top is
10 pixels
fine save it and here you can see they
are not touching each other now now we
are done with styling our div tags
according to our need you can check it
by going through the webpage and here
you can see we have both our boxes
present over here so let's move on to
the jquery part now and we'll try to
make some changes in the styling of
these div tags using jquery selectors
so we'll move to a javascript file first
of all we'll access both the div tags
here we'll try to make some changes in
both the boxes using the element name
so we have to create a function named
function here so first of all we'll do
that we'll write your function
function
and inside the body of this function the
next thing we have to do is to change
the style of these div tags right so the
jquery syntax goes like this we'll
define the syntax first so it goes like
dollar
then we have the element name
so a dollar sign followed by an element
name
now the javascript alternative for this
statement will be
document
dot
get element by tag name
and then we'll write here the
element name fine so this is the
alternative of this particular statement
in javascript you can check if it's
right or not
so you can see here it's showing some
error because we haven't written the
original element name here so it's
totally fine
now once we are done with this part we
have to mention here the action as well
in the jquery syntax
so the actions here may be predefined or
we can customize those functions as well
for now we'll use the predefined actions
so let me tell you the syntax first
we'll write here action so action is
going to be a function which will
perform certain
task in the
div tags fine
now let's move on and write the actual
code here
now in this particular case we are
accessing the div tags here so we want
to make similar changes to both the div
tags right what we can do is we'll write
here
dollar
inside this
will write the element name inside
double quotes and
after that we'll write the action name
so we'll write here dot css and inside
css will write here
background color and after this we'll
define the color here
so let's say the color is orange let's
see so let's define them inside single
inverted commas
and
we are good to go
now what we did here is we selected both
the div tags we have to put the element
name inside the double quotes then we
have the action as css that will allow
us to make styling changes in the html
elements then we have defined the style
changes inside the brackets here what we
are doing is we are changing the
background color of both the div tags on
the button click to orange
so
let's save it and what we'll do is we'll
click on this click me button and see if
it's working or not so click on it and
you can see the color is orange for both
the div text
you can see it again we'll refresh this
page click on this click me button and
you can see the color is orange now
fine so this is how we can access all
the elements from an html file using the
element name only it is an alternative
to get element by tag name fine
now let's suppose we want to make
changes to a particular paragraph let's
say paragraph 1 only in javascript we
can do it with the help of
document.getelementbyid method in jquery
we can also use the id attribute to do
so so let's suppose we want to change
the font style of paragraph one only we
want to change it to italic so we'll do
it with the help of jquery so what we
have to do is we have to provide the
paragraph tag and id first so we'll move
to html file
here is the html file and this is the
paragraph one we'll use here id as
p1 for this paragraph
save it now
and now what we'll do is we'll comment
this piece of code and we'll write here
again
dollar so we are using the id attribute
so we have to use hash here we'll write
here p1 dot css is the action name
and inside this will write
font style
and the font style is going to be
italic
fine
so we have to close this bracket over
here
and we have to remove this bracket from
here fine the thing to notice here is we
have to include the hash symbol before
the id attribute while accessing any
particular id save it go to the browser
and click on the button over here and
you can see the font style of the
paragraph is changed to italic now see
the same thing we can do with get
element by id method as well it's
straightforward right now the question
is what if we have two elements with the
same id and we want to change the style
of both the elements in jquery it
doesn't work in that way so what we'll
do here is we'll move to a
html file and we'll give this paragraph
3 the same id so what we'll do is we'll
write here ids p1 save it now and let's
see if the font style for paragraph 3
changes or not on the button click
so on clicking the button over here you
can see the style does not change it
means that jquery needs the id to be
unique for each element fine so the
other alternative to do so is to use the
class attribute in place of id attribute
we'll do the same thing instead of using
id as p1 what we'll do is we'll write
here
class so let's say the class name is
para for paragraph one and for paragraph
three
we'll use the same class name we'll
write here para
now let's try to access both the
elements using jquery selectors so we'll
move to a javascript file again and
we'll comment this
statement and over here what we'll do is
we'll write here
dollar
element name so we have to write here
the class name with the dot symbol
then we'll write here
dot css
and we'll write here
fonts style as
italic
fine
now save it
click on the button over here and you
will be able to witness the change in
the web page so you can see it's not
working
we have done something wrong here
so
let's check it out once
we haven't saved the html file i guess
so we'll save the html file
we'll save the javascript file and we'll
click on this click me button you can
see the change in the web page now
now you can see how we are able to make
changes in both the paragraphs at the
same time so this is how we can use
jquery selector so what we'll do now is
we'll add another box here with
different content like let's say we are
adding a list of items or something so
for that we'll go to our html file and
we'll write here
after this div tag we'll create another
div tag so inside this particular div
tag what we are going to do is we are
going to provide the id as
let's say
div 3 to this particular div fine
now inside here what we'll do is we'll
use the unordered list and then we'll
use
list element fine so
here what we'll do is we'll write item
1 and we'll copy this piece of code
and paste it again for five times so
let's change the item name to item two
three four and
five save it and you can see here we
have a list of items on our web page so
let's style this div tag as well to look
almost the same as the other two
containers so what we'll do is we'll
move to our css file we'll copy this
piece of code for div one
and we are going to paste it here fine
so what we are doing is we are basically
using the same code we are styling the
element the same way we did for previous
two div tags fine save it now and here
you can see we have three boxes over
here we have three containers over here
the first two containers contain four
paragraphs and the last container
contains a list of items
now we are done with both html and css
parts so let's move on to the jquery
part now
now let's suppose we want to make
changes in the first two containers only
or in any two containers let's say we
want to change the background color of
the first container and the third
container to green
and we have used the same class for the
first and second container let's do one
thing we'll move to html file and you
can see over here we have the first div
tag with class as div with two v's and
then we have another div tag with the
same class so the third one does not
have any class for that right
so in that case we can't use the element
name to do so because if we use the
element name for making changes then
those changes will be visible in all the
three containers we can use the class
name but we have used the same class for
div1 and f2 so it's impossible
what we can do here is we can use the id
attribute because we have unique ids for
both the div text for div one and div
three
now jquery allows us to make the same
changes in one or more elements using
the id attribute only
so the task is simple what we have to do
is we have to go to a javascript file or
jquery file we can say we'll comment
this statement for now and we'll write
here dollar and inside brackets will
pass the id attribute so we'll write
here given comma
div
and
we have to put here the hash symbol
because it represents the id of any
element so we'll write here dot css and
inside this will write
background
color and the background color is going
to be
green
fine
that's it guys what we have to do is we
have to separate the ids with the comma
and we can make changes to several
elements at the same time
save it
and click on the button over the browser
so what we'll do is we'll reduce the
size a little bit so that both the
containers are visible so you can see
the first and the third containers have
same colors over here so let me first
change the color of the third container
we'll go here and we'll change the color
to let's say
gray fine save it and you can see all
these three containers has different
colors so what we'll do is we'll save
this piece of code and we'll click on
this click me button and you can see the
containers with id 1 and id 2 the color
is changed to green so what if we want
to do the same thing for the third
container and the first container so if
we write here div 3 instead of div 2
save it now click on the button and you
can see the color is changing for both
the containers so it's working totally
fine not only that but instead of using
multiple ids we can also use different
attributes at the same time like we can
use the class name and the element name
here as well so let's say if we write
here let's comment this piece of code as
well
and we'll write here in the next line
dollar
let's suppose we are writing here
given so this is the id for the first
container so we are using the hash
symbol so remember it is a id and right
here we are writing
li so li is the tag name and we are
using tag name over here so what we'll
do is we'll write here css
and then we'll
change the background color
and the background color is going to be
let's say purple fine so we are done
with it save it and click on the click
me button you can see
the color of both the elements changed
at the same time this is one of the
reasons to choose jquery it provides us
the ease to work on multiple attributes
at the same time the color of the first
container and the color of the list
elements changed simultaneously here
so we can also make changes to the
particular element present inside a
specific div tag for example let's say
we have two more paragraphs outside the
div tag so let's add them first and what
we'll do is we'll move to our html file
we'll copy this piece of code from here
and we'll paste it
here after the h1 tag
fine now what we'll do is we'll change
the paragraphs
so let's say the paragraph one says
this is paragraph one
outside
div tags fine
we'll do the same here as well we'll
write here outside
div tags save it now and you can see
over here we have two paragraphs over
here what we'll do is we'll remove the
second container from here
so let's do it
and save it now
we'll remove the styling as well for the
second container
save it now we have only two containers
over here and we have a click me button
fine
now what we want is we want to make some
changes to the paragraphs present inside
the first and the second containers we
can't use the element name because it
will make changes in all the paragraph
elements so what we can do here is we
can write here
we'll move to a javascript file and
we'll write here
dollar and inside this we'll write
div
greater than sign and we'll write here p
now we are going to use here
fate toggle
so what we did here is we asked jquery
to make changes to the paragraph
elements present inside the div tags we
have also used the fade toggle action
here to make it more clear to you guys
the syntax is simple we have to pass the
parent element with a greater than sign
and then the element name in which we
want to make changes so let's see if
this statement is working or not
save it move to the browser click on
this click me button and you can see the
paragraph is completely hidden
right you guys don't worry about the
actions for now because we'll cover them
in the upcoming videos although they are
not complicated but still if you are
thinking about them then don't worry we
are here to help you with that
this statement can also work without the
greater than sign just like it does in
the css properties so let's see if it
works or not after removing this greater
than sign save it now you can see the
paragraphs are here and we want to fade
them out on button click so click on
this click me button and you can see
it's working totally fine and if we
click on this click me button again you
can see the paragraphs are here
next up what if we want to access the
first paragraph only
now we are talking about this particular
paragraph so what if we want to access
it
we can't use any of the selectors we
have been through till now it does not
have any id or class and we can't use
the element name because that will make
changes in all the paragraph elements
for that what we have to do is we have
to write here
dollar
and after it will write
p
colon
first fine then we'll write here
fate toggle
and we'll call this function
so we are done with it this statement
will access the first paragraph element
from the whole html document
save it click on the button and you can
see on clicking the button the paragraph
one is completely hidden click on the
button again and the paragraph is here
again
but will it work the same way if we
write second in place of first like if
we only want to access the second
paragraph not the first one so let's try
doing it
and it will be easy for you to
understand so we'll write here second
now what we want is we want to access
this particular paragraph save the
program move to browser click on this
click me button and you can see it's not
working
you can go through the inspect elements
and you'll find an error over here
so if we go to console you can see it
says unsupported pseudo second so it
does not supports this so we can do it
for the first element present in the
html file only so we'll write here first
again
save it now and you can see it's working
now
we can do the same thing with the class
name id or the element name what else we
can do here is we can make changes in
the odd and even elements as well so
let's suppose we want to hide the list
item present at odd numbers for that we
have to write a simple code so what
we'll do is
we'll comment this as well because
if you want to check it later you can
check it from here that's why we are
commenting all the statements so what
we'll do here is we'll write here li and
we'll write here after colon even fine
then we'll write here
fade toggle
save it
click on the button over here
and the list elements present at 0 2 and
4 are gone because even numbers start
from 0
that's why the item 1 3 and 5 are gone
and the item 2 and 4 are present at odd
places now we can do the same thing for
odd elements as well so for that we have
to write here
odd in place of even save it now click
on the click me button and you can see
the items two and four are gone now of
course they'll reappear on the screen if
we click on the button again that's
because of the fade toggle method we
have used as we have completed
javascript before jquery so i hope you
guys must know by now the definition of
events so the simple explanation of an
event is something that happens
like when we manipulate an html document
in javascript we try to do something on
the web page right several events take
place on a website like
the user hovers over a specific elements
or click on an element pressing a key in
the website can also refer to an event
or submitting a form or playing a video
also refers to an event in a website so
this is the basic definition of events
so let's go through an example of
javascript events and we'll see what
they actually are
we'll create a button for calling an
event and then we'll do same sort of
stuff with jquery as well so let's do it
with javascript first so first of all
what we'll do is we'll write here
we'll add an image on our browser so
we'll write here img
src is equals to images the image is
present inside the images folder and the
image name is
j1.png
then we'll write here alt and alt is
going to be
javascript fine
let's give it
an id as well so we'll write here id as
img1 for this img tag and then we'll
create a button over here so we'll write
here button id is equals to let's say
btn
and then we have
on click event so we will call a
function on clicking the button so we'll
write here
function function and then we'll
close this tag so let's say the name of
this button is click
fine
we are done with it
save it so the image is quite large so
what we'll do here is we'll change the
size of this image so we'll write here
width is equals to let's say
250 pixels fine save it now and you can
see the image size is fine now so what
we did here was a primary task we have
added an image and we are calling a
function using the on click event it
means that if the user clicks on this
button then something will happen and
for now that something depends upon us
and we'll define it after this so
basically something will change in the
web page on button click fine so let's
define this function now first
so we'll move to a javascript file this
is our javascript file and we'll write
here
function
function fine so we have to define this
function so what we'll do is we'll write
here document
dot get element by id and id of images
image 1 i guess let's confirm it once so
the id of image tag is img1
and then we'll write here dot
style dot width so let's say we are
changing the width of this
image on
clicking the button so we'll write here
let's say 500 pixels fine this is the
size we want to change
save it now that's it so we are doing
all this to give you guys an idea of
what events are in jquery and how they
are different from events in javascript
so this button click over here is
basically an event if we move to html
file and see here so this on click over
here is
actually an event and this event will
call function1 so the function one we
have defined in a javascript file and
this function one will change the width
of this image fine i hope you guys
understood it
so what we'll do now is we'll save this
piece of code we'll go to the browser
and click on this button so click on it
and you can see the image size is large
fine you can refresh it you can click on
it and the image size is large we can
also revert the changes by creating
another function here like we'll write
here function funct2 and then we'll give
the original size and on clicking
another button the image will get back
to its original size so we can do it but
will not do it as of now
now
similar events are present in jquery as
well the events and functioning remain
the same the only thing that changes in
jquery events is the way of calling an
event so the syntax in jquery goes like
this
so what we'll do is we'll remove this on
click button from a html file
we'll remove this on click event from
here and now this button has an id btn
and it's actually a button and what
we'll do here is we'll comment this
piece of code
because we want you guys to see the
difference in
both events in javascript and jquery
now what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar
inside this will access our button so
we'll write here button button is the
element name we are not using the id
attribute here of course we can write
here hash btn as well so we'll write
here
dot
click and what we'll do is we'll create
a
function name so we will write here funk
one and the next thing we are going to
do here is we are going to create this
function we are going to write here
function func one
and the rest of the things will remain
the same so we'll write here dollar
will access the image so we'll write
here
hash img1
and then we'll write here dot css will
pass your
width
and the width is going to be
500 pixels fine
fine so we are done with it this click
function over here so if you see here
you can see this click is a function
basically so this click function over
here is actually a predefined function
in the jquery library that will be used
to perform a specific task on the web
page
save it
save the program now move to the browser
click on the button and you can see the
size is changing we can also use the
concept of anonymous function here in
place of creating a whole function like
if we don't want to write here func one
and then we don't want to create another
function what we can do here is we can
write here
dollar
button and then we'll write a dot
click
inside this will write function
this is the body of this function
we'll put semicolon over here and we'll
copy this statement from here fine
now comment this piece of code
and here we have used the concept of
anonymous function
fine it's quite simple so save it
and click on the button
you can see it's working totally fine so
this was just a tutorial of how we can
use events in jquery so this is
basically an introduction of events
now next up we'll be going through an
event that will be needing every time we
are using jquery so what we are going to
do is we are going to write here
dollar and we are going to access
document so this document refers to the
whole html document and then we'll write
here
ready and then we'll write here a
function so we'll
create a body of this function
now
the ready function will be called after
the html documents is fully loaded
what we want to do is we want to keep
the jquery part in a queue until the
document is being loaded so for example
let's say we have a big website with so
many buttons and different things
present inside it
now the button will perform some actions
on clicking right let's say the user's
internet speed is not adequate and the
button loads before anything else on the
web page it will affect us right like if
the user presses the button before
anything loads in the web page then
there's no way of writing any jquery for
that right we can't do anything for that
so what we want is we want the html
document to be loaded fully before the
jquery part works so for that we use the
ready event so ready is basically an
event in jquery
so make it a habit of using the ready
event guys it is considered a good habit
by programmers across the world so what
we have to do is we have to put
this code in a jquery part or javascript
part and then we have to write anything
inside of it so what we'll do is we'll
cut it from here we'll paste it here and
let's remove this for once so this is
how our javascript file will look like
after including the ready event in a
website so what we have to do basically
is we have to include the ready event in
our javascript file and then we have to
start writing code for other events as
well
we have been through certain types of
events in the previous part
we have an idea of how to call an event
in jquery and how to use the on click
event to manipulate the html element
so we'll use the same code in today's
video as we'll be going through some
more types of jquery events and you guys
will have an idea of several jquery
events by the end of this tutorial
so let's start with the first event of
the day if you guys ever notice that
some buttons work on double click only
in javascript we use on double click for
such events now jquery also supports
such events so in jquery instead of
using double click or on double click
what we have to do is we'll go to this
code and we'll write here
double click only that's it so this is
the event and this is the function we
have created so what will happen is on
double clicking this button this image
size will change to 500 pixels rest of
the part will remain the same now i
suggest you guys to watch the previous
part because we have been using the same
code so i hope you guys have watched
that part before going through this
video so what we did here was we changed
the name of click event to double click
only and the rest will remain the same
now save the program go to browser and
click on this button over here you can
see the button is not working on
clicking it now double click on it and
it's working totally fine right so this
is how we can use the double click
jquery event
now the following events we'll cover are
the mouse enter and mouse exit events if
you guys remember from the animations in
javascript video wherein we were
changing the animation on mouse over
then you must have noticed that we are
using the on mouse over and on mouse out
events right
so the same events with the same task we
have in jquery as well
the names are mouse enter and mouse
leave
so here the mouse enter event represent
the on mouse over event and the mouse
leave event represents the on mouse out
event
now the rest of the things will remain
the same what we'll do here is
let me just remove this piece of code
and we'll write this code again so we'll
write here dollar
and then we'll access our image so this
is the id of our image so we'll write a
hash
img1 and then we'll write here
mouse enter
and then we'll create a function over
here
so function totally depends upon us we
can create an anonymous function or we
can create a separate function as well
so what we'll do here is we'll write
here inside this function
dollar and will again access this image
so we'll write here img1
dot
css and then we'll pass the styles over
here we'll write here width and we'll
change the width of this image to
500 pixels
fine
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write the code for mouse leave event as
well so if you save this program for now
and you can go over here on the browser
and hover your mouse cursor over the
image you can see the size is changing
now what we'll do is we'll write the
code for mouse leave event as well so
for that we'll write here
dollar
and then we'll access the image again
we'll write a img1
dot
mouse leaf
and then we'll create a function over
here so we'll write here function and
the function will be responsible for the
change in size of this image so we'll
write here dollar
then we'll again access the
image so we'll write here img1
then we'll write here dot css and then
we'll write here
width
is going to be again to the default ones
so the default width is i guess 250
pixels let's check it out over here
so if you can see here the width of this
image is 250 pixels right so what we'll
do is
we are done with it we'll save this
program
and now go over to the browser you can
see that the image size increases on
taking the mouse cursor over it and the
image gets back to its original size on
taking the mouse cursor away from it so
simple and so easy right
now there exists a common event that can
act like both the mouse enter event and
the mouse leave event so the whole event
is used to do so it takes two arguments
and the rest will remain the same so
what we'll do is we'll comment this
piece of code for now and we'll write an
alternate code for this
so we'll write here
dollar and then we'll access the image
so we'll write here
hash one
and then we'll write here hover
we'll write here
funk one and
func two so these are the two functions
we are going to create so next up let's
create these functions so we'll write
your function
function this is our first function and
then inside this will write dollar
will access the image again so we'll
write here img1
dot css
dot
okay dot css then we'll write here width
and the width is going to be
let's suppose 500 pixels for on mouse
over event and then we'll create another
function over here we'll write your
function function
now inside the body of this function
what we are going to do is we are going
to copy this piece of code from here
and then we'll paste it here fine now
instead of 500 pixels we want the image
to get back to its original form so
we'll write here
250 pixels only
so here we are we are done with the
programming part
now save this program and you can see it
over here that we have the exact same
functionality like that of mouse enter
and mouse leave events so the whole
event works almost the same
now jquery consists of several events
and we have discussed some of them till
now so there are some more events like
the form events keyboard events and
scroll events as well we are not going
to discuss all these events because the
list is so long and i hope that you guys
must have got an idea about jquery
events by now
in layman terms an effect refers to an
event condition or state of affairs
produced by a cause for example we click
on a button on the website and suddenly
the image disappears this refers to the
fade in effect and then we click on
another button and the image is back the
fade out effect right we have been
through such effects and animations
previously in the javascript part as
well if you guys remember we have the
zoom in and zoom out effects as well
wherein we were clicking on a button and
the size of the image changes to large
and all of that stuff refers to effects
and animations i hope you guys must have
got an idea about what we'll be doing in
this particular video first of all we'll
add an image to a html file and then
we'll use different effects on that
particular image the task is
straightforward right so let's move on
to the programming part directly now
let's add an image over here on the
browser first we can create a container
as well but let's do it with images only
for now because it will be easy and more
understanding for you guys
so we'll go through the hide and show
effect first
so we'll add an image and three buttons
to our webpage one for hiding another
one for showing and
last one for both so you'll understand
it much better while working on them so
let's add the image and buttons over
here
we'll write here
img
src is going to be
images slash
j1.png
then we'll write here alt as
javascript so this is a basic image we
have in a images folder we'll write here
id as img1 for this image
and the width is let's say
250 pixels for this image fine
save this program and you can see the
image over here on the browser now the
next thing we are going to do is we are
going to add buttons as well so we'll
write here
button and let's say the id of this
button is going to be
btn1 for button one
we'll write here height
then we'll copy this statement from here
and we'll paste it three times
the button id is going to be two and
three
and the button name is going to be
show and
let's say the last button name is
toggle
fine
so here we are we have an image over
here and three buttons for different
tasks what we want is we want to hide
the image by clicking on the hide button
and we want the image to get back on the
web page by clicking on the show button
fine so what we'll do here is we'll use
the
br tag as well so we will write here
br twice and here you can see we have
three buttons over here let me zoom it
out a bit
so we have three buttons over here hide
show and toggle so these three buttons
have three different ids btn one two and
three and we have an image over here
fine
now let's move on to the jquery part and
we'll see how easy it is to perform such
tasks in jquery
so here is a javascript file and we have
the ready function over here already so
we'll write a code inside this
particular event only
now what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar
and then we'll write here
button one will access this button with
idbtn1
then we'll write here click click is the
event
and we'll write your function and the
function is going to be an anonymous
function fine next up we'll write a
dollar
then we'll access
the image with id as
img1 then we'll write here dot height
and that's it so what we did here was
easy we use the click event and hide
effect
hide here is actually a predefined
function in jquery that will make the
desired element completely hidden from
the web page so let's check the output
for this code first save the program
move to the browser
and click on the hide button over here
so you can see the image is completely
gone from the web page it's not present
here anymore
and you guys can see how easy it is to
perform such tasks in jquery because we
have a predefined function already
present in our jquery file isn't it
great we don't have to write long code
for a small task right all we need to do
is to write a single line of code and we
are good fine
so let's write the same code for the
show button as well now we need to
access the button with ids btn2 and the
action will change to show
so what we'll do here is we'll copy this
piece of code from here
and we'll paste it here again now
the next thing we'll be doing here is
we'll be changing the id to btn2
and the height function will change to
show here fine now save the program move
to the browser and you can see we have
both the buttons working over here if we
click on this hide button the image is
hidden and if we click on this show
button you can see the image is here
again so these two buttons are working
totally fine you can see
if we click on the show button the image
is back here again
now if we want this task to be performed
after 2 seconds let's say we can say we
want the image to take 2 seconds to hide
and we know that in javascript we can
use the set time interval method or the
set timeout method something like that
but in jquery we have an easy
alternative for this so what we have to
do is we have to write here
inside this height action we'll write
here 2000 similarly we'll do the same
thing for show as we will write here
2000 now 2000 here refers to two seconds
fine save the program click on the hide
button now and you can see the image is
taking two seconds to get completely
hidden similar thing will happen with
the show button as well if we click on
the show button you can see the image
takes two seconds for that as well
so it's working totally fine right it
seems like the fade in and fade out
effects but there is a difference
between this effect and the fade in and
fade out effect we'll go through it in a
moment for now what we'll do is we'll
add functionality to this toggle button
over here now this toggle button over
here has the capability to perform both
tasks using a single button what i mean
by that is we don't have to create two
separate buttons for hiding and showing
the image what we can do is we can also
use a single button for this task so
let's add functionality to this button
first and for that we'll write here
and the id for this toggle button is
hash btn3
then we'll write here dot click
and we are going to create an anonymous
function
now inside the body of this function
will again access the image
so we'll write here hash img1
then we'll write here dot
toggle fine
let's change the timing here let's say
we want this to take three seconds on
using the toggle button now save this
program click on the hide and show
button and you can see they are taking
two seconds to complete the task right
two seconds to hide the image and two
seconds to show the image again now the
toggle button will work differently but
the toggle button will do is on clicking
the toggle button it will take three
seconds to hide the image and if we
click on this button again you can see
after three seconds the image is back
here again
fine the toggle function over here is
written in such a way that it can
perform the tasks of both the height and
the shoe functions
the time we mentioned here totally
depends upon us so we can either use it
or we can leave it as well
now moving ahead we have another type of
effect present in jquery which acts
almost the same as the hide and show
functions but the animations is slightly
different
so we are talking about the fade in and
the fade out effects in jquery we'll go
through them now and we'll see the
difference between hide show toggle and
fade in fade out and fade toggle fine so
what we'll do is we'll add three more
buttons in a html file
so that we can witness the difference
between all of them so what we'll do is
we'll copy this piece of code from here
we'll paste it here
and we'll write here the button ids 4 5
and 6.
now the button names are going to be
fading and the second button is going to
be
fade out
and the last one is going to be
fade toggle fine
save the program and you can see we have
three more buttons over here now you
guys will get confused but don't worry
about it it's an easy task so what we'll
do now is we'll use jquery for fading in
and out this particular image
now the syntax will remain the same so
we'll move to a javascript file
and now what we'll do is we'll access
button four five and six which are fade
in fade out and fade toggle so we'll
write here
hash
btn 4
for the fade in button so we'll write
here dot
click
and on clicking we'll call an anonymous
function again
and then we'll access the image over
here so the image id is img1 then we'll
write here dot
fade in and we'll
pass the timestamp as well so let's say
the timestamp is 2000 for this fade in
function
fine
now we'll do the same for fade out as
well so we'll copy this from here we'll
paste it here
the button id is going to be 5 and
instead of fade in we have
fade out over here
fine so we have to write here fade out
with a capital o and fade in with a
capital i
now we have written the code for both
fade in and fade out buttons here so
that it will not create any sort of
confusion for you guys
the fade out effects work the same as
the hide effect and the fade in effect
works the same way as the show effect
fine
so save this piece of code click on
height and you can see these functions
are working totally fine
the hide and show buttons are working
totally fine now click on this fade out
button and you can see the image fading
out in two seconds
click on the fade in button and the
image is here back again after two
seconds
so these two buttons are working totally
fine
the fade toggle effect the last button
over here will write the code for this
button as well so this fit toggle effect
in jquery acts the same as the toggle
effect it can work like the fade in and
the fade out button so let's write the
code for that as well what we'll do is
we'll copy this piece of code from here
and we'll paste it here the button id is
6.
and instead of fade out
we'll write here
fit
toggle fine
now save this program
and you can see the button over here is
working totally fine on clicking fade
toggle the image fades away after two
seconds or we can say it's taking two
seconds to fade away and on clicking
this way toggle button again you can see
the image is here again
we can see the difference here as well
between the height show and fade in fade
out effects
the fade effect is different from the
other effect
the syntax although seems to be the same
and no significant differences in the
syntax and the working
the only different thing is the way of
achieving the desired effect you can see
the difference by clicking the button
you can see on clicking the hide effect
the animation is different from that in
fade in or fade out effect you can see
there is a difference of animations only
now let's move ahead and talk about
another effect in jquery the upcoming
effect we'll discuss is the slide effect
the syntax is same so let's go through
the slide effect quickly
now what we'll do is we'll add three
buttons and we'll discuss the slide
effect fine so what we'll do here is
let's remove these buttons
and
okay so let's do one thing let's remove
these three buttons and we'll write here
id is seven
eight and
nine
fine
and then we'll change the name of these
buttons so we'll write here
slide up
slide down
and
let's say
slide toggle fine now i hope you guys
must have understood the working of
slide toggle by now it will work in both
ways it will make the image slide up and
slide down at the same time by using a
single button so
don't worry about it we'll remove these
br tags from here and we'll paste them
here
save this program now and we have three
buttons over here slide up slide down
and slide toggle now what we'll do is
we'll remove this piece of code as well
i hope you guys must have got it by
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write the code for slide
effect
fine the syntax remains the same so we
will write here dollar
the button id is going to be btn7
for slide button for slide up button
we'll write here the click event and
we'll create a function over here fine
the task will remain the same we will
write here again
img1 will access this particular image
and will write here
slide up
we want this image to take two seconds
to slide up so we'll write here 2000 as
the timestamp
now save this program and click on the
slide up button over here
you can see the image sliding in the
upward direction right now what we'll do
is we'll write the code for slide down
and slide toggle as well
so we'll write here button
8 for slide down
will right here slide down instead of
slide up
and we'll write here slide
toggle fine we'll write here btn 9 for
slide toggle
save the program and you can see on the
browser that all the buttons are working
totally fine if we click on slide up
button the slide up button is working
fine the slide down button is also
working fine and if we click on the
slide toggle button you can see the
image is sliding up and down as well so
before wrapping up this video now let me
tell you guys about the stop method as
well so what we'll do is we'll add
another stop button on our webpage we'll
move to a html file
we'll copy this particular statement
from here
we'll change the name of this button to
stop
and the button add is going to be btn10
fine save this program now
we'll move to a javascript file and will
write here
dollar will access this stop button so
we'll write here hash btn10
dot click
and we'll create a function over here
now inside this function will write hash
img1
will access this image and then we'll
write here
dot stop so we are calling a function
over here so stop is a function
basically now save the program and move
to the browser now you can see if we
click on this stop button when the
effect is taking place
so if we click on this slide up button
and then in between we click on this
stop button you can see the difference
over here we can slide down the image
from here and
we can do the same thing
with the stop button so what stop button
is doing is it stops the effect in
between
right
you can see all the buttons over here
are working totally fine
and we can
stop this effect in between right
so this is why we use jquery for such
tedious tasks a single line of code can
do it so quickly and so easily we have
been using these effects to make our web
pages more interactive right
now this animate effect we'll use in
today's video is a bit different from
these effects the animate effect uses
css properties and it can be used to
make an image or an object like a
rectangle or something move across the
web page in a particular manner
seems confusing right so let's start
writing the code and everything will be
clear to you guys we'll be using an
image for this task so let's remove all
this code from here first we'll write
the code again
now we'll remove this code from here
and we'll write the code again so let's
add the image over here and then we'll
style that image using the style tag
only so we will write here
div will be using a container for this
inside this will write img
now src is going to be images
slash
j1.png so we'll be using the same image
for this task
then we'll write here alt
so let's say we are writing here
something and then we'll write here ids
img let's say fine
let's close this image tag save the
program now and you can see the image
over here the image size is quite large
we can reduce the size of a chrome
browser so you can see this is the image
now what we'll do next is we'll style
this image using the style tag so let's
style this image as well here we'll move
to a head tag and we'll write here
style
fine
now inside the style tag we'll access
this image using the image id so id for
this image is img we'll write a hash img
and then inside this will write some
properties over here
so let's define the height of this image
first
let's say the height is going to be 250
pixels then we'll write here
width as well so let's say the width is
again 250 pixels
and we'll use opacity over here fine
we'll write here opacity is equals to
let's say 0.4
we'll discuss it later why we are using
opacity here
now the last thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here position as
absolute
so opacity here will define the fading
effect of this image save this program
and you can see it here on the browser
we have a picture with an opacity of 0.4
it's obviously different from the actual
image let's increase the size of this
image for now
so here is the image
now the next thing we'll be doing is
we'll be adding a button over here to
call the animate effect for that we'll
write here after this
button and the button id is going to be
let's say btn
then we'll write here the name of our
button is let's say animate
save this piece of code and you can see
we have the animate button over here
we'll use the br tag to create some
distance between the button and the
image so save this program and you can
see over here that we have a button and
an image
now we'll use the animate effect to make
this picture move across the browser or
we can say across the container
so we'll use the click event for the
animate button
now let's move on to the jquery part
here we are in the jquery part we'll
remove this piece of code and now we'll
try to access this animate button using
the button id fine so for that we'll
write here dollar
inside this will write
btn so this is our button id
and then we'll write here dot click we
are going to use the click event over
here
then we'll create an anonymous function
this task is easy and here we are we
have used the click event here so the
next thing we'll be doing is to use the
animate effect now so for that we'll
write here
dollar now we are going to use this
animate effect over a image so the image
id is img and then we'll write here dot
animate
and we'll leave it for now
now this animate effect over here has
three different parameters the first one
are going to be the css properties the
style changes we are going to create on
a picture so we'll write those changes
inside the curly braces the second
parameter is the timestamp
and let's say we are using 2000 over
here so 2000 over here is the
milliseconds
now the third parameter which is the
callback we'll be discussing callback in
the upcoming videos for now we'll use
these two parameters only
now let's move ahead and we'll write the
css properties here inside these curly
braces
so we'll
write over here let's say we are writing
here left
and we'll write here left as
150 pixels fine
now this left property over here will
take the image 150 pixels away from the
left side of the container
so save this program and now you can
witness the changes on this web page
click on the animate button
and you can see the image slides over to
the right corner the animation takes two
seconds to complete because we have
given the timestamp here as 2000
milliseconds
let's reduce the size of this chrome
browser a bit and now you can see it
properly refresh the page and we'll
click on this animate button and you can
see the image slides over the effect is
working fine let's make some more
changes to this image style by clicking
the animate button
all we have to do is to add some more
css properties to this animate effect
and for that we'll write here some more
properties with the help of commas only
so we'll put a comma over here and we'll
write here let's say
opacity so we'll change the opacity of
this image to
1 then we'll again use the comma and
change the height and width as well so
let's say the height is going to be 400
pixels
and then we'll write here width as well
fine so width is going to be again 400
pixels
so we are done with it now the height
and width of this image will change to
400 pixels along with the opacity
changing to one
it means that the image will be
completely opaque after clicking on the
animate button save this program now and
move to the browser click on the animate
button here to see the magic now
you can see the size of the image
increasing gradually here in 2 seconds
however this animate method does not
have any toggle function though so we
can't retrieve the changes just by
clicking on the button again let me
reduce the size a bit more so that it
will be easy for you guys to understand
this effect
here we are we have this effect click on
the animate button and you can see the
change now
from opacity as 0.4 to opacity as 1.
there are some changes in the animations
right so this is what animate effect
does in jquery
now instead of writing here 2000 what we
can do is we can write here slow or fast
so let's try doing it as well what we'll
do is we'll write here instead of 2000
we'll write here slow for now so we'll
write here slow save this program click
on the animate button again and you can
see the change so it's not taking two
seconds anymore now the slow keyword
will work and the animation effect will
change fine
so that's all that we have to discuss in
this animate effect guys
the task for you is to create another
button over here to revert the changes
and make the image get back to its
original form a very simple and easy
task right try doing it guys and let us
know if you face any sort of problem let
me give you guys an introduction to
callbacks first a callback function is a
function that is passed to another
function as an argument
and that particular function will get
executed later on
it means that if we want to perform more
than one task at a time then we have the
concept of a callback function to
achieve it
for example if we have an image and we
want to apply more than one effect on
that picture but the thing is
we want the second effect only after the
first one completes then in that case we
have to create a callback function that
will be called only after the first
effect is done you guys will get it once
we go through the programming part so
let's move on to the programming part
directly without wasting any time
now here we have the code from the
previous part wherein we use the animate
effect to make changes in our image by
clicking on the animate button
the image height width and opacity will
change by clicking this animate button
if we click on it you can see the image
size changes along with the opacity as
well
we discussed previously while working on
the animate effects that this animate
effect usually takes three different
parameters one for the css properties
the other is the timestamp and the last
remaining is the callback function
let's say we want to perform another
task after the animate effect takes
place a simple one like let's print a
message first on the screen by using the
alert method
so what we'll do is we'll move to a
javascript file
and here we are in a javascript file and
we'll write here
after this slow we'll write here alert
and then we'll pass
let's say
animated over here fine
what we did here is we put a statement
to get processed after the animate
effect right
we are expecting the animation to take
place first and then we get a pop-up
with the message animated the reality is
going to be different now save this
program
move to the browser click on this
animate button over here and you can see
the message popping up even before the
animation takes place although jquery
processes the code line by line but when
it comes to effects it performs the
later task if the current one is taking
time
there is nothing wrong with this program
but we can use the callback function to
make it work more properly
now a callback function is like we are
asking the system to wait for the
current task to complete and then
execute another task
so let me take you through the syntax of
this animate effect once again so that
it will not create any sort of confusion
what we'll do is we'll write here the
syntax
will comment it out
now the animate effect takes three
parameters right the syntax goes like
this we write dollar then we have
bracket and we try to access the element
right so let's say we have the ids img
here then we'll write here animate
and
animate is basically of method right
now inside this we'll write a pair of
curly braces comma
time stamp and we have another thing
over here so what we'll do is we'll
write here function for now
and this is the correct syntax of
animate effect with all the three
parameters
now the curly braces over here are for
the css properties as we know
then we have the time stamp and the last
function over here is the callback
function now whatever task we want to
perform after the animate effect takes
place is what we'll be writing inside
this callback function for now let's say
we want to print this message on the
screen after the animation takes place
so for that we'll create an anonymous
function after this time stamp in the
animate method what we'll do is
we'll remove this piece of code from
here and
here we have to add another argument so
this whole thing lies inside the animate
method now we have to pass another
argument over here so what we'll do is
we'll write here function
and
this is going to be an anonymous
function now what we want is
we want to print a message after the
animation takes place right so we'll
write here alert
and then we'll write here
let's say
animated fine now save this program and
move on to the browser
click on the button over here and you
can see the animation will take place
followed by the pop-up message i hope
you guys have got an idea of what
callbacks are and how to use them
right callbacks are not used with the
animate method only instead we can use
callbacks for other methods as well so
let's try to use it with the slide up
and the slide down animation effect what
we'll do is we'll access the same image
using click event and for that what
we'll do is we'll remove this piece of
code from here
and we'll start writing the code again
so we'll write here dollar and then
we'll
access the button so for that we have to
write here hash btn as btn is the id for
animate button then we'll write here
click click is the event
and then we'll create a
function inside it fine
so this is the body of this function and
now inside this function what we'll do
is we'll again try to access the image
to make animation changes over it so
we'll write here dollar then we'll write
here hash img
the id of our image then we'll write
here
slide up and we'll
write a let's say 2000 as the timestamp
and after this we'll create a callback
function so for that we'll write here
function
and inside the body of this function
what we'll do is we'll access the same
image but this time we'll do it with
slide down effect fine so we'll write
here dollar
then we'll again access this particular
image
we'll write here dot slide down
and we are good to go fine what we did
here was quite understandable if you
didn't understand let me tell you again
that we have used the slide up effect
and then we are trying to slide down
that image right after the slide up
effect occurs
so let's check it out if it's working or
not save it and move on to the browser
click on the animate button over here
and you can see that this image slides
up in two seconds and right after it the
slide down effect is taking place we can
also make the slide down effect work for
two seconds by giving the time stamp
over here if we write here 2000
then both the effects will take two
seconds to complete click on the animate
button and you can see both the
animations are taking two seconds now
now let's move ahead to jquery chaining
so chaining in jquery allows us to run
multiple methods within a single
statement for example we can chain more
than one effect or method to a single
html element
in chaining if one task takes some time
to complete the following process could
execute before completion so let's go
through the syntax one and you guys will
understand it what we'll do is
we'll remove this piece of code from
here
now we have a button click event over
here inside this will write
dollar
will again access this image we'll write
here hash img
then we have the slide up effect so
we'll write here slide up
and we'll pass the
time is 2000 milliseconds over here then
we'll write here dot and we'll write
here slide down
so what we did here is we changed two
different effects which in slide up and
slide down
so let's write here the timestamp as
well let's say we are writing here 3000
for now
now you will not spot any difference
here though we have changed two effects
here the slide down effect will take
place right after the slide up effect
save this program and try running it you
can see the opacity changing before the
slide up effect takes place so this is
the difference between chaining and
callbacks in jquery guys
we can change as many effects as we want
so if we write here
let's say
dot
fade in and we'll write here 2000
then we'll write here dot
okay let's call the fade out effect
first so we'll write here fade out and
then we'll write here fade in
and we'll write here 2000 again
so we'll change this to 2000 as well
and we have five different effects over
here we have slide up css slide down
fade out and fade in fine
save the program and try running it now
you can see on clicking the animate
button we have four different effects
working together we have slide up slide
down fade out and fade in all working on
time
right before we move on to dom
manipulation in jquery let's recall the
definition of dom
dom stands for document object model and
it defines the whole html document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for javascript or jquery
so that other functions can work over it
it represents the entire document in the
form of objects and nodes whether it be
elements or tags or anything in the
document stored in the document object
model
the entire page content can be accessed
or manipulated by using javascript or
jquery you can go through the dom
manipulation video and you will find it
in the playlist
now that we have enough knowledge about
the document object model we'll start
writing the html code and then we'll try
to access that html document with the
help of
jquery so let's start this video and
we'll add a simple and small box over
here with some text present inside and
outside of it
so what we'll do is we'll write here
inside the html document
we'll write here let's say
we'll use the h2 tag and we'll write
inside it
click
on the
button present below so this is some
text we have been adding here so save it
and you can see the text on the browser
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to use the span tag over
here so we'll write here span
and then we'll use id is equals to let's
say span one
and we'll leave this stack for now i'll
tell you why we are doing so
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to add a container over here
inside which we are going to add a box
so we'll write here for that
div and then we'll use the class
attribute the class is going to be let's
say
div one
and then we'll write here style as
background color and the background
color is going to be let's say
aquamarine fine so we'll close this div
tag over here now inside this div tag
what we'll do is
we'll write some more code over here so
we'll add a paragraph over here we'll
write here p and the class is going to
be p 1 for this paragraph 10.
now we'll close this and inside this
paragraph tag let's say we are writing
this is
box 1 fine
we are done with it the last thing we
are going to do is we are going to add a
button over here we will write here
button and id is going to be
btn1 for this button
then we will close it and will write the
button name so lets say the button name
is click me
fine
what we did here was an easy task right
we have been doing it all the time
although there is a specific reason for
using class here in place of id for the
paragraph tag and for the division tag
save this piece of code and you can see
this is a division inside which we have
a paragraph over here which says this is
box one and then we have a button over
here now let's style these elements for
now to make it look more cleaner so
we'll style these elements here only
with the help of a style tag
so for that we'll move to a head section
and we'll write here style
so
inside this style tag what we'll do is
we'll start styling our elements so
first of all we'll write here div one
will start with the box so we'll write
here height as
let's say 250 pixels
then we'll write your width as 250
pixels again
then we'll write here border
and the border is going to be let's say
5 pixel thick solid and
black in color fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to write here margin margin is
going to be let's say
50 pixels
and the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write your font size as
extra extra large
and then we'll write here
font
weight so the font weight is going to be
bolder
and the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to style a paragraph so
we'll write here dot p1 and then we'll
write here
text align at the center
and margin is going to be
let's say 100 pixels fine save this and
you can see we have a box over here with
some text present inside it the text
says this is box one
now let's move on to the jquery part and
we'll see what else we can do with these
elements now so here is a javascript
file we'll write a jquery code right
over here
so let's discuss what manipulation is
before we start manipulating the html
document
manipulate refers to control something
with skills right
we want to control our html document on
certain events we ain't going to try
something new or something different
so we'll use methods to do so
these methods are predefined in jquery
and all we have to do is to use them
with the correct syntax that's it we'll
be good to go
now let's try to access the text present
inside the box first what we'll do is
we'll get the text from the box and then
try to print this text on the screen
with the help of
jquery method
so we'll write here
dollar then we'll access the division so
for that we'll write here dot div one
because this is the class name for a box
then we'll use event over here so we'll
write here click and then we'll create
an anonymous function
so this is our function inside this
we'll write
let's say where x will hold the value of
the text then we'll write here dollar
will access the paragraph with class p1
then we'll write here dot html so html
here is the method then we'll
write here dollar and we'll try to
access span tag so we'll write a hash
span 1
then we'll write your dot text and we'll
pass x over here fine
now over here what we did is we use the
html tag to access the text present
inside the paragraph tag
the html method gets the html content or
we can say the inner html of the matched
element
next up we are using the text method to
print the message on screen so the span
tag here inside the html document you
can see it over here we have kept it
empty on purpose
because we want to print this particular
text inside the spam tag that's why we
left it empty over there now let's save
this program and try to run it fine
so you can see the text here on the
screen on clicking the box you can see
here this is box one present inside the
span tag
fine now there is a difference between
the html method and the text method so
we'll see it now
what we'll do is we'll write here
we'll remove this piece of code or we'll
just comment it out fine so that it will
be easy for you guys to understand later
now what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar
then we'll again try to access this
division so we'll write here dot div one
then we'll write here dot
click
and we'll create a function over here
fine
so this is an anonymous function and
inside it will write
alert
we'll try to access a paragraph tag so
for that we'll write here
dollar and inside this will access p1
so we'll access our paragraph and then
we'll write here
dot html fine
now this html method will give us the
text present inside the element with
class as p1
but there will be a difference so before
that what we'll do is we'll move to html
file and make some changes over here
so we'll insert an i tag somewhere
inside this paragraph what we'll do is
we'll write here i over here
and we'll put box one inside the i tag
so it will change the style a bit it
will change box one to italic and rest
of the thing will remain the same save
the program now and you can see the
change in the box here there is some
italic text present in between the
paragraph
now click on the image
and you can see we have an alert box
over here if you can see here we have
the alert box and the italic tag is
clearly visible the html method gives us
the whole thing present inside a
particular tag you can see it over here
it says
this is then it has i tag box one and
then i tech clues so this is how the
html method in jquery actually works
now if we use the text method here in
place of the html method the scenario
will change so let's try to do it as
well what we'll do is we'll write here
text in place of html save this program
click on the image over here and you can
see the text here inside the alert box
it's the plain text over here you can
see it says this is box one only so guys
this is the difference between the html
method and the text method so i hope you
guys understood the next method we are
going to discuss here is the attribute
method this method helps us in getting
the attributes value or we can also
change the attribute value as well
so let's say we want to know the id of
this particular paragraph text
what we can do here is we can write here
so let's comment this piece of code as
well first and then we'll write here
dollar then we'll again access the
paragraph so for that we have class as
p1
then we'll write here click
and then we'll create a function over
here
fine
now inside this what we'll do is we'll
use the alert method again inside this
we'll write
dollar and then we'll write here
dot
p1
then we'll write here dot attr so attr
is the short form of attribute method
then we'll write here
let's say class fine
save this piece of code go to the
browser click on the box and you can see
it says p1 over here this is a class
name we can't change this class name for
now so what we'll do is we'll move to a
html file and we'll give an id over here
to the paragraph tag as well so let's
say we are writing here id as
id
p1
now this is the id of our paragraph type
save this piece of code
move to the jquery file and now we'll
try to access the id over here so we'll
write here id save the program click on
the box over here and you can say the id
is id p1 fine
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to change this id fine
so what we'll do is we'll change the id
of this paragraph tag on button click on
this button click fine what we'll do is
we'll write here before this piece of
code
we'll write here
dollar and then we'll try to access the
button so the id for a button is btn1
then we'll write here dot click and
we'll create a function over here fine
now inside this function we'll write
dollar and then we'll write here
the class name as p1
and after this we'll write here dot attr
will write here
id so we want to change the id the next
parameter is going to be the new id so
we will write here inside double
inverted commas idp 2 or we can say we
can write here p2id fine so
that there will be no confusion for you
guys
now save this program so let's check it
out if it's working or not click on the
box you can see it says id p1 right this
is the id and this function is currently
working
now click on the button over here you
can see we have clicked on this button
now click on the box again and you can
see it says p2 id the id of this
paragraph tag is changed we can do it
with the help of attribute method only
this method is useful if we want to
change the style or something of any
element or we want to change something
inside an element
so this method is simple and easy you
guys can do it by yourself as well now
the next method is the css method we
have been using this method since we
started the jquery part right so we can
get the css properties of any element
with the help of this property
what we have to do is
we have to comment this piece of code
first so we'll comment it out first and
we will write here
now what we want to do is we want to
access the css property of any html
element so we'll write here
dollar
will try to access the css property of
this box so we will write here dot
d1 this is the class of our box then
we'll write here click again this is an
event we'll write your function
and inside this function what we'll do
is we'll write a code
now we'll write here alert we'll use the
alert method so we are trying to display
the properties of this box inside the
alert method what we'll do is we'll
write here dollar
then inside this will write
dot
div one
and after this we'll write dot css and
we want to know let's say the background
color of this box fine so we'll write
here
background color so this code over here
will return the rgb value of the
background color of the box save the
program and click on the box
you can see we have the rgb value as one
two seven comma two five five comma two
one two this is the rgb value of
aquamarine color
of course we can change this property as
well we can change the background color
on button click so we'll do this again
what we'll do is
we'll write here before this piece of
code
dollar and we'll again access the button
we'll write here hash btn1
then we'll write here click
and we'll create a function
fine
now inside this we'll write
dollar
then we'll again access the division so
we'll write here dot dav1
then we'll write here dot css and we
want to change
the background color fine
now the background color is going to be
let's say
green
so we did it here we want to change the
background color so we have the first
argument as the css property which is
background color and the second argument
is going to be the change so we want to
change the color to green
now
what we'll do is we'll save this piece
of code and you can see the color is
changing to green on clicking the button
over here if we click on this box again
you can see the rgb value is also
changed now
you can see the rgb value is 0 comma 1
to 8 comma 0 which is the rgb value of
green color
we can make certain styling changes to
html elements using this method like we
can change the font style font color or
basically we can change any css property
using this css method the first method
we are going to discuss is the append
method
the append method is used to append
something inside a particular element
let's say we want to add something
inside this box after paragraph 1.
let's say we want to add an image or
some text or anything we can add for
doing such tasks we have the append
method and the prepend method so both
these methods work within a particular
tag it means that if we are using the
append method then it will add something
inside the specific box only not outside
of it the same goes with the prepend
method as well so let's see how these
methods actually work in jquery what
we'll do is we'll add another paragraph
over here inside the box but this time
we'll use jquery for that so we'll move
to a javascript file here's a javascript
file we'll comment this piece of code as
well
or let's say let's remove this piece of
code you can get this code from the last
part
what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar then we'll try to access this
button over here so we'll write here
button one this is the id of a button
then we'll write here click
and we'll create a function over here
find an anonymous function
so this is a function now inside of this
function what we'll do is we'll use the
append method within the div tag so
we'll write here dollar then we'll try
to access the div tag with class as div
one and the next thing we are going to
do is we are going to use the append
method so we'll write here append and
inside of it
we'll write here inside double quotes
p p stands for paragraph tag we have to
write the html part over here
now inside this we'll write
this is
paragraph 2. we can also write here this
is box 2. it totally depends upon us we
what we want to write now this will add
a paragraph inside this box save the
program
click on the button over here and
you can see a paragraph present inside
the box over here you can see the
paragraph says this is paragraph
two
similarly we can add images or anything
here in place of the second paragraph
all we have to do is to pass the html
code here as a parameter to this append
method
for example let's say we want to add an
image over here so for that what we'll
do is we'll write here
we'll copy this piece of code from here
and we'll paste it here fine we'll
comment this piece of code for now
because we are adding images so we'll
comment it out now inside here what
we'll do is
instead of passing this paragraph tag
over here what we'll do is
we'll write here
the img text so we'll write here img src
is equals to let's say images slash
j1.png
and then we'll write here
okay we have to put this inside double
quotes so then we'll write here
height let's define the height and width
as well so we'll
define the height as let's say 100
pixels
and we'll define the width as well so
we'll write here width is equals to
100 pixels fine so here is a code
now we have to close this image tag over
here so we are done with it
now keep one thing in mind guys that if
we want to use double inverted commas
within the html tags like we are using
double inverted commas for height and
for image
source as well so in that case we have
to use single quotes to pass the element
as the parameter just keep this thing in
mind otherwise jquery will not work so
save this program for now
and click on the button over here you
can see on clicking the button we have
an image over here inside the box it's
not totally inside the box because we
have used some styling for this box as
well so we have to style this box as
well for that we can pass the id over
here as well and then we can define
those properties inside the css file
with that particular id
fine
i hope you guys can do it by yourself
now the following method is the prepend
method that does the same task but it
adds the element at the beginning of the
box fine so what we'll do is we'll
create a button for prepend over here
first so we'll
copy this piece of code
we'll paste it here we'll change the
button id to btn2 and we'll change the
name to
prepend fine
let's change this name to append as well
so we'll write here append
save it now you can see we have two
buttons over here one for append and the
other one is for prepared fine now we'll
add some text before the paragraph so
what we want to do is we want to add
some text before this paragraph
somewhere here inside the box so for
that we have to use the prepend method
the syntax remains the same so what we
have to do is
we have to again write here dollar
then we have to access the prepend
button so for that we have the button id
as btn2 then we'll write here dot click
and then we'll create a
function over here fine now inside this
function will again access the division
so we'll write here
again dot div one
now instead of append we'll write here
prepend fine as we want to add a
paragraph over here so what we can do
here is we can write here inside double
quotes p
and then we have to close this as well
so
now we'll write here this
is
paragraph two using
pre-pinned fine save it now click on the
button over here click on prepared you
can see we have this is paragraph two
using prepend over here inside the box
and this is present before the actual
paragraph we can also use the append
method so if we click on this append
button you can see we have an image but
this image is outside of the box this is
because of the css properties
so what we can do is we can remove some
of the css properties from here and it
will work fine i guess
so we'll remove these properties from
here
now let's see if it's working or not
save it now
click on append you can see the image
inside the box after this paragraph and
click on prepend you can see we have a
paragraph over here
and it says this is paragraph two using
prepend remove this margin top as well
save the program now and now i guess it
will work fine click on append you can
see we have an image over here after
this paragraph click on prepend and you
can see we have a paragraph over here
fine so here we can use both the append
and the prepend method simultaneously to
add anything to our html element
now the next two methods are the after
and before methods both these methods do
the same task but the only difference is
these methods do such tasks outside of
the element for example the after method
will add a paragraph but the location of
the paragraph will be outside of the box
fine
so the syntax is also simple so let's
add the buttons over here for
after and before method so what we'll do
is we'll copy this piece of code from
here
and we'll paste it here so we have two
more buttons we'll write here
before and then we'll write here
after we'll change the button ids as
well so instead of one and two we'll
write here btn3 and btn4 will save it
and you can see we have four buttons
over here fine
what we'll do is we'll
use the br tag over here to make it more
clear so you can see now we have append
prepend before and after so we'll write
the code for before and after now so
what we'll do here is
we'll use these buttons to add text to a
html file so for that we'll write here
dollar
and then we'll again access
btn3
for
the before method so we'll write here
function
and we'll create an anonymous function
now we'll do the same task we'll write
here dollar and then we'll access the
division we'll write a div one then
we'll use the
before method for before button so we'll
add a paragraph over here so what we'll
do is we'll copy this from here so we
will add the same paragraph
we'll make some changes so we'll paste
it here and
we'll
write
using before over here fine we'll do the
same thing for after as well we'll copy
this piece of code
we'll paste it here and instead of 3 the
button id is 4 and instead of before we
have to write here after
fine we'll change the text as well we'll
write here after and
now we are good to go save this piece of
code
move on to the browser and click on
before button
you can see it's not working as of now
so there's something wrong okay we have
an error over here so
what we did wrong is
we have an extra pair of these brackets
over here save it now click on the
before button you can see we have a
paragraph over here which says this is
paragraph two using before so this is
the result of before method and if we
click on after button you can see the
paragraph after the box these paragraphs
are not present inside the box if you
want to use the append method you can
see on clicking the append button
the text or the image is present inside
of the box after a particular paragraph
and on clicking the prepend button the
paragraph is present inside the box only
so this is the difference between append
prepend and before after methods in
jquery i hope you guys should have got
the difference between the append method
and after method as well as the prepend
and before method as well so let's move
ahead and we'll discuss two more methods
now the remove method and the empty
method
the remove method is used to remove any
tag from the html document like if we
write here so let's add the buttons for
these methods first what we'll do is
we'll copy this from here and we'll add
two more buttons fine
we'll add the buttons after using br
tags so the button ids will change to
five and six
and the button names is going to be
remove and
empty fine
save it and you can see we have two more
buttons over here remove and empty will
again use the br tag over here to make
it more clear
save it and you can see we have six
buttons now the remove and empty buttons
are not working as of now so let's write
the code for these buttons as well
now what we'll do is we'll remove this
whole box from the screen on clicking
the remove button so for that we have to
write here
dollar we have to access the remove
button so we will use the id over here
the id is 5 then we'll write here again
click
this thing remains the same every time
we use jquery so the next thing we are
going to do is we are again going to use
the
div class so we'll write here div one
and then we'll write here remove fine
we have to create a method remove and we
are good too so save this program and
click on the remove button over here and
you guys can see the whole box is
completely gone however the empty method
works a bit differently from the remove
method it makes an element empty without
deleting the html element it will remove
the paragraph but the box will remain
there so let's write the code for empty
method as well what we'll do is we'll
copy this piece of code from here we'll
paste it here we'll change the button id
to 6
and instead of using the remove method
we'll use the
empty method fine
save this program you can see on
clicking the remove button the box is
completely gone and on clicking the
empty button the paragraph is gone but
the box is still here
fine
so this is the difference between the
remove and the empty methods in jquery
jquery ui is an open source javascript
library built on the top of jquery
library
so let's go through the website for
jquery ui and the rest will discuss over
there only
what we'll do is we'll go to chrome and
we'll write here jquery ui press enter
and click on the first link
so here we are on the website of jquery
ui where we have several options present
whether it be downloading jquery or we
can also glance through the website to
know more about the new features added
to jquery ui you can see over here if i
zoom it out a bit you can see it's
written over here that jquery ui is a
curated set of user interface
interactions effects widgets and themes
built on top of the jquery javascript
library
whether you are building a highly
interactive web applications
or you just need to add a date picker to
a form control jquery ui is the perfect
choice it basically contains several
interfaces effects widgets and much more
things that make jquery ui
quite helpful and essential for making
our web page more interactive all these
effects widgets and interfaces are
predefined in jquery ui all we have to
do is to use them with the correct
syntax and we are good to go you can see
over here if we click on these draggable
dropable or any of these interactions
click on it and you can see we have a
box over here we can drag it around we
have the source code for this and we
have to write this code to make a box
movable around the screen so this is why
we use jquery ui or jquery ui allows us
to do such tasks more easily than
javascript or jquery so let's move ahead
and we can also go through the about
section over here if we click on about
over here
and if we want to know more about jquery
ui you can see all the goals and visions
behind creating jquery ui and all
it is an open source and transparent
library it means that all the members in
the community whether it be developers
designers or experts or managers anyone
in the community is free to connect with
the jquery t if you scroll down you can
see the list of all the prominent
contributors here all of them gave
something to jquery ui in different ways
now let's move ahead to the downloading
part and we'll download the jquery file
and open the rar file so we have to
extract this file in the same folder
wherein we are saving our jquery related
programs what we'll do is we'll save all
the files inside a new folder and we'll
name it jquery ui
fine so what we'll do is we'll move to
the home page and
you can see over here we have this table
version or we have the old and
unsupported versions as well this jquery
1.8 is the stable version we'll click on
it
and it will automatically download so
here you can see we have winrar over
here it is a rar file now what we have
to do is we have to extract this file
fine so we'll extract it
we'll go to jquery we'll create a new
folder we'll name it as
jquery
ui and we are good to go we'll click on
ok
and the file is now extracted you can
check it by going through the same
folder
so what we'll do is we'll close this
winrar now the only task left now is to
add these files inside our html files so
we'll add all the required files and
let's quickly take a look inside the
jquery ui folder and see what we have
here
fine we'll move to a jquery ui folder
so here is a jquery ui folder inside the
jquery folder
this is the jquery ui and
inside this what we will do is
we'll create a single folder so we'll
cut all these files from here
and we'll paste them here
fine we'll delete this particular folder
now here we are inside the jquery ui
folder you can see we have external and
images we have two more folders over
here the external folder contains the
jquery file and the images folder have
certain images over here you can see
these all are icons
now we have these
css files over here we have the jquery
js file as well we have jquery ui.js
file as well and we have all the
minified versions as well now the reason
behind having a lot of external css
files and images over here is
jquery ui consists of widgets and user
interfaces that's why it requires some
external css files and images to make it
work more efficiently
now the plain jquery library is plain
javascript but jquery ui consists of
some images and css files as well so
let's add these files to our html file
now what we'll do is we'll open vs code
and chrome browser side by side so here
is the result of our first program
now what we'll do is we'll add these
files inside a html file so first of all
we have to include the javascript file
but for that what we'll do is we'll
write here
script and then we'll write it src is
going to be
jquery
and let's check out the name of that
folder again so here you can see we have
the folder name as jquery
hyphen ui so we'll write a jquery ui
slash and inside this
we'll add this particular file we'll add
jquery ui.js because we want to include
the javascript file right so we'll write
here type is equals
to text
slash javascript
and we are good to go close the script
tag save it and we have added the
javascript file over here now we have to
include some more files to use jquery ui
completely
in particularly the css files now the
question in your mind may come what are
these other files used for right these
files are the minified versions of same
jquery and css files smaller in size but
the working remains almost the same so
what we'll do is we'll add the css files
as well over here for that we'll move to
a head section and we'll write here
link
rel
and inside this will write jquery dash
ui
slash now we have to include three files
over here the first file name is
jquery ui.css so we'll write here
jquery okay what we'll do is we'll write
here
rel then we'll write a style
sheet and will pass
the source inside href so we'll write
here
jquery ui
slash
then we'll write here jquery ui dot
css so we'll write here jquery
ui dot
css now we have included
one file over here
we'll close this
link tag
and we'll copy this as well fine to add
other two files so we'll
copy it from here and we'll paste it
here
twice fine
now we have three css files over here
we'll change the names so the first one
is jquery ui the second one is
jquery
ui.structures.css so we'll write here
structure
dot css
and
the last file is jquery ui dot
theme dot css fine
so we have added all the required files
to our html file now we don't need any
more files now
we can check it by going through the
console if there is anything wrong in
the program or not
now before we wrap up this video one
more thing is this jquery ui file this
javascript file which we are adding
we have to add this file after the plain
jquery file only because the code
executes line by line and we may have to
face so many errors or difficulties
because of it so that's why we add the
jquery ui file only after the plain
jquery file always keep this thing in
mind guys before we move on to the date
picker widget in jquery let's discuss
what a widget is
in simple terms a widget is an
application or a component of an
interface that enables a user to perform
a function or access a service
suppose you use any android or ios
device then you must have noticed the
feature of widget that allows the user
to do certain things without opening the
actual app
for example mobile phones have widgets
that help us play music or know about
the weather outside or maybe some
particular apps sometimes have the
option to use them with the help of
widgets only
similarly jquery ui has some predefined
widgets that allows us to do specific
tasks with less amount of code needed
the date picker widget helps us in
picking the date from the calendar
an example of this date picker widget is
when we try to make any travel booking
and it asks the user to pick a date
within which they want to travel
then on clicking the tab we get the
calendar to pick up a date
that calendar refers to the date picker
widget
let me take you through the widget from
the official website of jquery ui and
you guys will understand it much better
here you can see we are on the website
and if you can see here we have
different interactions and widgets over
here
if we click on the date picker widget
from here so this is the date picker
widget if we click on it
you can see we have an input box over
here and the date is written here right
you can see date written over here now
on clicking the input box here we have a
calendar to pick a date from it
pick up any date from it and we have the
date as input in the text box right so
we'll create this text box and use this
widget in today's video you can also
check the source code from the website
if you want to but let's create the
whole thing again here
fine
so we'll move back to a
vs code and we'll open this document for
now
now we'll create a container box for
this first and then we'll put an input
box inside it the task is easy so we'll
move to html file and we'll write here
div id is equals to let's say div one
and here we have a container now let's
style this tag a bit so that it can be
visible properly so what we'll do is
we'll move to a head section
and we'll style this div tag over here
only we'll use the style tag
we are not going to create any external
css file for this so inside this we'll
write
hash
div one so this is the idea of a
container then inside here we'll write
height height is going to be let's say
500 pixels fine then we'll write here
width
and width is again going to be 500
pixels
then we'll give the border as well so
we'll write here border and border is
going to be three pixels
black in color and let's say solid fine
so we are going to write here solid and
then we'll define the border radius as
well to make it look more attractive so
border radius is going to be let's say
25 pixels
and then we'll write here position
and position is going to be relative
then the last thing we are going to
write here is the margin margin is going
to be auto
save it
and we have a box over here at the
center of our web page if you
open the browser completely you can see
over here we have a box so for now what
we'll do is we'll reduce the size from
here so instead of 500 pixels
let's say we have a box of size 200
pixels fine we'll define the width as
well so save it now you can see we have
a box over here the box looks a bit
smaller we can say so we'll again change
the height and width we'll write here
300 for height and 300 for width save it
now and it looks fine now so let's move
on and we'll add an input box inside
this container now for that what we'll
do is we'll write here inside the div
tag we'll use the paragraph tag and then
we'll put date inside it then after date
we'll put the input tag inside the
paragraph tag and input type is going to
be
text
and let's give the id as well so let's
say the id is date for this input tag
and we'll write here placeholder as well
so let's say inside here we'll write
enter
date fine we have to close this input
tag and we are good to go save it now
and you can see we have an input box
over here inside the container
fine
so let's make some style changes to make
it look more appealing so what we'll do
is we'll style this paragraph tag we'll
style the whole paragraph text so
we'll write here p and then inside it
will write text align is
center we want
the text to be present at the center of
the box
margin top is going to be let's say 150
pixels we want the text box in the
center of this container so margin top
is 150 for that
then we'll write here let's say font to
it fine we'll write here bolder
save it now and you can see we have the
input box at the center of this
container so what we can do here is we
can put a space between this and save it
now you can see it looks fine now
now we are done with the html and css
part we are doing all this so that you
can stay in touch with html and css and
it will also make the learning part
easier for you guys so let's move on to
the jquery ui part now and we'll add the
date picker widget to this input box
over there only
so we'll move to a javascript file and
what we'll do here is we'll add the date
picker widget to our input box
so for that we'll write here
dollar we are again going to access this
particular input box so for that we have
the id as
date
we'll write a dot
then we'll write here
date picker
fine
we are done with it can you guys believe
that we don't even have to write so much
code to add this widget
one line and we are done
save the program and click on the input
box now you can see we have a calendar
over here we can select any date from
here and the date will appear inside the
box you can see we have 12 1 20 21
fine
the date format here will be month day
and year which is mmdd and yy
fine and the date will appear inside the
text box only the good thing about this
date picker widget is that we can
control it for example you can see here
that the month of december starts from 1
fine
and there are no values present before
that month so what we want is we wanted
to show the dates from the previous
months as well for that what we can do
is we can write here inside this we have
to put curly braces over here and then
inside these curly braces we'll write
here
show other months so we'll write here
show other
months so this is case sensitive guys so
keep this
syntax in mind we have to write here
show with small s and then other with
capital o and months with capital m
we'll write here true
and save it now click on the input box
and you can see we have the dates over
here as 28 29 and 30. fine
however we can't select these dates
right now
for making them available for selection
what we have to do is we have to write
here after a comma we have to write here
select
other months
fine
now pass this as true
save the program click on the input box
try to select 29 from here and you can
see it says 11 29 20 21
fine
we can also show the button bar over
here beneath the calendar
so for that what we have to do is we
have to write here after a comma show
button
panel and we have to pass this boolean
as true
save it now
click on the input box and you can see
we have two buttons over here one is
today and the other one is done
fine
one of the button will take us to the
current date for example if we are in
the month of march if we click on this
today button you can see we are here
back in december and if you are done
selecting the date
then you can click on this done button
over here this widget has some more
functionalities like we can also show
the menu for changing the months and
years as you can see here for now we
have to go to other months with the help
of these arrow buttons only what we can
do is we can pass the boolean options
and the value will be set to true for
change months and change you
so let's do it here what we'll do is
we'll write here after comma
change month
and we are going to pass it
true
and we are going to write here change
here as well fine
value is going to be true again
save it now click on the input box and
you can see here we have the menus for
months and years here
we can choose any month from this list
let's click on july and here we are in
the month of july 2021. similarly we can
choose years as well we have years till
2031 from 2011. fine
now widget functionalities makes it
easier for the user to choose any date
from the given dates we can also
restrict the years according to our
needs so if we want to restrict the
years according to our need we have to
write here
min date and we have to pass the date
here we'll write here
new and then we'll write here date
then we'll write here the year so let's
say we are writing here 2016
1 comma 5
and then we'll write here
max date fine
we'll use the same syntax we'll write
here new date and let's say we are
writing here 2023
and we'll write here comma 1 comma 6
fine so we have an error over here we'll
remove it and we are good to go
fine the format will remain the same for
year month and day numbers in the
programming start from zero so january
will be zero a calendar will allow us to
choose between february 5 2016 and
february 6 2024
all the other dates will either be
removed or not available for selection
so save it
now click on the input box and if you
try to click here in 2021 you can see we
have
2016 as the first option will click on
2016 and you can see we don't have the
month of january in the year 2016
because the numbers start from zero
and we have written here one so the
calendar will start from february 2016.
inside here we can't choose these dates
we can start from 5th february 2016 only
fine we can show more than one month at
a time as well so
what we can do here is we can write here
comma
number of months so we'll write here
number of
months and will pass here let's say
2 fine
now we can select any date from 2 months
so click on the button over here
and let's
increase the size of this chrome browser
save this program now click on the input
box and you can see we have two months
over here we have december 2021 and
january 2022
fine so these are the functionalities
the date picker widget can perform the
list is quite long and we can't discuss
all of these functionalities so you guys
can check them by going through the
official jquery ui website i want you
guys to go through them and let us know
if there is any crucial functionality we
left out
a tooltip is basically a message which
appears when a cursor is positioned over
an icon image hyperlink or other
elements in a web page
so let's go through the jquery website
once and we'll see what this widget
actually does
here is the website of jquery ui we have
seen the usage of the date picker widget
from this website and we are well aware
of this website by now
so let's quickly go through the tooltip
widget and then we'll start using the
widget in our own program
what we'll do is we'll go to widgets and
we'll look for the tool tip widget here
you can see here at the bottom this tool
tip widget click on it and it will take
us to another web page
now here we have a text box and on
hovering over the text box you can see a
box with some text present inside it
which says we ask for your age only for
statistical purposes
this is known as the tool tip widget in
jquery ui where we can use this widget
any idea guys
now imagine we are working on an
e-commerce website where we have certain
different types of products and what we
can do is we can use this tool tip over
our products it will look nice right it
will give the user a bit of information
about the product and the website will
look more interactive
this was just an example of where we can
use this widget so let's use this widget
in our program now what we'll do is
we'll use the same code from the
previous video with an input box present
inside a container
so let's make some changes over here in
the html part first
we'll add an attribute over here we'll
add the title attribute so let's write
the code again we'll write this code
again
what we'll write here is
we'll again use the p tag because we
have styled the p tag already we'll
write here name
then we'll put some space and after this
we'll write here input
type is equals to text
and then we'll write here id is equals
to let's say
tool
and finally we'll write here title let's
say title is
enter your name here fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to use a placeholder and
inside this will write enter name
and we'll close this input tag now
fine
the same task but we change the name and
edit the title attribute here this title
attribute is a default html attribute so
if you save this program for now and you
can see here on taking the mouse cursor
over the input box a small message
appears on the screen so this tool tip
is actually very basic this is the
default html tool tip
now the next thing we'll do is to use
the tooltip widget we'll use the jquery
ui tooltip widget we'll move to a
javascript file and we'll try to access
this input box with the id first so here
is a javascript file and what we'll do
here is we'll try to access this input
box over here so for that we'll write
here dollar and then we'll use the id so
the id is
tool and then we'll write here dot
tool tip
fine
this is a method well
use brackets over here so that's it the
tooltip widget will take care of the
rest save the program
move to the browser and you can see here
if we take our cursor to this input box
we have a message over here so this
tooltip is a bit different from the html
one right the tooltip is larger in size
and it's a bit different as well
so what we can do is we can also make
customizations to this widget we can
control the effects and animation of
this widget by giving several boolean
parameters and by setting their values
for example we can track the mouse
cursor here and the tooltip will move
along with the mouse cursor just a
single property we have to give and we
are good to go so let's do it here and
you guys will understand it much better
what we'll do is we'll use curly braces
over here and then inside here we'll
write
track and we'll pass the value as true
fine
save the program move to the browser and
you can see it on the browser that the
tool tip tracks the mouse cursor and the
box is moving along with the cursor
right you can see the box moving it
moves to either of the sides along with
the cursor of a mouse now if you see
here carefully the animation here is the
fade in and fade out by default you guys
can see the tooltip fading in and out on
taking the mouse cursor over the input
box and on taking it away from here
now the next thing we can do with this
widget is we can control the animation
of this widget
so we have two parameters to control the
animation which are the show and the
height property both the properties can
take multiple parameters like the
timestamp delay and the type of effect
we want so let's say if we write here
after a comma
so let's say we write here
show
and then we have to use curly braces
because we have to pass multiple
parameters over here inside here what
we'll do is we'll write here effect
and the effect is going to be let's say
slide down fine this is a predefined
effect present in jquery ui already
and we don't have to do anything else we
just have to write the name of the
effect and jquery ui will take care of
the rest
now here we'll write
duration
and the duration is going to be let's
say 2000 fine then we'll also write here
delay as well so
we'll write here delay and delay is
going to be let's say 250
fine slide down here is the effect and
the duration defines the time this
effect will take place for delay here is
the time taken before the effect starts
taking place if you want to check the
output save the program go to the
browser and we'll move our cursor inside
the input box you can see the change in
the animation the
tooltip is sliding down on taking the
mouse cursor to this input box and if we
take it away from here the
tooltip fades out right so you can see
the animation it takes certain time to
appear and then it
suddenly goes out if we take the mouse
cursor away from the input box fine
now we can change the effects as well we
have several effects present like we
have highlight we have pulsate and we
have bounce as well so let's use some
more effects here what we'll do is we'll
change the slide down to
let's say highlight
fine
now the tooltip will get highlighted for
some time save the program
and move to the browser you can see here
on taking the mouse cursor to the input
box we have the tooltip highlighted for
some time
right
another tooltip effect we have in jquery
ui we have the pulsating effect as well
what we can do is we can write here
pulsate in place of highlight so this is
another effect we have in jquery ui save
the program and now the tooltip
animation will change you can see on
taking the mouse cursor the tool tip is
pulsating right
so let's move ahead and we'll now see
the height feature as well
we want some animation in the end as
well so when we take the mouse cursor
away basically for that what we can do
is we can define another property over
here we can write here
height and
the syntax will remain the same for hide
as well because we have to pass several
parameters that's why we are using
curly braces over here effect we will
write here as
let's say
explode fine
then we'll write here duration as well
duration is going to be
let's say 2000 fine let's remove the
delay from here as well because we don't
want any delay in a tooltip animation
save the program now take your mouse
cursor over this input box and you can
see the pulsating effect here now take
it out and you can see the explode
effect is not working
so we have to remove this l from here
save it now
now try to do it you can see the
pulsating effect here and on taking the
mouse cursor away you can see the
tooltip exploding into pieces here
now one more thing we can do here is we
don't actually need the whole title
attribute to use the tooltip what we can
do is we can use this tool tip without
the attribute value as well what we can
do is we can remove the value from here
and let's say we are removing this value
from here so this is the value of our
tooltip basically now save the program
what we can do instead of it is we can
write here
content and let's write here something
so let's say we are writing here this is
the
place
for
name
fine we'll write here comma save it now
what actually happens is jquery ui
dynamically takes this value from
content and puts it inside this
title attribute
now this will work totally fine save the
program move to the browser and take
your cursor over this and you can see we
have the tooltip widget as this is the
place for name
and when we take the cursor away from
this input box you can see the tooltip
exploding into pieces
so these are the customizations we can
make in the tooltip widget in the jquery
ui the list of features is quite long so
you guys can check them by going through
the website
the task for you guys now is you have to
put this tooltip over an image and see
the result let us know if you face any
sort of problem and will be more than
happy to help you guys
the accordion widget is mainly used for
descriptions or we can say it is a
jquery based expandable and collapsible
content holder that is broken into
sections and probably looks like tabs
only
so we have been through the syntax of
the previous two widgets we discussed
there's not too much of a difference so
let's quickly go through the
introduction of this widget from the
jquery ui website and then we'll use it
in our program so here we are on the
official website we'll quickly go
through the accordion widget
so here's the widget you can see the
first widget present is the accordion
widget click on it
and we can see we have some sections
over here right we have section one we
have section two three and four
if we click on any of the sections here
like if we click on section two you can
see this section expands and we can go
through the description of that
particular section so let's try to
achieve this thing by ourselves and then
we'll see the customizations allowed in
the accordion widget so we'll move to
the vs code and first of all what we'll
do is we'll add some sections over here
along with the description only so
here is the output of this particular
document for now what we'll do is we'll
add some particular sections over here
so we'll write here
div let's say the id for this div tag is
div one fine so here is our div tag now
inside this what we'll do is we'll add
some headings and the description part
right so we'll write here let's say h2
and inside this we are writing let's say
html
now what we'll do is we'll create
another div tag and then inside this div
tag we'll write p and now we'll write
something about the html fine so we'll
write here let's say html
for hyper text markup language
and then we'll write here let's say it
is used
to structure
a web page fine
so let's write something more here and
we'll write here and it's
content fine save the program you can
see it over here we have a heading as
html and then we have a paragraph which
is html stands for hyper text markup
language and it is used to structure a
web page and its content fine i hope you
guys got this so now what we'll do is
we'll copy this piece of code from here
and we'll paste it again
fine we have pasted it four times we'll
change the headings and the paragraphs
as well so let's say we are writing here
css then we'll write here let's say we
are writing here
css stands for
cascading style sheet
right here it is used
to
style a web
page in different ways fine
save it and you can see here we have
some headings and some text below them
you can see it over here it says css
stands for cascading style sheet it is
used to style a web page in different
ways similarly we'll change these two as
well so
let's do it first we'll write here
javascript
and then we'll write here let's say
javascript
crypt was introduced
in the year to 1995.
and then we'll write here
it is used to add functionality fine
i hope you guys must know all of this by
now so we have been through all this
already now the last thing we are going
to do is we are going to write here
jquery fine
and then we'll
write here inside this paragraph tag
will write here jquery
was jquery was introduced in 2006 so
we'll write here jquery was introduced
in 2006.
and let's say we are writing here jquery
is in
open source
fast
tiny and
rich
feature
library fine
and that's it we are not writing
anything more because this is just for
illustration purposes so we'll save this
and here you can see we have all the
four headings we have html css
javascript and jquery
so this is the html part we are done
with it now let's use the accordion
widget to make this ok looking webpage a
bit attractive so we'll use the widget
only we'll move to a javascript file
here we are in the javascript file and
we'll write here inside this
let's say
now we want to access the whole division
right so we want to access this
particular division with id as div one
so we'll write here dollar and then
inside
double inverted commas we'll write div
one this is the id then we'll write here
dot
accordion fine
this is a method so we'll use brackets
over here
that's it guys we are done with it save
the program and you can see how nice
this thing looks now we don't have to
put any effort into adding functionality
to this web page a single line of code
can do this task for us so this is the
actual use of jquery ui it allows us to
do certain tasks with a single line of
code
now the first section always remains
open like this
and if you want to make it collapsible
like you can see we can click on any of
these sections now and that particular
section will expand but if you refresh
this page and you can see it over here
the first section always remains open
now what if we want to make it
collapsible we don't have to do so much
of a task what we have to do is we have
to pass some properties and jquery ui
will take care of the rest
now what we'll do is we'll right here
inside the brackets we'll use curly
braces over here and now we'll write
here
collapsible and we'll pass it as
true fine
now save the program and you can see if
we click on this html again you can see
it collapses on clicking it so this
property is working totally fine and it
allows us to
make a section collapsible or expandable
fine jquery ui helps us do such tasks
without any problem so what else we can
do here is we can change the icons as
well
here you can see that we have these
arrow shaped icons over here
in the header part if you guys remember
jquery ui has some predefined css
properties or we can say it has some
predefined css libraries as well through
which we can also change the style so
let me show you the icons we have in
jquery ui and for that we'll go back to
the website here are the icons we can
use any of the buttons from here you can
see the names we don't have to do so
much of a task you can see the icon type
you can see it over here it's written
that ui icon arrow 1n so these are the
names for these particular icons we can
use any of these icons we don't have to
do much of a task we have to copy the
names from here and we have to paste
them into a javascript file
so let's move back to a jquery file once
and first of all we'll write the
property over here we'll write here
icons and this is a little bit tricky we
can say we have to use curly braces over
here
and inside this we have to write header
we are going to use different icons for
header and for
active header so we'll write here header
and we'll take one icon from here fine
we'll let's say we are taking this ui
icon caret one so we'll copy the name
from here we'll paste it in a jquery
file
then we'll write here comma we'll again
do the same thing for active header as
well so we'll write here active
header
and then we'll take one more icon so
let's say we are taking this icon from
here
copy it from here
paste it here and we are good to go fine
so this is how we can change the icons
using jquery ui
now let's go through the output once
save this program and you can see the
icons are changed now we have these
icons over here so let me comment this
property for once
save it now you can see these were the
icons we had before we are using the
icons property now after using this
property save it and here you can see
the icons are changed fine
so this is how we can change the icons
using jquery ui
so some more customizations we can make
in this widget are
we can also change the time for the
animation to take place using the
animate property now we don't have to do
so much of a task for that we'll
use a comma here and we'll write here
animate we'll pass the time in
millisecond so let's say we are writing
here 2000 save it and now the animation
will take two seconds to complete you
can see the change in the speed here it
takes two seconds to expand and two
seconds to collapse fine
we can also change the event from click
to mouse over as well so for that we
have to write here
after a comma we have to write here
event and then we can write here let's
say
mouse over i hope this will work so the
default event is the click event and we
can change the event using this event
property only
so
let's save this program and if we take
our mouse cursor over any of these
sections you can see that particular
section expanding and collapsing
with the mouse cursor right you can see
the mouse over event working over here
so these are some basic customizations
we can make in the accordion widget in
jquery ui the list is so long and we
can't discuss all the properties so you
guys can go through them from the
official jquery ui website and let us
know if we missed out on anything
important
now that we are aware of what widgets
are and we know a lot about them from
the previous few widgets we have been
through till now
we know quite a bit about them and their
usage right so widgets make it easier
for us to do certain things without
writing much of a code
now the message box we are talking about
here is a message kind of thing that
appears on the screen and it looks more
attractive than the traditional alert
method
we can also customize the box with some
properties and make a webpage look more
interactive to the user the actual
widget name is dialog it's not message
box actually the widget name is dialog
and the work of this widget is to put a
message on the screen inside a
particular message box
so let's go through the jquery ui
website quickly and will then use this
widget in a program here we are at the
official website of jquery ui and we'll
quickly move to the dialog widget to
know more about it so here you can see
this is the dialog widget click on it
and you can see it over here we have a
dialog box with some message on it right
so this is the dialog box over here it
has a heading which says basic dialog
and inside this we have some content
over here
right
now if we take the mouse cursor over the
title you can see the cursor changes and
we are now able to drag this widget
across the screen fine
or we can also change the size of this
widget with the help of a mouse you can
see the size changing if we try to
change it if we try to increase the size
or if we try to reduce the size we can
do it with the help of this widget
now you can also go through the
customizations allowed in the dialog box
from the website only but let's use this
widget in our program and we'll see some
customizations there only here we are in
the vs code now there are two simple
steps to get the jquery dialog box
we can either place the content inside
the div element and then we can access
the content from there or we can just
use the dialog function in our
javascript file as well
for now we'll be using the first method
in which we'll create a division and add
some content inside it so let's do it
here
what we'll do is we'll write here inside
this body tag we'll write here div
and we have to provide an id so let's
say the id for the div is dialog
we'll close this and here we are
now we'll write something inside this
div tag so let's say we are writing here
this is a customizable
dialog box fine so this is our text save
the program and you can see it over here
we have the text as this is a
customizable dialog box on the browser
now what we want to do is we want the
content of this div element inside the
dialog box for that
we'll move to a javascript file so this
is a javascript file and we'll write
here
dolo we'll try to access this div tag so
we have the ids dialog we'll write a
hash
dialog then we'll write here dot
so the widget name is dialog so we'll
write here dialog and that's it
now the dialog widget will take the
content from the div element dynamically
and put it inside as a message
save the program and you can see here we
have a message box with the same message
as the content from the div element you
can see this message box over here has
no title as of now although we can
drag this message box in a web browser
or we can also resize it you can see it
over here now to add the title we have
two ways first we can either use the
title attribute in the html development
or we can use the title property here
inside the dialog function only
so let's give it a try what we'll do is
we'll move to html file and we'll use
the title attribute over here so we'll
write here title and let's say the title
is
title using attribute
fine
save it and you can see we have the
title over here as title using attribute
now we can also use the title property
as well so for this we'll move to a
jquery file or javascript file we can
say and then we'll write here inside
this dialog function we'll use curly
braces and we'll write here title
then we'll pass the title here so let's
say the title is
title using
property fine
for now we have the title as title using
attribute because we are using an html
attribute for the title so
save this program now and you can see
the title changes to title using
property fine
i didn't remove the title attribute from
the html file to let you guys know that
the title property here will overwrite
the title attribute if it ever gets into
a situation where we have used both of
them
so i hope you guys got this now the next
customization we can do is we can change
the dragging of this message box right
now we are able to move this message box
within the browser you can see it over
here we are free to move it so to stop
the user from doing this we have to set
the draggable property to false
so what we can do is we can write here
after a comma
draggable
and we have to set this property to
false all the properties here are by
default set to true mostly so we have to
set it to false save the program and now
try to move this box you can see we are
not able to move this box now
so this is how the draggable property
works
although the size can still be changed
with the help of mouse cursor only we
can change the size of this
dialog box so to stop this from
happening what we have to do is we have
to write here
resizable
and we have to pass this property as
false fine save it now and
you will notice that we are not able to
resize this dialog box now so these are
some of the basic properties of this
dialog widget now we'll further move on
and we'll see some more properties over
here
now the following property is close on
escape
so if you press the escape key from the
keyboard you can see the message box
closes if we set the close on property
to false then it will not allow us to
close the dialog box by pressing the
escape button this is one more property
of the dialog widget so what we have to
do is
we have to write here after a comma
close on
escape fine we have to set this to false
and we are good to go save it now and
press the escape key from the keyboard
and you can see we are not able to close
this dialog box by using the escape key
anymore
for the next property let's add an input
box first we'll see why in a moment so
let's add it first we'll move to html
file and we'll write here before the div
tag so let's say we are writing here
first
name and we'll use an input tag so we'll
write here input
type is equals to text
and that's it
fine
save the program you can see we have the
input box on the browser you can see we
have it over here
the reason behind adding it is to show
you guys that if we try to interact with
an element while the dialog box is there
on the screen jquery will not stop us
until we use the model property so if we
try to write here any name so you can
see we are able to do that and we have
the message over here as well
now to make this dialog box a model
dialog box what we have to do is we have
to pass the model property to true here
fine we have to make the
dialog box as a model dialog box so we
have to write your model and we have to
pass here true save the program and now
you can see we cannot access the input
box anymore if we try to click over here
you can see we are not able to do
anything with this input box
so what we have to do is we have to
close this dialog box first so let's
close it and now we'll try to write
something inside this input box
you can see we are able to write
anything over here
right now you guys might wonder that
this dialog box is opening every time
right
what if we want to open it on a button
click for that what we have to do is we
have to set the auto open property to
false first and we have to add a button
as well so let's start by adding a
button and then we'll set the auto open
property to false
we'll add a button over here so what
we'll do is we'll write here after this
input element
we'll write here button we have to pass
an id over here so let's say the id is
btn1
and the name of this button is let's say
dialog box fine save it now and you can
see we have a button over here named as
dialog box now the next thing we are
going to do is we are going to set the
auto open property to false so for that
we'll move to a javascript file and
we'll write here
auto open
fine and we'll set this property to
false
save the program and you can see the
message box is not opening by default
anymore now to open the dialog box on
the button click we have to access the
button first and then we have to use the
open method seems a bit confusing right
so let's try to do it and you guys will
understand it much better i guess
so what we'll do is
we'll write here before this
dialog box so we'll access the button
first so we'll write here dollar the
button id is
btn1 then we'll write here dot click we
are using the click event we'll create a
function over here and now inside the
body of this function what we have to do
is we have to open the dialog box for
that we'll write here dollar
we'll again write here
dialog because we want the content from
the div element for the dialog box then
we'll write here dot
dialog fine now we'll right here inside
this open
and that's it
we have to pass the open method here as
a string because we want to open the
dialog box on a button click now save
the program
and
you guys can see here we have to click
on the button over here to open the
dialog box click on the button you can
see on clicking the button the dialog
box is opening and we are not able to
write anything still here right we are
not able to write any name over here for
that we have to close this and then we
will be able to write here anything
and for the dialog box to appear we have
to click on this dialog box button
so guys these are some of the
customizations we can make in this
particular widget i hope you guys got
this one of the most accessible and
widely used widgets in jquery ui is the
auto complete widget it helps the users
complete the text they are writing in an
input box or somewhere by giving
suggestions
so let's go through the jquery ui
website quickly and then we'll see the
syntax and all for this particular
widget so here we are on the website
we'll look for the auto complete widget
and here is the autocomplete widget
click on it
now you can see we have a text box over
here so before we do something let's go
through the description given over here
for this autocomplete widget it says the
autocomplete widgets provides
suggestions while you type into the
field here the suggestions are the tags
from programming languages so if we
write here
let's say ja
you can see we have two different
options we have java and javascript
right so this is what the autocomplete
widget is now let's use this widget in
our program
so here we are in the vs code what we'll
do now is we'll create an input box
first and then we'll use this particular
widget so for creating an input box what
we'll do is we'll write here let's say
we are writing here
favorite language
fine
now we have to create an input box for
this so we'll write here input
type is equals to text and let's provide
the id as well so we'll write here id so
let's say the id is
input for this text box
now let's add a button over here as well
to make it look nicer a bit so what
we'll do is we'll add a button over here
we'll write here button
so let's say we'll give the id as ptn1
we don't need this but let's do it here
so let's say the button name is submit
now save the program and you can see it
on the browser we have an input box
where we have to mention our favorite
language and the submit button as well
so let's move on to the jquery part now
and we'll use the autocomplete widget
here we are in the javascript file now
the syntax is the same so we have to use
this widget with the id of a html
element what we'll do is we'll write
here
dollar so the id for input box is input
so we'll write here hash input then
we'll write here dot auto
complete
fine
that's it right the syntax for all the
widgets we have been through is similar
to this one but there is a slight
difference in this particular widget
what this widget does is it provides us
with suggestions so we have to give
those suggestions by ourselves to the
system to let jquery ui go through them
and then only it can provide us with
certain recommendations
the suggestions will be the name of some
languages in this particular case so
let's create an array over here of all
the languages we want what we'll do is
we'll write here before this
document.ready method or event we can
say
we'll create a variable over here so
let's say the variable name is language
then we'll create an array so
let's say we have certain
names of particular languages stored
inside this array right so we'll write
here html
then we have
css
we have javascript as well so we'll
mention all the languages we know we'll
write a javascript then we have php
and
we have java
so then we'll write here
python
and
then we'll write here
let's say c
we have c plus plus as well so we'll
mention that as well so we'll write here
c plus plus then we have
c sharp so we'll write here c sharp and
we have pearl so we'll write here pearl
will write here
so we have to put this inside double
inverted commas
then we'll write here let's say ruby
and we have
scala so we'll write scala
then we have cobol as well
so these all are languages
then we have basic
so we'll write here basic and
let's mention some more so let's say we
are writing here
fortran so we'll write here fortran
and then we have
lisp
and finally let's add here typescript
fine so we'll write here typescript
i guess these are enough for now
so the next task we have to do is to let
the autocomplete widget know about this
particular array for that we have to
pass this array as a parameter to this
autocomplete widget over here fine
now the thing to keep in mind here is
that we have to pass two parameters in
this widget
one is for the source of the array we
can say and the other one is for the
customizations so we have to pass them
inside curly braces this means that we
have to use two pairs of curly braces
right so we'll use two curly braces over
here we'll
separate them with a comma so the first
one is for the source and the second one
is for the customizations fine
now the next thing we have to do is to
pass the source to this autocomplete
widget
the source is the array right for that
what we have to do is we have to write
here inside this first curly braces we
have to write here source
and we have to give the name of a array
over here so we'll write here language
and that's it
fine we are done with the autocomplete
widget so let's check the output now
save the program and move on to the
browser here we have an input box now
try to write something over here what
we'll do is we'll write here let's say
c you can see we have the names of all
the languages which have the letter c
present in their names
this is the basic working of this
autocomplete widget it suggests all the
related names to the user and lets them
choose from any of them so if we click
on c plus plus you can see we have the
input sc plus plus over here and if we
write here
java we have two options we have
javascript and java we can click on any
of them and that will be present as the
text inside the input box
now we can also use the array inside the
autocomplete widget as well we don't
have to create any variables or anything
just copy the array from here
and what we have to do is we have to
paste it here inside the
autocomplete widget fine will comment
this piece of code will comment it out
save it now and you can see on writing
here c we have all the options with c
present in their names fine so this is
working totally fine i guess
now talking about the customizations we
have in this widget we'll be going
through three different types of
customizations
what we'll do is we'll write here first
so we have this pair of curly braces
over here for the customization so we'll
write inside it let's say
delay
and let's
pass the value as 500 over here fine
delay is 500 means the suggestions will
be shown to the user after 500
milliseconds if we write here 2000
instead of 500
and save the program now try to write
something over here and it will take two
seconds to complete for example let's
say we are writing here java now wait
for two seconds and then the options
will appear on the screen
fine so this is a property of the
autocomplete widget now the second
property is the min length property this
property defines the minimum length
required for the suggestions so for
example if we write here
min length
and if we pass the value as let's say 3
save it now if we write here c
fine we have the min length as 3 and c
is of single letter we'll not get any
suggestions because the minimum length
is 3 instead of c if we write here j a
we are still not getting any suggestions
because the minimum length is 3 right
here v and you can see after 2 seconds
we have two suggestions over here as
java and javascript
let's change the delay to
500 over here again and now what we'll
do is we'll try to search for another
language let's say we are searching for
python now we have four
letters over here and you can see we
have the suggestion as python so this is
how the main length property of this
autocomplete widget works
now the last property is the focus
property let's go through the example
directly we'll write here
after a comma
or to
focus fine we'll pass this as
true because this is a boolean property
save it now now go to the browser and
write here something let's say we are
writing here
kobul and you can see
we have the first option in focus
because of this particular property now
try to write here java
and you can see we have two options the
first one is in focus and if we pass
this property as
false
save this program right here java again
and you can see none of the two options
are in focus now
so these are some of the customizations
we have in the autocomplete widget a
widget is an application or a component
of an interface that enables a user to
perform a function or access a service
this was the definition of widgets and
we know how to use certain widgets like
the date picker widget accordion widget
tool tip widget and many more such
widgets right so let's suppose a
scenario now wherein we are already
using a widget in our program and we
have customized the widget according to
our needs
now what we want is we want to change
the property of a widget by clicking on
a button
how we can achieve this thing we can't
write the whole thing again right
here comes the concept of widget
modification in jquery ui
what we need to do is we need to modify
a particular property of a specific
widget
is it possible in jquery to do so the
answer to this question is yes it is
possible to modify any widget property
in jquery with the help of specific
methods
let's go through the programming part
directly and you guys will understand it
much better
we'll use the dialog box widget and then
we'll try to modify a particular
property of that widget so let's write
the code again so that you guys can get
a fair idea of what's coming
what we'll do is we'll write here inside
the body tag we'll create a division so
for that we'll use the div tag the id is
going to be let's say
dialog for the dialog box
and we'll define the title here as well
so let's say the title of our dialog box
is going to be
title 1
we'll close the div tag now inside there
we'll write this is a customizable
dialog box fine
save the program and you can see we have
the text over here which says this is a
customizable dialog box now we have to
add the dialog box for that we are going
to use the jquery ui widget but before
that let's add some buttons over here as
well we'll add two buttons because we
have two different properties
so we'll write here
button and the id is going to be
btn1 for button 1
and the name is let's say get fine
we'll add another button for that we'll
write here button id is going to be btn2
and the name of this button is going to
be set save this program and you can see
we have two buttons over here we have
the get button and the set button
now this is going to be a basic dialog
box the next thing we'll do is we'll
move to the jquery part and we'll write
some code there
so here we are in the javascript file
and what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar will access this whole division
so for that we'll write here hash
and id is dialog for the division then
we'll write here dot dialog
this is a method so we have to use
parenthesis over here and then we'll use
curly braces to define all the
properties of this dialog box widget
now inside here we'll write properties
so let's say we are writing here
draggable
and we are passing this property as
true for now
then we'll write here
resizable and the property value is
going to be true again then we'll write
here
close on escape
we'll write here
true for this one as well
now the next property we are going to
use is the model property we'll write
here false for model
and then we'll use the auto open
property fine will write your auto open
and then we'll write here
true
and that's it
so what we are doing here is we are
defining the customizations allowed in
this particular widget i hope you guys
already have an idea of what we are
doing because we have discussed it in
the dialog box widget video
now save the program and you can see we
have a dialog box with title as title 1
and inside it we have a message which is
this is a customizable dialog box if you
try to drag this dialog box you can see
we are able to do that because we have
defined the draggable property to true
and we can also resize this because the
resizable property is also set to true
now what we want is we want to change a
particular property on a button click
right for that we have to use the click
event with the buttons so we'll use the
click event with buttons first and then
we'll use methods fine
so first of all we'll write here
dollar
the id for button one is btn1
which is
the get button then we'll write here dot
click
and we'll create a function over here
fine
and we have the body of this function
now inside this will write alert and
let's see if this button is working or
not we'll print a message so
we'll write here get is working
save the program click on the get button
you can see we have a message with get
is working as output now copy this piece
of code and we'll do the same thing for
set button as well we'll change the
button id to btn2
and instead of get will write here set
save the program click on set over here
you can see this button is also working
fine
so basically we were checking if these
buttons are working or not we'll comment
this piece of code for now
now the idea is to get the value of any
particular property and then change it
right for that we have two methods in
jquery ui the getter method and the
setter method
the getter method is used to get the
value of any particular property and the
setter method is used to change that
particular value
you can also go through the
documentation present on the jquery ui
official website but let me just tell
you about these methods the syntax for
the getter method goes like this
what we have to do is we have to take a
variable that will store the value so
for that we'll write here where model
let's say
then we'll access this dialog box we
have the ids dialog for that
then we'll write here dot
dialog and inside brackets we have to
pass two parameters one is the option
and
second one is going to be the name of
that particular property
so we'll write here option option refers
to these properties so basically we are
telling the computer that we want to
access these particular properties the
option parameter will remain the same
for all jquery widgets the second
parameter is going to be the name of a
particular property so let's say we are
writing here model
and on saving the program if we click on
the get button the output will get is
false because the model property is
initially set to false click on the get
button but before that we have to write
here some more things so what we'll do
is
we'll print the model variable inside
the alert method so we'll write here
alert model save this program click on
the get button you can see we have the
output as false because this is the
initial value of this model property now
let's move ahead and we'll try to change
this property to true now
for that we have the setup method in
jquery ui the syntax for setup method is
almost the same we'll copy this piece of
code from here
we'll paste it here inside this
and now what we'll do is we'll pass one
more parameter over here the third
parameter is going to be the change so
till now the value of this model
property is false but what we want is we
want to change it to true so we'll write
here true
save it now click on the get button you
can see the output is false click on ok
now click on the set button you can see
there is no change in the browser but
click on the get button again and you
can see the output is changed to true
this means that the model property is
now set to true fine
we can change any property by using
these methods so let's try this thing
with some other properties as well what
we'll do is we'll write here instead of
model let's say we are writing here
draggable fine
so the initial value of draggable was
true
what we'll do is we'll write here
draggable again and we'll change this to
false now
fine
save the program click on get you can
see the output is true because the
initial value of draggable property was
true
now click on set and you can see we are
not able to drag this dialog box anymore
right
this is because the draggable property
is now set to false when we clicked on
this set button click on get again and
you can see the property is false
so this is how the widget modification
in jquery actually works we can also
change the height and width of this
dialog box for that we have to define
the height and width over here let's
define them we'll write a height height
is going to be let's say
250 and we'll define the width as well
so the width is going to be let's say
250 again fine
so here we have the dialog box the
height and the width are 250 pixels we
can resize it obviously because the
recessible property is true now what we
want is we want the height so inside
this getter method we'll
write here height
and click on the get button after saving
this click on get you can see we have
the height as 250 pixels
now what we want is we want to change
the height right we'll write here height
again
now the new height is going to be let's
say 300 on clicking the set button
save the program
click on get the initial height is 250
fine click on set you can see the change
in the height click on get again you can
see the height is changed to 300 pixels
now
fine
so this is how we can make modifications
in the widgets afterward and this thing
remains the same for all the widgets in
jquery ui the name of the widget is the
only thing that will change rest
everything will remain the same
so far we have covered widgets and their
usage in the past few videos widgets
make it easier for us to perform a
function or access a service with less
code required
we came across different types of
widgets and their usage it's quite easy
to use widgets in jquery all we have to
do is to call the widget with specific
name and that's it jquery even allows us
to make customizations in widgets right
now
talking about interactions they have
almost the same syntax as widgets but
the working and customizations makes the
difference
interactions basically let the user
perform various actions on the dome
element with the help of mouse without
changing the appearance of the element
the first interaction we'll be going
through today is the draggable
interaction in jquery
this interaction enables draggable
functionality to any dom element it is
used to move the draggable object by
clicking on it with the mouse and
dragging it anywhere within the viewport
this interaction allows us to move a
particular element whether it be an
image or a box or anything movable
across the screen
we can customize the way we can move the
box with the help of certain
customizations as well
let's go through the official jquery ui
website to see the working of this
interaction and then we'll use it in our
own program here we are on the official
website of jquery ui and you can see
over here we have all the interactions
which are placed differently from
widgets right we have all the
interactions over here then we have
widgets as well click on the draggable
interaction draggable interaction is the
first interaction available here click
on it and it will take us to a new page
you can see over here we have a box with
some text present inside it which says
drag me around click and hold over the
box and try to drag it we are able to
drag it here right
so let's achieve this thing in our own
program now and then we'll go through
the customizations as well
here we are in the vs code now we'll do
the draggable thing with two different
boxes so let's add them quickly what
we'll do is we'll write here inside the
body tag
we'll use the div tag we'll write here
div
and inside this div tag we'll create
another division for box one so we'll
write here div id is equal to let's say
okay we'll use class for this so we'll
write here class is equals to let's say
box and we'll close this div tag now
we'll write something inside it so let's
say we are writing here box one
now we'll create another box for that we
have to use another div tag we'll write
here div class is going to be the same
we'll write here box
then we'll write here inside this box
2 let's say fine
save this program and you can see here
we have some text present on the screen
which says box 1 and box 2. so let's
style these boxes as well
what we'll do is we'll write here inside
the head tag
we'll use the style tag for this so
we'll write here style
and inside this
we are going to make some style changes
in these boxes so we'll write here box
because box is the class we'll write
here dot box now inside this will write
let's say we are using border border is
going to be let's say 5 pixel
solid
and let's say black in color fine let's
keep it simple for now we'll use the
height over here we'll write here height
as let's say 100 pixels
then we'll define width as well which is
again going to be 100 pixels
and finally after this we'll write here
margin margin is going to be let's say
10 pixels and we'll align this text to
the center so we'll write here text
align at this center
fine
now we are done with it save the program
and you can see we have two boxes now
the next thing we want to do is we want
to move these boxes with the help of a
mouse button right for that we have to
use the draggable interaction from
jquery ui we discussed earlier that the
syntax remains almost the same for
interactions and widgets in jquery
so let's add the interaction to our
program now
here we are in the javascript file and
what we'll do is we'll write here
dollar now we need to access these boxes
for that we have the class as box so
we'll write here dot box
and then we'll write here dot
draggable
it is a method so we'll use parenthesis
now that's it guys we are done now we'll
be able to move those boxes in our
browser
save the program and try doing it so you
can see we are now able to move these
boxes across the browser
we are able to move them freely try
moving them to the bottom and you can
see the scroll bar appearing over here
right
the same thing will happen if we try to
move it horizontally if we try to move
it horizontally you can see the scroll
bar at the bottom of our browser
so we are good to go with that
now talking about the customizations we
have in this interaction we can control
the dragging path of the element we can
either make it draggable along the
x-axis which means horizontally or along
the y-axis which means vertically so for
that we have to write here inside this
we have to use curly braces for
customizations the same thing we did
with widgets as well
now we'll write over here axis
axis we are going to define so let's say
we are writing here x
we are going to drag the box along the
x-axis now save the program and you can
see we are not able to move the box
towards the bottom side right we are not
able to move the box along the y-axis
what we can do is we can move this box
horizontally only because we have
defined the axis as
x and now we will be able to move the
box horizontally only
the next thing we can do is we can also
change the cursor upon dragging the box
to make it look a bit more interactive
what we have to do is we have to write
here after a comma we have to write here
cursor
and we have to define here
grabbing fine this is the cursor name
now save the program
and you will notice on dragging the
element the cursor changes right we can
also change the opacity of this element
on dragging you can see we have the
opacity as one because the black color
is completely visible for now we can
change it just right here after a comma
opacity
and we'll define the opacity as
let's say 0.5
fine
now
save the program try to drag this box
and you can see on dragging the opacity
changes to 0.5 of this particular box
the same thing will go for box 2 as well
because we have defined the axis as x we
are not able to move the box in other
directions so let's comment this
access for now save it now and you can
see now we are able to move these boxes
free fine the next thing we can do here
is we can also limit the dragging area
of this box
we can either limit it to the division
or to the document as well so for that
we have to define a property over here
we have to write here after a comma
containment
and then we have to write here either
parent for division and for document we
have to write a document only so let's
do it with parent
save the program
and you can see the area is limited now
we can drag it till here only we can't
drag it out of this box because we have
a division over here defined as well and
these boxes are present inside that
division if you go back to the html
document you can see here we have this
div tag as well we can move these boxes
only inside this div tag we can't go out
of this so this is how we can limit the
dragging area of a particular element
another property we can use is the grid
property so let's write here first and
then you can understand it much better i
guess so we'll write here grid
and we'll define the grid inside
these brackets we'll write here 300
comma 300
now save the program and you guys will
get it much better but before that let's
comment this piece of code we are not
going to limit the draggable area of
these boxes save it now and now on
dragging the box you can see that it
automatically stops after 300 pixels and
the in between movement of the box is
not visible let me zoom out the browser
for you and you can see it more clearly
now you can see the box stopping after
300 pixels and the in-between movement
of this box is not visible so this is
how we can use the grid property to make
it look more interactive to the user
now the last two properties we are going
to discuss today are the snap and the
snap tolerance properties if the snap
property is set to true then the two
boxes will stick together if closer to
each other
the snap tolerance property defines the
distance between the elements to stick
together so let's use them here first
we'll
comment this grid as well we'll write
here
after this
snap so snap is a boolean property we'll
write here true for that and we'll write
here snap
tolerance fine
and we'll set snap tolerance to let's
say 100 pixels this is in pixels keep
this thing in mind now if the distance
between the two boxes at any time
becomes 100 or less than 100 then both
the boxes will stick together save the
program and you can see over here that
moving the first box near to the second
one they are sticking together right the
snap tolerance is hundred it means that
if we try to bring the box near to box
two and the distance between them is
either hundred or less than that then
the boxes will stick together
so this is how we can use the draggable
interaction to make our webpage more
interactive i hope you guys got it the
basic definition states that
interactions let the user perform
various actions on the dom element with
the help of the mouse without changing
the actual appearance of the dom element
the sortable interaction we'll be going
through today is used to sort elements
just by dragging them
so let's go through the jquery ui
website quickly and then we'll use it in
our own program
here we are on the official website of
jquery ui we'll go to the sortable
interaction directly here it is click on
it and here you can see we have a list
of items we can sort them according to
our needs if we pick any one of them
from its position and if we try to drag
it to another place you can see we can
do so because of the sortable
interaction in jquery ui
the sortable interaction enables a group
of dom elements to be sortable click on
it and drag the element to a new spot
within the list and all the other items
will adjust according to this particular
item it shows all the properties of the
draggable interaction by default we'll
see them after going through the syntax
of this interaction so let's move on to
the vs code and we'll try to implement
this thing in our own program now
here we are on the vs code the first
thing we'll be doing is to add those
elements to a web page for that what
we'll do is we'll take a div tag and
we'll define the list inside that
particular div tag we'll write here div
close it now what we have to do is we
have to declare an unordered list for
that we'll use the ul tag we'll write a
ul
class is going to be let's say sort
we'll close this stack and now inside
this we'll define the list fine
we'll use the li tag for that we'll
write here li id is equals to let's say
sortable we are giving all these
elements ids because we want to style
them as well so for styling purpose
we'll be using the id attribute
we'll close it and here we'll write the
name of item let's say item1
will copy this piece of code from here
we'll paste it certain times
and then we'll change the name of items
fine we'll write here item 2
then we have item three
four
five six and
seven fine
we have a list of items on our web page
so you can see we have seven different
items over here now let's style them as
well for that what we'll do is we'll
move to the head tag of a html file and
we'll use the style tag over here
we'll write here inside this style tag
hash
sortable this is the id now we'll style
these elements we'll write here border
border is going to be 2 pixels solid in
nature and
black in color
then we'll write a height so let's say
the height is
20 pixels for each box then we'll write
your width
width is going to be let's say 100
pixels they are going to be rectangular
in shape not squares so height and width
is going to be different let's define
the margin as well let's say margin is
10 pixels
then we have text align as well fine so
let's say we are writing here text align
at the center
save it now and here you can see we have
all the boxes over here but it's still
not working
let's see what the problem is
so you can see over here we have a
mistake we have written here as loid so
we'll correct it we have solid over here
now save it and you can see we have all
the items over here we have seven items
all are placed inside boxes
now we did some basic styling here
everyone can understand it because it's
so basic the next thing we have to do is
to use the sortable interaction here for
that we'll move to a javascript file
so here is a javascript file now we have
to use this interaction in all the items
so we have to use it with the parent
element to make each box movable within
the area covered by the ul tech
so we'll be using the class attribute
here
we'll write here
dollar now we are going to take a
selector so for that we'll write here
dot sort because this is the class name
and then we'll write here dot sortable
fine this is the interaction name it is
basically a method that's why we are
using parenthesis over here
that's it guys the sortable interaction
can do the rest of task by itself
this interaction over here is already
defined inside the jquery file all we
need to do is to pass it as a method and
jquery will take care of the rest
we are done with it let's save the
program
save it and here you can see it on the
browser that we are able to move a
particular box now click on item 1 and
you can see we are able to drag it and
if we put it down here you can see all
the other items adjusting themselves
without any problem so we have already
discussed that the sortable interaction
has all the customizations of the
draggable interaction by default let's
use them what we'll do is
we'll write here inside curly braces
we'll write here let's say opacity this
property we have used in the previous
interaction as well so let's define the
opacity as 0.5 then we have cursor
we can write here cursor as let's say
grabbing a hand like thing will come
when we try to grab the boxes now
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here containment
it can either be document or the parent
so for now we will be using parent over
here
then we have let's say
delay and
we'll define the delay in milliseconds
so let's say the delay here is 300
milliseconds and the last thing we are
going to do is we are going to write
here distance
fine we are going to write here 50 now
so here we have all the customizations
allowed by this interaction in jquery ui
almost all of them are from the previous
interaction that is the draggable
interaction the distance here is in
pixels and it means that this
interaction will work only if we drag
the element for 50 pixels
save the program now try to move a box
you can see we are not able to move a
box until the distance reaches 50 pixels
fine so this is how this distance
property actually works now the delay
property defines the time interval taken
by the interaction so here the time
interval is 300 milliseconds when we try
to move a box it will take 300
milliseconds and then only the box will
move so these are some of the few
properties that i think are the most
important to understand you can find
more from the api documentation present
on the official jquery ui website
here is a task for you guys what you
have to do is to add an image in this
program and then see if this works the
same or not now that we have a good idea
of what interactions are and how we can
use them to make a more interactive web
page we can simply go through this new
interaction in jquery ui without a
problem if you haven't watched the last
two parts wherein we discussed the
draggable and sortable interactions i'll
suggest you to go through them and it
will be easy for you guys to get this
topic
the resizable interaction in jquery
enables any dom element to be resizable
with the help of the cursor we can grab
the right or bottom border of any dom
element and drag it to the desired width
and height
so let's go through this interaction
quickly from the official website and
then we'll see what we can do with this
particular interaction to make our web
page more interactive so here we are on
the official website of jquery here's
the resizable interaction click on it
and it will take us to a new page
you can see we have a box over here
which says resizable what we can do here
is we can grab the box either from the
bottom
or from the right side and you can see
we are able to change the height and
width of this particular box
we have the option for certain
customizations that will be going
through after some time
so i hope you guys must have got an idea
by now about this resizable interaction
let's use it in our program here we are
in the vs code the first thing we'll be
doing is we'll be adding an html element
over here let's use an image for now to
get an idea of the syntax so we'll add
an image to a web page for that we'll
write here inside the body tag we'll use
the div tag first so we'll write here
div now inside this will write img
source is going to be images this is a
folder in my computer so
right here we'll write j1.png then we
have
id so let's say the id for this image is
img1 and then we have to set the
alternate as well so let's say we are
writing here javascript
close this img tag save the program and
you can see we have the image over here
which is quite large in size so let's
style this image as well we'll change
the height and width of this particular
image for that we'll write here inside
the head tag we'll use the style tag
so inside this we have the ids img one
for this particular image so we'll use
it here
then we'll define the height of this
image so let's say the height of this
image is going to be
250 pixels fine
we'll also change the width of this
image so for that we'll write here
width let's say the width is going to be
250 pixels again now we'll write here
border so let's say the border is going
to be one pixel
solid
and black and color fine
that's it we are done with this image
save the program and you can see we have
an image over here which is of 250
pixels in size
the next task we have to do is to make
this image resizable
for that we have to use the resizable
interaction only so
we'll move to a javascript file this is
a javascript file now inside here what
we'll do is we'll try to access this
particular image using the id attribute
for that we'll write here dollar then
inside double inverted commas we'll
write the id so we have to write here
img1 then we have to write the
interaction name only so we'll write
here resizable and then we'll use
parenthesis because this is a method and
i hope you guys are aware of all these
things by now
save the program and get ready to see
what this resizable interaction can do
with our dom element save it
here if you can see we have something
present in the bottom of this image we
have an icon over here
this is an indication for the user that
this particular image or element is
resizable we can't resize the element
from the left side or from the top
because the interaction is already
programmed in that way
we can grab the element from the right
side if we try to grab it from here and
if we try to resize it you can see we
are able to resize this image
similar thing goes with the bottom part
as well we can resize this image from
here as well
now talking about the options we have in
this interaction we can use animations
with this image to make it look more
engaging to the user so for that we have
to write here inside this resizable
interaction we have to use curly braces
for properties and then we'll write
animate we'll set this property to
true fine
save the program and now you can see
that the animation is taking place on
resizing this image if we try to resize
this image you can see the animation
over here
it is working totally fine other
properties include the containment
option we can limit the area of
expansion of this image we can restrict
it to the parent element or to the
document as well we have discussed this
property in the previous two
interactions as well so this property
remains the same
we'll write here containment
and we'll write here let's say
parent fine
now save the program
before that we'll comment this animate
property save it now
and here you can see we are able to
resize this image but up to a particular
extent we are not able to resize it
outside of the div tag
we can resize it from here as well
and you can see the div tag has its own
area we can't resize this image more
than this
and we can also limit the maximum and
minimum height of this image for that we
have to write here
max height so let's say the max height
is going to be 400 pixels then we'll
write here max width
the max width is going to be 400 pixels
again
we have to write here min height and min
width as well so let's say the main
height is going to be
150 pixels
and the min width is going to be the
same so we'll write here min width
and then we'll write here
150 fine
save the program and you can see we can
now resize the image up to a specific
height and width only if we try to
increase the width you can see we are
able to increase the width up to 500
pixels only and we are not able to
increase the height because of this
containment property we'll comment this
as well save the program and now we'll
be able to resize this image you can see
on resizing it from the bottom we are
able to resize it up to 400 pixels only
same goes with the width as well now if
we try to reduce the size of this image
you can see the minimum size is 150
pixels so this is where the image stops
same thing goes from the bottom end as
well now this is the minimum size of
this particular image according to these
properties the minimum height and the
minimum width is 150 pixels
we can also use the ghost property
instead of showing the actual image
during the resizing we can set the ghost
option to true to show a
semi-transparent part of the element so
let's do it here what we'll do is we'll
write here after this min width
we'll write ghost and we'll set this
property to true save the program and
now on resizing the image you can see if
we increase the size of this image we
have a semi transparent image which
helps us in resizing this image up to an
extent same thing goes with the
reduction of size as well the last
property we have is the aspect ratio of
the image we can either give a preserved
aspect ratio or we can also give the
boolean value
both the values for this option will
work totally fine for example if we
write here after this ghost property
aspect
ratio and if we set this property to
true
so before saving this we'll commend this
ghost property out save the program and
now if we try to resize the image you
can see the size of the whole image
resizing in a proper manner what else we
can do here is instead of setting this
property to true we can also write here
aspect ratio as
16 by
9. now this is the preserved aspect
ratio save the program and you can see
the image resizing in a different manner
now you can see the aspect ratio of the
whole image is changed
so these are the properties we have in
this interaction that can help us make a
more interactive or engaging website i
hope you guys got this jquery ui
provides many ways to change the look
and feel of a web page by using the
predefined customizations we have
we know everything about these
customizations by now because we have
been through them in almost all the
previous few videos
now the time has come when we'll go
through some more features which jquery
ui provides us
to make our web page more interactive
so let's add some widgets over here and
then it will be easy for you guys to
understand what we are talking about
here
so for that we'll add some widgets over
here we'll write here
div
will use a div tag so the first widget
we are going to use is the dialog box
widget or we can say the message box
widget so we'll write here dialog then
we'll write here title so let's say the
title is title 1 fine
now inside this div tag what we'll do is
we'll write here something so let's say
we are writing here this is a
customizable
dialog box
fine
so this is a very basic dialog box
now save it and you can see we have this
is customizable dialog box written over
here we'll write it this is a
customizable dialog box so save it now
so you can see it over here in the
browser
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
move to the jquery part and we'll write
some code there to make it look like a
dialog box fine
so here we are in the javascript file
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here some code so inside this
document.ready function so inside this
will write it down now we'll try to
access this particular dialog box we
have the ids dialog for that div tag so
we'll write here hash
dialog
then we have the widget name as
dialog fine so basically what we are
doing here is we are adding some widgets
to our web page now inside this will
write some properties for this
particular widget
so we'll write here
draggable so this is the first property
draggable will be set to true
then we have
resizable
we'll set this property to true as well
then we'll write here
close on escape
so this is the property where we press
the escape key from the keyboard and it
closes the dialog box we'll set this to
true as well
now the next thing we are going to do
here is we are going to write here model
so we will set the model property to
false for now
and then finally we will write here auto
open fine we will set this property to
true
save the program and move to the browser
here you can see we have a dialog box
with some text present inside it it says
this is a customizable dialog box and
the title is title 1 we can resize this
dialog box as well if we want to resize
we can do it and we can drag it also
because these two properties are set to
true by us
now the next thing we'll do is we'll add
another widget away
we'll discuss why we are doing so in a
while so let's do it quickly here what
we'll do is we'll move to html file and
will write here
after this
we'll write div will again use a div tag
so let's say the id is going to be we
are going to use the date picker widget
now beside this will keep it empty for
now
save the program and you can see we have
nothing over here on the browser so
let's move to the javascript file and
we'll add the datepicker widget now
here's a javascript file now what we'll
do is we'll write here
dollar
the id for this datepicker widget is
date so we'll write here hash
date
then we'll write here
datepicker fine
this is our widget
now we'll add some properties as well
here so we'll write here show other
months
and we'll set this property to true
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to write here
change month
we'll set this property to true as well
and then we have the change here
property so we'll set this to true as
well
now save the program
and you can see we have a calendar over
here that has some dates from the
current month
we have been through all these widgets
previously so i don't think that this is
going to create any sort of problem for
you guys so here we have two widgets one
is the date picker widget and the other
one is the message box which fine we can
add more widgets here as well but for
now let's go back to the main topic for
the video we are going to change the
look and feel of these widgets with the
help of color theme
for now if you see here in the browser
the default color of these widgets is
blue
so you can see if we select any date the
date changes to blue in color
so this is the default color which
jquery ui provides us now we can change
all of these things with the help of
theme customizations
now let's suppose we want the color
theme to be of different colors so let's
go through the jquery ui website and
we'll see what changes we can make and
how we can achieve those changes so here
we are on the official website of jquery
ui here you can see we have an option
named themes overview right click on it
and it will redirect us to a new page
here you can see we have several widgets
present over here we have almost all the
widgets present and the thing to notice
here is the base color of all the
widgets is blue right you can see it
over here the base color is blue for
this particular widget and anywhere you
can check the base color is blue for all
the widgets right
you might have noticed that we have
several options on the left we have roll
your own we have gallery and we have
help as well so let's click on help and
it will let us know more about this
theme roller thing
so you can see it's written over here
that theme roller allows you to design
custom jquery ui themes for tight
integration in your projects to create a
custom theme select the roll your own
tab and tweak the settings as you work
the ui components to the right will
update to reflect your design and you
can download your theme whenever you
like
fine so this is written over here we
have some more info about the theme
roller you can go through it if you want
to
now click on roll your own
and you can see we have several options
here right
so these options are for customizations
only
we can customize the whole web page
according to us from here the task is
simple customize everything according to
your need and click on the download
button the file will be downloaded and
you can use it later on
fine
the other option we have here is the
gallery the most simplified option
provided by jquery to its users click on
it and you can see we have different
predefined theme options to use for
click on any of these themes and you
will see that particular theme in action
right next to that particular theme you
can see we have clicked on ui darkness
and the ui is changed now the color
theme is changed basically we have
several themes over here we have sunny
we have overcast we have flick
we have redmond we have start and many
more right
so we are going to use these particular
customizations for now
so here what we have to do is we have to
click on any of them so let's suppose
for now we are clicking on ui darkness
we want to use this particular theme in
our web page click on it click on the
download button right below it
so it will redirect us to a new page
here we have the jquery version we want
to download you can see we have stable
for jquery 1.8 plus
we have then legacy and other versions
as well fine then we have several
options for different widgets
interactions and effect
let's say if we want to exclude any
particular widget from having this theme
color we can uncheck the box from here
and then we can download the file the
download button is present at the bottom
here you can see the download button
over here click on it and the download
will start we have a rar file downloaded
over here you can see we have a zip file
over here
so you can see it here on the folder
this is a zip file now what we'll do is
we'll extract all the files from this
folder
so we'll open it
here we are in the winrar then we'll
click on extract to and we'll choose the
folder where we want to extract these
files so for now we are going to extract
it in the downloads folder only click on
ok
and it's done
now check in your downloads folder so
what we'll do is we'll go to download
and here you can see we have this
particular folder over here
fine
now we'll close this tab for now
so here you can see we have jquery ui
1.13.1.custom so this is a custom
jquery ui file
now if we open this folder you can see
we have different files over here we
have the css files javascript files and
many more for now what we'll do is we'll
rename this particular folder we'll name
it as let's say
jquery ui dark this is our theme name
fine now what we'll do is we'll copy
this folder from here
so we'll copy it from here and we'll
paste it inside a jquery folder so here
is a jquery folder you can see we have
all the jquery files over here we'll
paste it here
now you can see we have the jquery ui
dark folder as well so what's happening
here is that all the jquery files will
be downloaded again the only change will
be present inside the css and the
javascript file
so the css files will remain the same
with some minor changes that will be
present inside the file the styling
changes basically what we are talking
about here
now the next task is to replace this
file with the previous one inside vs
code
so for that what we'll do is we'll close
this tab we'll move to vs code again
so here we are in the vs code now what
we have to do here is we have to write
here jquery ui dash dark
fine
we are done with it we'll copy it and
will change it for all the files
fine
now this particular program will access
all the jquery files from the jquery ui
dark folder not from the jquery ui
folder because we are willing to work on
themes so for that we have to mention
jquery ui dark over here
we have to change this for the jquery
file as well so what we'll do here is
we'll write here jquery ui dark
for this as well
now save the program and you can see
here we have the customizations applied
to our widgets the color theme is
changed it's dark now it looks beautiful
although so this is what theme
customization in jquery actually looks
like
jquery allows us to make our own
customizations with the help of several
easy methods i want you guys to make
some more interesting changes to these
color themes and let us know what
exciting thing you guys achieved
the calculator app is a simple program
to work on we have done such a task
using pure javascript in the past and we
already have an idea about how this
thing works
the task is simple we have to create an
app where we can perform several
arithmetical operations without a
problem
so we'll divide this program into three
different parts in the first part we'll
create the structure of this calculator
app using html then we'll style this app
using css and then finally we'll add
functionality using jquery this time as
simple as that
let's start with the programming part
directly we'll start with html by
creating the structure of our app so we
have several buttons in our calculator
app as we know we have numbers we have
operations we have many more other
buttons in a calculator app so let's add
them here now
what we'll do is we'll write here inside
the body tag so for now let's remove
this calculator using jquery heading now
we'll use dev tag over here
so we'll write here div
so we are going to use a class so let's
say the class name is
calculator fine
now inside this div tag we have to
create our calculator right so for that
the first thing we are going to do is we
are going to write here a paragraph so
we will write here inside this paragraph
jquery
calculator so this is going to be the
heading of our calculator
or we can use any image here as well if
you want to put any logo of your own in
your calculator so you can do that now
the next thing we are going to do here
is we are going to take another div
now inside this we are going to write
the program for the display area of our
calculator so what we'll do right here
is
we'll write here class
and let's say we are writing here class
root fine so this is our class name
now inside this dip we'll write
div
class is going to be let's say screen
and then we'll write here
numbers so let's say we are writing here
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and 9
fine
now we are done with this
save this and here you can see we have
one heading over here which is a jquery
calculator and we have 10 different
digits right
now the next task we are going to do
here is we are going to create the area
for a button so
we are again going to take a div tag for
that we are going to write here div
class is going to be the same so lets
say the class is going to be
cal
fine
we will change the name here as well
we'll write here calcula
now after this div tag we have to use
several div tags inside one div tag
right so we'll write a div
class is going to be let's say button
and then we have our first button as
let's say c
fine
we have to do this again we have to add
so many buttons so we'll write here div
then class is going to be button again
for this button as well
and the button name is going to be
this fine
the next thing we are going to do here
is we are going to write here div
class name is going to be button again
and we are going to write here
so lets change this class we are going
to put a backspace as well so we'll
write here backspace
button backspace basically
so
the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write the name of our
button over here so let's say the name
of our button is back for backspace
now the next thing we'll do here is
we'll use one more class we'll use one
more div tag so this time we are going
to use this one for plus minus so we'll
see the functionality of these buttons
later on for now just focus on the
structure of this
calculator so we are going to write here
div
and class is going to be
button
plus minus
fine
then we'll
make a symbol for plus and minus so
we'll write here plus and minus
fine
we have closed this div tag and another
div tag is also closed
right
let me zoom this out let me zoom visual
studio code a bit so that it will be
easy for you guys to understand for now
now what we are going to do is we are
going to add another button over here so
first for that we have to write here
div so let's say we have a button over
here as percent fine
so we'll write here class is going to be
button and the name of this button is
going to be percent
fine so let me break it down a bit so
that it will be easy for you guys to
understand
so here is the code we have these three
div tags inside single div tag this is
because what we are doing here is we are
adding a buttons over here so this is
the first row wherein we will have four
different buttons or we can say five
different buttons we have a c button
then we have c e
back plus minus and a percentage but
fine now what we'll do is we'll copy
this whole piece of code from here we'll
do the same for all the rules fine so
we'll
paste it here now we have to change the
button names so instead of c but we'll
do here in the second row we'll write
here 7
then we have 8
after ce
so we'll write here 8 then instead of
backspace we'll write here
9 and we'll change the class name to
button only fine we'll change this as
well instead of plus minus we'll write
here divide so we have a
divide symbol over here and the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to write here
square root in place of
remainder so for now we'll write sqrt
so i hope you guys understood this now
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to copy this from here
and we are going to paste it again
fine so let's change the name of this
class as well let's say
the name of this class is button device
for division
so we'll do the same thing for all the
arithmetical operators
so the next row is going to contain
five
then we have
six
okay we have to start this row from four
then we have five then we have
six
and the two arithmetic operators are
going to be multiply and
1 by x fine so we'll write yes asterisk
and instead of this we'll write here
1 by x
fine
so we'll change this class to button
inverse so that it will be easy for you
guys to identify all these buttons
that's why we are doing it and instead
of asterisk we'll write here button
multiply
fine so this is going to be the class
name for multiplication
i hope you guys got this
now we have to include two more rows
fine the next row is going to contain
so first we'll copy it from here we'll
paste it here
and the next row is going to contain one
two
three then we have two operators so the
two operators are going to be pi
and let's say
minus
okay so we have to write here minus and
we have to change the class to button
minus
and we have to write here
pi fine so we'll change this class to
button
pi
and we are done with four rows now we
have to include one more row so this row
is going to contain only four buttons
so we'll paste it here we have to remove
so we have to insert zero first so let's
say the class for zero is button
zero
and the class for decimal is going to be
button decimal so the next thing we have
to include here is decimal
we'll write here button decimal
and the third one is going to be plus
and equals to fine so we don't need this
tv tag here
we'll remove it from here and we'll
write here plus
so we'll write your button
e
for plus
and
okay so what we can do is we can write a
button add four plus and the last one is
going to be equals two so we'll write
here button equal
fine
so we are done with the html part we are
done with the structure basically let me
reduce the size of vs code now save this
program and you can see we have all the
buttons over here we have c c e back and
so on so you can see we have all the
numbers we have all the symbols and we
have some other symbols as well we have
pi over here we have 1 by x we have
square root and a lot more things right
now what we have to do is we have to
style these buttons so for styling let's
move on to the css file now and we'll
start styling our calculator there only
so here we are in the css file let's
start styling what we'll do is we'll
start with the whole body tag first what
we'll do is we'll write here body
and the body color is going to be
something different or we can say
something other than white right so
we'll write here background color
now we'll put some rgb values we have
some predefined rgb values with us so
we'll use them for now you guys can use
any color of your choice so we'll write
here 236 comma
232 comma
175 fine
so this is the rgb value for this
particular color
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here
margin top
margin top is going to be 150 pixels in
order to bring the calculator at the
center of the browser fine save the
program and you can see the change in
the background color
so the next thing we have to do is to
add the name of our calculator for that
what we'll do is we'll style a p tag so
you can see it over here inside the
html file we have to style this p tag
over here fine
so what we'll do is we'll write here
after this
p
we are going to style the whole tag
we'll write your margin
margin is going to be
0 for this one
then we have font family as well so
we'll write your font family
we'll use this one and the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to write
here font weight
font weight is going to be boulder
then we have position
position is going to be relative for
this
then we have
left so left is going to be let's say 35
fine we want it to be at the center of a
calculator
app
so that's why we are using 35 percent
over here save it now and you can see we
have jquery calculator heading present
at the center of the screen
so we'll achieve the whole calculator
step by step we don't need to hurry in
this
the next thing we have to do is to
create the body of this calculator now
for that what we have to do is we have
to use the calculator class
so if we move back to our html file you
can see the class name is calculator for
the parent div type
we are going to use this now what we'll
do is we'll write here dot calculator
this is how we can access any particular
class in css or in jquery as
now we are going to write here position
position is going to be relative
then we have margin
margin is going to be
1m
or 2. fine
the next thing is going to be padding
padding is going to be 1 m
and auto as well
okay so instead of auto what we can do
is we can write here 0 for padding we
don't want
any automatic padding in our program so
the display is going to be
inline block
the width is going to be
let's say 350 pixels fine
for the whole calculator body the width
is going to be 350 pixels
now the background color is going to be
h fine border radius we have to mention
here border radius is going to be 25
pixels okay 25 pixels we have to write
here
and the box shadow
box shadow will also define we'll write
a 5 pixel
5 pixel
15 pixel and then we'll write three
pixels so the box shadow is for all the
four sides of the box
then we'll mention the color as well so
let's say the shadow color is going to
be
black fine
now we'll write your font family
font family is going to be
oxy
so we'll write here oxygen
and that's it so save the program
and you can see we have the whole auto
body of our calculator now that we are
done with the outer body of a calculator
we'll move on and we'll work on the
buttons and rows now
so you can see we have the calculator
over here it's not present in between
for now
we'll discuss it why it's not working
fine so we have done a mistake over here
let me check
we have to write here
let's try block
inline
save it now and you can see the
calculator body is now present at the
center of a browser fine so that's why
it was not working now it's working
totally fine we have the calculator at
the center of our browser
now let's work on the buttons and rows
as well
what we'll do is we'll write here dot
calc row
so this is another class name you can
see it over here we have the class name
for screen
now what we'll do is we'll write here
text align at the
center fine save the program
and you can see we have the text aligned
at the center
the next thing to work on is the display
area for that we have the classes screen
inside the calcro class
so let's write the code over here for
the same what we'll do is we'll access
the screen so we'll write here dot calc
row
then we'll write here div dot
screen fine
now the font family is going to be
droid
sends mono
and the display is going to be
table
the next thing we are going to write
here is the width so width is going to
be 85 percent
following it will define the background
color as well so we'll write your
background color and the background
color is going to be
white
fine
not pure white it's sort of gray i guess
now i will write here text align text
align to the right
we are writing the code for the screen
fine guys so we'll write your font size
font size is going to be 2m
and
the main height so the min height is
going to be one point
2m
then we have margin left
it's going to be 0.5
m
heading right
fine heading right is going to be 0.5 m
again
the next thing is going to be border so
the border of screen is going to be of
different color so we'll
write here border
and the border is going to be one pixel
solid and
of
different colors so the color code is
triple eight for this particular color
and then we'll write here color
color is going to be
this one
fine
now save the program and you can see
here on the browser that the display
area is changed now you can see it over
here this is the display area of a
calculator app the color is changed and
the styling is also changed so we are
done with the display area now we will
work on buttons so let's move on and
we'll write the code for buttons
for that we have to write here dot calc
row
div
the first property is going to be text
align text align is going to be at the
center
display is going to be inline block
font weight is going to be bold
then we have border
is going to be 1 pixel solid and
of
raised color fine
then we have the background color
background color is going to be this
of white color we can say then we have
padding
padding is going to be 10 pixel and 0
then we have margin
margin is going to be 7 pixels
and
five pixels
fine
we have the border radius as well so
we'll write your border radius for the
buttons is going to be 15 pixel box
shadow we have to mention
box shadow is going to be 2 pixels
2 pixels 1 pixel and
1 pixel the color of box shadow is going
to be
dark gray
then we have width so width is going to
be 50 pixel
for each button
save the program and you can see we are
almost done with the app now the
calculator looks nice right the last
thing we have to manage are the buttons
present in the last row we are talking
about these four buttons over here so we
have to manage them what we'll do is
we'll increase the size of this equals
two button fine then it will look
completely nice so what we'll do here is
we'll write here
dot
calc true
then we'll write here div dot equal
will access the div tag with class is
equal
and we'll write here width
for this is going to be 112 pixel
fine then we'll again do the same thing
we'll write a calc row
div dot equal
and the margin left fine so we'll write
a margin left and the margin left is
going to be 5 pixels
save the program and you can see the
calculator is completely done now what
we did here is we increased the size of
our equals to button and we are good to
go now right
now that we are done with the structure
and styling of a calculator app the last
remaining part here is the functionality
of a calculator
we'll use jquery for adding
functionality to our calculator so let's
move on to the javascript file and we'll
write the code there for adding
functionality
so here we are in the javascript file
we'll start writing our code the first
thing we are going to do is we are going
to write here dollar
we are going to write here document
dot
ready
then we will write inside it function
and now we are good to write a code
so firstly we will take some variables
so we'll write your var
result this will hold the result
this variable is going to be zero
initially
then we have where
previous entry so we'll write here where
preventry
this is again going to be zero we are
initializing these variables with some
values
the next variable is going to be
operation
the value is going to be null at this
start
and then we have where
current entry
so this is going to be a string we'll
write here 0
and finally we'll write here update
screen this is going to be a function
so we'll write a result
that's it so these are all the variables
and functions we are going to use in a
javascript part or we can say the jquery
part now we have to add some events for
that we'll write a dollar
then we'll access the class
so we'll write here dot
button
then we'll write here on
click
so this is the event name we'll write
here
click
on clicking what we want is we want to
call a function fine so we'll write a
function
and this function is going to have a
parameter with it fine so this is it
inside this but inside this function
what we'll do is we'll check if the
button is pressed or not so we'll write
here where
button pressed
is equals to
will access the html document we'll
write here this
dot
html fine
now what we'll do is we'll write here
console dot
log
and inside this will write
button pressed fine so what we basically
did here is we wrote the code to check
if the button is pressed or not so if
the button is pressed the value will be
displayed on console so let's check it
out we'll zoom a chrome browser we'll go
to console
and we'll try to press a button you can
see the button is pressed
so it's working totally fine for now
it will do is we'll close the console
and we'll write the code again now the
next thing we are going to do is we are
going to write code for all the buttons
fine
what we will do is we will write here if
button pressed is going to be
c so this is our first button we are
going to write the code for this one
so then what will happen is the result
is going to be
0
fine
then we'll change the value for current
entry as well
we'll write here current entry and the
value of current entry is going to be
zero again fine now the next thing we
are going to do here is we are going to
write the code
for other buttons as well so we will
write here elsif
else if
button pressed is going to be
ee
then what will happen is
the current entry
is going to be
zero again fine
then we'll write the code for back plus
minus then we have decimal
and we have many more buttons right so
let's do it as well
we'll write here
elsif
the next button is back
we'll write here button pressed is
triple equals
to back
then we'll write here inside this
current entry
is equals to
current entry dot
sub string
and we'll define the sub string inside
we'll write here 0 comma
current entry dot
length
minus one so we are going to decrease
the length of our current entry by 1 on
pressing the back button
so it's basically the backspace key
now we are done with it
now the next thing we have to write here
is for plus minus so we'll write here
lsa
button pressed is going to be
plus minus
and what we'll do is we'll multiply the
current entry by -1 fine
so if the user has a value minus 3 on a
calculator screen and if he presses plus
minus so what will happen is minus 3
will be multiplied with minus 1 and the
value is going to be 3
fine so what we'll do is we'll write
here
current entry
is equals to minus 1 fine so we are
going to multiply this value by -1 then
we have else if
button pressed
is going to be
decimal so what we'll do is we'll add a
decimal in current entry so what we'll
write here is
we'll write here current entry
plus is equals
to decimal fine
then we have
is number
so if we write here else if
is number
and we have button pressed inside it
fine
now what will happen is
we have to use if here again we'll write
it
if current entry
triple equals to 0 current entry is
equals to button pressed so we'll write
here
current entry
is equals to
button pressed fine
now we have to write here else part as
well so we'll write it else
current entry is equals to
current entry plus
button pressed fine
so we are done with it now the next
thing we have to write here is the elsif
part so
we have to write the code for plus minus
multiplication and division as well
right so for that what we'll do is we'll
write here
is operator
so we'll write the code for all of them
later on so for now we'll write here is
operator
button pressed we have to write here
prevent free is equals to
pass float we have to
make this value in decimal so we'll
write your parse float
current entry
fine
then we have operation
so we'll update the value of operation
to button pressed
and we'll write here current entry is
equals to
now we have to write the code for
modulus we have to write the code for
square root we have to write the code
for 1 by x and we have to write the code
for pi so we are talking about this
particular row or we can say this
particular column where we have modulus
square root 1 by x and pi
so what we are going to do here is we
are going to write here else if
button pressed is equals to
modulus so what we have to do is we have
to
write here
current entry
current entry we have to divide the
current entry by 100 so we'll write here
current entry
is equals to current entry by 100 fine
then we have else if the user presses
square root
button pressed is equals
to square root
what we have to do is we have to write
here
current entry
is equal to we have to use math
dot
sqrt this is a predefined library so we
have to pass current entry inside this
so we'll write here current entry inside
this particular
library
now the next thing we have to write here
is the code for elsif
button pressed is going to be
1 by x
so
we have to write here 1
by
x
then the change is going to be in
current entry so we'll write here
current entry is equals to
1 divided by
current entry fine
now we are left with pi and is equals to
only so we'll write here for pi first
we'll write here else if
button pressed is going to be
pi
what we have to do is we have to write
here
current entry is equals to math dot
pi
fine
now we have to write here else if button
pressed is going to be is equals to
we have to write here current entry we
have to update current entry every time
so we'll write here operate
and we'll pass
preventry then we'll pass
current entry and operation
fine
and after this operation is going to be
null so we'll write your operation is
going to be
null fine now what we'll do is we'll
write here
date screen
update screen is going to be
the screen is going to be updated with
current entry basically so we'll write
here update screen and
current entry
fine
so let's check it out if this thing is
working or not save the program move to
the browser and
you can see it's still saying update
screen is not defined
fine let me check if there is any
mistake in our program so
what we have to do is we have to remove
this
bracket from here and we have to paste
them here at the end because we want
this program to be present inside these
brackets
save it now and let's see if it's
working or not
so you can see it's still not working
let's do one thing the update screen is
not defined it so we'll comment this
update screen for now
and we'll see if this thing works now or
not so you can see
it's working
for all the numbers but it says is
number is not defined yet so we'll
define it now
so let's move ahead and we'll uncomment
these two things we'll uncomment update
screen now
so the next thing we have to do is we
have to write the code for update screen
first so
let's do it
we'll write here
update screen
so update screen is going to be a
function so we'll write your function
function will
take a parameter we'll write here
display
value fine
so then we'll write here
where
display value is equals to
display value dot
tostring we are going to display the
value in string form so we'll write here
two string will convert it
and then we'll access screen so we'll
write here dollar
then we have the screen class as screen
then we'll write your dot html
we'll write a display
value
dot
substring fine so we'll write here 0
to 10
that's it
let's see we have defined update screen
as well now save it
and we'll move to browser will open a
console
so it says display value to is not a
function so we have made a spelling
mistake somewhere
here it is
i'll write here this
play value everywhere
fine
save it now
move to the browser
okay so it's saying display value is not
a function
as of now
we'll check it later if this thing works
or not so what we are going to do now is
we are going
to write further code so we will write
the code for is number first
we'll write here is number will check if
the entry provided is number or not so
we'll write here
function
function is going to bring a value
then we have
return
will return
is not a
number
fine
we will write your value
then we'll check for operator as well so
we'll write here is operator we'll write
function
and then we have the value of this
function
will return here something so we'll
write here return
value is equals to
the first value is going to be divide
or or periodically of value
triple is equals
to s trick for multiplication
our value is
going to be addition or it can be
substitution fine so we'll write your
value
minus
fine
now we have
to write a function so we'll use the
operate function so we'll write your
operate
function and it will have three
parameters a b and
operation
fine
now we have to write here a so is going
to be
parse float so we are going
to change the value of a to parse float
then we have b we'll do the same thing
for b as well we'll write your parse
float
write your b
then we'll write here console dot
log
a comma b comma
operation so this thing is to check
we'll write it if
operation is going to be
plus
then it will return
a plus
b
fine
same thing for all the operators
so we'll copy it from here we'll paste
it
four times we'll change the values over
here we'll write here plus minus
multiplication
and
division
fine we'll change the symbols here as
well we'll write here division
multiplication
subtraction and addition
so we are done with it let's check it
out if this thing is working or not so
it says
it's not working for now
let me check if there's any error or
some sort of thing
okay so we have done here wrong is we
have written here
to string with the smallest save it now
and check if it's working
okay it's working totally fine now you
can see
we have a
answers over here so you can see
everything is working
so
this is how it actually works so the
error was with two string actually we
have written here two string with the
smallest so we have to replace it with
capital s save it now and you can see
the calculator is working totally fine
let's try to do some calculations over
here first we'll increase the size of a
browser now let's say we are adding some
numbers so let's say we have
41 we are adding 9 in it so we have the
answer as 50. let's see if other buttons
are working or not so we'll write here
45 will click on plus minus and you can
see the value of plus minus is minus 45
click on it again you can see the value
is changed to 45 again
so the ce button is also working fine
we'll take a random number so let's say
the number is 400 we click on sqrt you
can see we have the square root of 400
which is 20.
now if we click on pi we have the value
as
3.1415 which is the actual value of pi
then we have modulus so let's say we are
writing here four thousand will click on
modulus and you can see
it is 40
so
[Music]
this is also working fine
now we'll write here 523
and then we'll click on one byte so you
can see it gives us the value of 1 by
523 or 1 by any number we are providing
it basically so let's say we are writing
here 10
and we'll click on 1 by x you can see
the value is 0.1 because it is dividing
1 by 10
so i hope you guys must have got an idea
about how we can create a calculator app
using html css and jquery it's easy to
create a calculator using jquery then to
use javascript for creating a calculator
right
now the task for you guys is to show
some creativity with what we have done
till now let us know in the comments
what exciting thing you did a to-do list
refers to a list of things or tasks
that a person wants to get done or that
need to be done
it contains a list basically so let's go
through the overview of what we are
going to do today
so here we are on the browser we have a
to-do list over here you can see we have
a text box over here to give some input
we have a button present next to it and
it says add
anything will write here and then if we
press add the task will be added to a
list below the text box
the list is unordered here so let's
suppose we have four tasks to do so what
we'll do is we'll write here task 1
we'll click on add then we'll write here
task
2
then we'll add task 3 and finally we'll
add task 4 as well
fine so here we have four tasks to do
now let's suppose we are done with task
one we did it whatever the task it was
what we want now is we want to remove
this task from the list double click on
task one and you can see the task fades
out
right the task is deleted the transition
here was smooth and interactive right
so another thing we can do is we can
change the positions of these tasks by
ourselves try to drag any task from here
you can see we are dragging task 2 in
place of task 4 you can see we have task
2 at the last and task 4 is present in
between now
fine
i hope you guys must have got the task
by now it's simple and what we have to
do is to create this whole thing on our
own from scratch we'll divide this thing
into three parts starting with html for
creating the structure then we'll move
on and work on the styling using css and
finally we'll use jquery to add
functionality
so let's start with the programming part
without wasting any time
so let me zoom out the chrome browser
here we are and here you can see we have
a html file which is named as 2d1.html
then we have linked the css file and the
javascript file here as well we have
used jquery and jquery ui fine so we'll
start writing the code here only what
we'll do is we'll remove this line from
here and we'll start writing you
so first thing first we have to take a
container for the whole box we are going
to make so we'll write here div
let's say the class is going to be
container for this dip
and here we have our first dip now we'll
add a heading so we'll write here
h2 now inside this will write let's say
to-do list using
jquery
fine
we are done with it the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to write
a paragraph over here we want this
paragraph to be bold and italic so you
can see it over here we have written
over here double click to delete an item
and drag to reorder so we'll do this
thing here now what we have to do is we
have to take a p tag for that
now inside this p tag we want this
paragraph to be bold and italic right so
we'll take
b
and i will take both the tags over here
now inside this will write
double click
to delete an item
and
drag to reorder fine so we have to write
a drag to reorder
we are good to
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to add a form so let's add a form
here as well
now what we'll do is we'll use the form
tag over here we'll write here form
the name is going to be let's say
to-do list fine this is the form name
we'll write here to do list
then we'll close this and inside here
we'll create an input box or we can say
a text box so for that we have input tag
so we'll write a input type is equals to
text
and let's say we have a name for this
text box fine so we'll write your name
is equals to list item
fine so we have list item over here now
what we'll do is we'll put this right
over here
now next thing we have to do is to add a
button for a
container so for that we'll write after
this form tag we'll write
div
id is equals to
let's say button
and the button name is going to be add
fine
then what we'll do is we'll use a br tag
over here
and after this we'll take unordered list
so we'll take ul tag over here
we'll see why we are taking it
so basically the ul tag here is for the
list items which will be taking as input
in the jquery part so let's style this
form as well but before that let's save
it
so you can see we have a text box over
here we have this heading over here we
have a paragraph we have a text box and
we have a button over here we haven't
used the button tag for this particular
button so we'll style it and we'll
manage to make it look like a button so
let's move on to the css part now
we'll start with the whole body of our
web page so for that we'll write here
body now inside the body tag what we'll
do is we'll write here background
color so we have some predefined color
over here in this particular to-do list
web page so you can see the color over
here is grayish in color so the color
code for this color is
hash 5 0
then we have 4 f4 f fine so this is the
color code
you can use any color of your choice so
for now we are going to use this save it
and you can see the color is changed to
gray
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to put this box in between
the web page right so we will write here
margin top margin top is going to be
let's say 150 pixels
save it and you can see we have the
to-do list over here
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to style our container as well for
that we'll write here
dot container
then inside this will write
padding so let's say the padding is 20
pixels then we have
width of the container so let's say the
width is 300 pixels
then we have margin so we'll write your
margin
0 and
order fine then we have margin top as
well so margin top is going to be 40
pixels
then we'll write here background color
so the background colors value is going
to be
202
comma 241 and then we have 239 fine so
this is
going to be the background color of our
container
now the next thing we have to mention
over here is the border radius and the
box shade so we'll write here border
radius
now the border radius is going to be
let's say 25 pixels
and then we have
box shell fine so for box shadow what
we'll do is we'll write your 5
pixels 5 pixels then we have
15 pixels
3 pixels
and then we have the rgb value so the
box shadow is going to be blackish in
color so we'll write here 54 54 54. it's
grayish although
now the next thing we have to do is to
style the form so for that we'll use the
form tag we'll write your form
we'll write a display
display is going to be inline and in
block
then we have the input tag as well so
we'll write here input
and we'll give some padding over here so
we'll write a padding is going to be
4 pixels and then we have 15 pixels
let's say 4 pixels and 5 pixels fine
then at the last what we'll do is we'll
style our button as well we have used
the div tag for a button not a button
tag so we'll style it as well so we'll
write your hash
button
now
this hash button is the id of a button
so we'll write here display
we'll write inline block then we have
after this display we have background
color
so the background color we have to
decide for our box so let's say
we want it to be
white in color fine
so let's say this is the background
color of a button
let's save it once
and you can see the background color is
white so what we'll do is
we'll change the background color over
here we'll write here hash
f1
let's say we want to make it bluish
fine so we'll write here f1 to dd
fine we have to put a 0 over here as
well
now it will look fine
save it and you can see we have a button
of blue color
so let's change the font color as well
so for that we'll write here color and
color is going to be white
save it now and you can see we have the
font color as white for a button then we
have to write here
border radius border radius is going to
be 5 pixels for this button then we have
text align at the center and after text
align we have margin top margin top is
going to be
two pixels
and then after margin top we have to
define the padding as well so we'll
write here padding as five pixels and 15
pixels
now save the program and you can see we
have a button over here the button looks
nice right
so the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here
button again we want to add hover effect
over here so we'll write a button hover
then inside this will change the cursor
to
pointer on taking it to the button
then we have
opacity as well let's change the opacity
on hovering as well so let's say the
opacity is going to be 0.8
now it's working fine we don't have to
put any space in between here
so let's do one thing the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to write
the styling code for unordered list as
well for unordered list will right here
padding
so padding left basically padding left
is going to be 20 pixels
and then we'll write here
font weight fine let's say the font
weight is going to be
bold
then we have
the list present inside unordered list
so we'll style that as well we'll write
here ul li
and now we'll style this as well we'll
write here padding
padding is going to be 5 pixel
and then we have
color
so the color is going to be
let's say
rgb
five comma five comma five so black
basically
and then we'll write here
font weighted so we'll write your font
weight the font weight is going to be
bolder
and that's fine so we have to
style every even element right if you
can see here in this particular program
you can see if we add something over
here the even elements are
having
gray background color right so that's
why we need to do this as well so for
that what we have to do is we have to
write here
uli then we have to mention the nth
child so
we'll write a nth child and we'll do
this for even child fine
so we have to write here then
a ground color so background color is
going to be
gray so the color code for this is
5 2 4
f
4
fine
then we have the text color as well we
want to make it white so we'll write
here white
and then we'll write here finally
font weight
onto it is going to be
bold
fine
so we are done with it
so the last thing we have to do is we
have to write some code for
deleting time as well so we'll write
here dot strike
and we'll write here
text decoration text decoration is going
to be line through
and we'll write here
nothing so just leave it here now the
next thing we are going to do is we are
going to write the code for hovering
over the list we'll write here li hoover
then we'll write cursor
as point fine
so we are done with the css part now
save it
and you can see here the changes in the
web browser we have the whole to-do list
interface over here
the only thing left now is functionality
so let's do that as one we'll move to
the javascript file and add
functionality to this web page there
using jquery so here we are in the
javascript file we'll do a jquery part
over here so first of all we'll write
here dollar
document
so we are going to use the
document.ready function so we'll write
here ready
now inside this will write function
and we have the body of this function so
we are good to go we are good to write a
program now
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to add the task entered in the text
box inside the list right for that what
we have to do is we have to write here
doll we have to access a button so we
have the button ids
button so we'll write here button
then we'll use the click event we'll
write here click
now we'll define a function inside it so
we'll write your function
and inside the body of this function
what we'll do is we'll write here
where
so we have to write here where
to add and then we have to add the
element fine so we'll write here dollar
now inside this we have the input text
so we'll write it input
inside this will write name is equals to
list item so we have the name as list
item for input box right if you guys
remember that
if we go back to our html file you can
see we have the name as list item for
this input tag over here
so we are using the same then we'll
write here dot
value so whatever value that will be
present inside the text box or that
would be entered inside the text box
will store inside
to it will store inside this particular
variable fine so we'll write your dot
well
now we have the value inside this
particular variable what we'll do is
we'll append this to unordered list fine
so we'll write here
dollar
we have an ordered list so we'll write a
ul then we'll write here append
fine
now inside this what we'll do is we'll
write here
like we want to add this as list so
we'll write here li
then we'll add
to it over here fine so we'll write here
2i
and then we have
to close this li tag away fine
so save the program now and what we'll
do is we'll try to add something to our
list fine
so here we have our program we'll save
it we'll try to write something over
here we'll write it task
11
so we have to write it task 11 click on
add and you can see we have task 11
written over here similarly we'll write
here task 12 click on add we have task
12 over here
13
and then we have 40
rest of the things are not working we
are not able to sort this list as of now
because we haven't
done the programming part for that right
now
the next thing we have to do is to
remove any item from the list on double
click right for that we have to create
an event and we have to tell the system
basically to remove a particular item on
double clicking the task is simple we'll
use the fade effect present in jquery so
what we'll do is we'll write here dollar
document
and then we'll write your dot on we'll
use an event so we'll
write here the event name is double
click fine so we'll write here double
click this is the event name this is a
predefined event in jquery then we have
to write here li because we want to
remove an element from the list only
fine then we'll
declare a function over here now inside
the body of this function will write a
code we'll write here dollar
then we'll write here this
dot
toggle class
i'll write here strike
so we are toggling a class from the css
part then we'll write here dot
paid out fine
and let's define the speed of this fade
out as well we'll write here slow
we have made a mistake over here so we
have to write here fade out
now we have another error over here we
forgot to put a comma over here so we'll
write here comma
that's it guys the list item will fade
out if we double click on it now
so let's check if it's working or not
save the program
try to add something here over here
we'll write here task
11
12
then we have task 13 and then we have
task 14 fine
now we'll try to delete a particular
task let's say we want to delete task 12
double click on it and you can see it's
working totally fine right the task is
deleted the task is not present here
anymore
now we are done with the adding and
deleting part
but if you see here when we add
something to a list so let's add one
item over here first let's say we are
adding task
15 fine click on add
and the item is here fine when we click
on the text box again the previous item
is still here what we want is we want
the text box to be empty once the item
is added to the list so for that what we
have to do is we have to write over here
dollar now we have to access this input
box so we'll write here input
then we have dot
focus
and we'll create a function inside this
so we'll write your function
now inside the body of this function
we'll write dollar
this
dot
well
and we'll write here
this fine
save it and you can see it here it will
work fine now if we write here let's say
task one click on add click on the text
box again and you can see the text box
is empty now
the last thing we have to manage here is
sorting them on dragging right sorting
the list item on breaking for that we
have to use the sortable interaction
from jquery ui
so we don't need to write anything over
here just will write here
dollar we have to sort this unordered
list right so we'll write here ul then
we'll use the sortable function so we'll
write your sortable
and we are good
fine so that's it guys we are done with
it the to-do list is done so let's try
to use it once and we'll understand it
much better
save it now and we'll see if this thing
is working fine or not we'll add some
tasks over here so let's say we are
writing over here task
51
this is our first task we'll put a space
in between over here
then we have
task
52 fine then we have item one
and
item two
fine
so we have four items and tasks over
here so basically what we want to do is
we want to check if this thing is
working or not double click on task 51
you can say it's working
try to drag item one from here in place
of item two you can see we are able to
do it item one is present at the bottom
now
one more thing we want to do here is we
want to add one more item over here
we'll add
task 53 as well click on add you can see
we have task 5253 and item one will
delete all of them
so let's try to do it double click on
each item you can see
the item is deleted now click on the box
again and you can see the box is also
empty so it's working totally fine now
the task for you guys is to make some
changes to this particular program and
let us know if you can do anything more
with this particular program
so far we have seen various different
topics related to jquery in this
particular playlist we came across
jquery effects animations callbacks and
then we moved on to jquery ui wherein we
covered topics like widgets interactions
theme customization and menu
let's use some of the concepts in a
website today let's move ahead and we'll
take an overview of what we are doing
today the task is simple we will create
a movie downloading website from scratch
using html css and jquery only
so here we are in the website wherein
you can see we have the front page of
our website here we have some text which
says download your favorite movie in
just a click and then we have welcome
written over here right
the page seems simple the first thing we
have here is the navigation bar which
will navigate us to different sections
of the website we have home about
categories top rated and contact over
click on any of them and it will take us
to that particular section in our
website
if you see here we have two arrows
present at the bottom of our home page
if we click on it it will take us to the
about section right here we have some
more text present we have the contact us
button present over here and it will
take us to that particular section click
on it and here we are at the contact us
section of our website
the next section contains categories of
movies we have in our website we have
six different categories present over
here hover your mouse cursor over any
and you can see the animation in that
particular category
the next thing we have are the top rated
movies the hover effect you can see here
as well but if we click on any image you
can see the image size is larger now and
we can also use these arrows to change
the mode right you can check all the top
rated movies over here
now in the last part we have the contact
us page wherein if we write our name
email and message and then if we click
on send message button a dialog box will
appear on a screen and it will say
something so let's try to do it here
we'll write here caution
then let's say we have a email id over
here we'll write here caution
at the gmail.com
and then let's say we are writing
something over here now click on the
send message button you can see we have
a dialog box which says thank you for
contacting us we'll get back to you soon
don't forget to check your email
fine
the task is simple right i hope you guys
must have got the task by now all we
have to do is to recreate this whole
thing from scratch on
so let's get back to the programming
part without wasting any more time
here we are in the vs code and we have
all the required files present in our
system already if i show you once you
can see we have this whole folder
present in our system where we have all
the files images and everything we need
to create this website
we have the jquery file the jquery ui
file and almost everything we need right
you can see it over here we have images
over here we have icons we have the
jquery ui file we have project content
and many more things right
so let's minimize this for now
now let's move on to the html file first
and we'll start by designing the layout
of our web page or we can say website we
have to create a preloader thing before
we create the body of our website so
we'll keep these small things in mind
and later we'll see what vital part
these small things play in making a
website more interactive to the user
so we'll start the code by writing over
here inside the body tag so let's use
comments for different sections so we'll
write here
preloader fine so this is a comment now
we'll start writing the code for prelude
so first thing first we'll write here
dip we'll take a div tag
we'll write a class so let's say the
class name is
preload now we'll close this div tag
and inside this will create another div
tag
so we'll write here div
class is equals to let's say
load
fine so we are done with preload we'll
comment it out once again we'll write
here
reloader ends fine so our preloader ends
over here
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to start writing the code for the
head section of a
website so
we'll
write here
head section starts
so now we'll write the code over here
for the head section so the first thing
we have to write here is we have to take
the header tag we'll write your header
class is going to be
header for this
and then we'll close this header
now inside this we'll write div
class is equals to let's say
container
so
we have to take so many div tags so keep
these things in mind
so the next thing we are going to write
here is we are going to write here
div
now class is going to be let's say
row justify
content between fine
and then we'll write here a line
items at the
center
fine so we have
taken this class name as row justify
content between and align items center
so now inside this what we'll do is
we'll write here
div
class is equals to
brand name so we'll write your brand
name
fine now we'll close this div tag and
inside this will take
an anchor text so we'll write here a
href is going to be
index.html so
this is the link now what we'll do is
we'll write here
movie
menu fine
now after this div tag what we'll do is
we'll write here
if
class is equals to
nav toggle fine
so this is the class for a navigation
bar now
inside this will write here
span will close the span tag we'll keep
it empty for now now after this div tag
we have to write here
nav class is equals to let's say neff
we'll close this div tag now inside this
we'll define a
items we'll write here home about
categories top rated and contact find
now inside this nav tag we'll write here
you will take an unordered list now
inside this unordered list we have to
use the li tag
so we'll write your li anchor tag now
inside this anchor tag we are going to
write href is equals to
home so this is the id for home page so
we'll write here
home
now we'll do the same for every category
or we can say every item in the menu so
we'll copy it from here
we'll paste it
five times
fine so here we are now the next thing
we have to do is we have to change the
names so instead of home after we have
about so we'll write here about
then we have the
categories so we'll write here
categories
we have to change the id as well so
we'll write here
category
then after categories we have
top rated movies so we'll write here top
rated and the id is going to be let's
say
top then we have the contact us fine so
we'll write here
contact and instead of home we'll write
here
contact fine so we are done with it we
are done with the header so
the next thing we have to do is we have
to write here after this header
we have to mention it over here that the
header ends over here so we'll write a
header end
now we have to start the next section so
the next section is going to be
home section so we'll write here home
section
starts
and after this we'll write the code for
home section
so the home section starts with the
section tag will write your section
class is going to be home
so let's name it as home section this
class
will write here id as well so let's say
the id is home
now we have to create a shape over here
if we move back to our website and if we
go to the home page you can see we have
a shape over here the shape is rotating
360 degrees so we'll create the shape
first now for that what we have to do is
we have to write here
we have to close this
section tag first now inside this
section tag will
mention a comment again so let's say
we'll write here shape for this
particular shape now what we'll do is
we'll write here div
class is going to be
shape
0 1
so this is the class name
now we'll close this div tag
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to take another dev tag we'll
write here div
class is equals
to container
now we have to take another div tag over
here we'll write here class is equals to
oh
align items
and
center fine
we have to close this dev tag over here
now inside this we have to write
another div tag so we have to take
another div tag we'll write here if
class is equals
to home content
and now over here what we'll do is we'll
take another h4 tag so we'll write it
over here h4 and we'll write over here
this thing will write download your
favorite movie in just a click copy it
from here we'll paste it inside the h4
tag
now we are done with the heading so
after this what we'll do is we'll
take another heading we'll take h2 tag
we'll write here h2 and we'll write here
welcome to
movie menu fine
so we are done with it now the next
thing we have to do is we have to make
these arrows over here so if we move
back to our website you can see we have
two arrows over here which takes us to
the about a section so we have to write
the code for these two arrows as well so
after this we'll write over here
inside comment so we'll write over here
scroll down
now we have to write the code over here
so we'll write here a
href is equals to
about and then we'll write here
class is equals to
scroll down fine
now we have to
use icons so what we are going to do is
we have already have these icons present
in our system so we'll mention them over
here we'll write here img
src is going to be inside the images
folder what we'll do is we'll
move inside the icons and inside the
icons we have this file over here arrow
down dot svg so this is basically an
icon so we'll write your alt
and inside this will write
scroll down fine
so this thing is done
now
the anchor tag is done
so we'll move
back from here now the home section ends
over here so we'll write here
inside the comments
we'll write home section
and fine
so we are done with the home section
let's check it out once save the program
open it with live server and you can see
we have all these things over here we
have home about categories top rated
contact and then we have two headings as
well fine
so we are not able to see the icon as of
now we'll style it later on
now let's move back to the programming
part so the home section we are done
with the home section the next section
we have to work on is the
about section so we'll write here about
section start
now the about section what we have to do
is we have to write a section
we have we are going to take the section
tag again so we'll write here class is
equals to
about section
now the class is done we have to write
the id as well the id is going to be
about fine now inside the section tag we
have to take another div tag so we'll
write here div
class is going to be container for this
one as well
and now inside this div tag what we are
going to do is we are going to take some
more div tags we will write a div class
is equals to row
so this is the class name
now what we have to do is we have to
write
some more things about the image so we
have an image already over here you can
see if we move back to our website so we
have this image over here as well now
what we'll do is we'll write some code
for this image as well so let's move
back to the html file and will write
here
div
class is equals to img box
so this is going to be the name of our
class
and inside this we'll take another div
tag and we'll write here
class is equals to shape
zero so why we are doing here so because
is because
if we move back to our website you can
see we have this shape over here as well
so we'll style this shape as well later
on in the css file for that we need to
mention the class so that's why we are
using here class is shaped
fine
now after this what we are going to do
is we are going to write here
img so we are going to add the image now
we will write here img src is going to
be
inside the img folder
we have about dot png and we have to
mention the alternate here as well so
we'll write here alternate
as
about us fine close the img tag
and we are done with it now inside this
div tag what we have to do is we have to
write here div
class is equals to
about
content
and then we have this
div as
class
row
now inside this what we have to do is we
have to mention the section title so the
section title is about us so we'll write
some code for that as well we'll write
here div
class is going to be
section title
now inside this what we are going to do
is we are going to take the h1 tag and
will write here
about us fine
now after these two div text what we
have to do is we have to mention a
paragraph here
so the paragraph is this one over here
so this is the paragraph this is nothing
but a paragraph which most of the
prototypes of any websites use so what
we'll do is we'll copy it from here
and what we are going to do is we are
going to use the p tag inside the
paragraph tag we are going to paste this
fine
so this is a paragraph now we are done
with the paragraph tag as well
after the paragraph tag what we have to
do is
we have to write here
if
we are going to take another div we will
write here class so class is going to be
stats for all the stats we have for our
website now inside this div tag we are
going to take another div tag we'll
write here div
class is equals to row
and over here we'll write diff
class is equals to
stack box fine
so we are writing the code for these
stats over here we have daily downloads
movies available and happy clients right
so we are writing the code for this only
now after this what we have to do is we
have to close this div tag
and inside over here we have to write
h2
and inside h2 we'll write 150 k
plus
fine now we have to write it over here
h5
so let's say we are writing over here
daily downloads
so we are done with it the next thing we
have to write here is div
class is going to be
stat box again
now inside this div tag we'll write h2
the heading is going to be
2500 plus
and then we'll write h phi
fine for h5 what we'll write here is
movies available
so we have to do this thing for
more time we'll copy this piece of code
from here we'll paste it here
the class will remain the same now
instead of 2500 we have to mention the
happy clients over here so we'll write
here
one million plus and instead of movies
available we'll write
happy clients fine
so we are done with it now after this
particular div tag what we have to do is
we have to mention the contact button as
well so we'll
mention the heading over here we'll
write here
contact button and we'll write the code
over here so the code starts with a
href is equals to hash contact this is
the contact this is the id basically for
the contact page for the contact section
so then we'll write a class as
button button one
and we'll write here
contact
us
fine
so the anchor tag is closed we are done
with the section so
we are done with this particular section
as well so what we'll do is we'll write
here
about us ends over here so we'll write
about this end or we can say about
section end
so we are done with the about section as
well save the program for now move to
the browser and
here you can see it's not
okay it's working so here you can see if
i increase the size of a browser you can
see this is a about section we have an
image over here we have about us we have
all the stats we have daily downloads of
150 000 and plus we have movies
available over 2500 and we have one
million plus happy clients then we have
a link over here for the contact us so
we'll create a button later on in the
css part for this
so let's move on to the programming part
again
now the next section we have to mention
over here is the categories section
so if i take you to this website you can
see we have categories over here we have
six different categories
so we have to write the code for this
part as well so let's move ahead and
write the code for categories as well
so we'll write here
categories
and we'll write here section
start fine
so the category section starts over here
what we'll do is we'll take a section
tag again so we'll write here section
class is equals to let's say service
section
and then we have id fine so id is going
to be
categories
we'll close this section tag now inside
this section tag will table take a div
tag if class is going to be
container
and inside this will take another dev
tag we'll write here div class is row
and inside this will take another div
tag so we'll write here dev class is
equals to
section title
so we are using all these classes
because we'll need them in the css part
so
what we'll do is we'll write here
h1
now inside h1 will write
categories
fine now over here what we'll do is
we're going to take div class is going
to be row
and what we'll do is we'll write here
the code for all the category item so
basically we have six different category
items we have six different categories
of our movies so if you can see it over
here we have western mystery drama
animation comedy and fantasy so we'll
write the code for them
now inside here what we'll do is we'll
write over here
first we have to mention
let's mention it over here what we are
doing here so we'll write here
categories
start fine
so what we'll do is we'll start writing
the code over here we'll take a div tag
class is going to be
service item
so we'll write your service item
as the class name and
inside this we are going to take another
div tag we are going to name it as
service item
inner so this is going to be another
class
now inside this what we are going to do
is we are going to write here
the image code right we are going to add
the image over here so we will write a
img
src is going to be
img slash
so we have service folder so we'll write
your service now inside the service we
have one dot png as a image so we'll
write here alternate as
category 1
now close this
after this we have to take another div
tag we'll write a div
classes
overlay so we'll write here class is
overlay
now inside this what we'll do is
we'll write the heading so basically we
are going to mention the category name
over here so we'll write here
h3
and inside h3 we'll write
western fine so this is going to be the
first category
now so the first service item or we can
say the first category ends over here
now
after this what we have to do is we have
to add five or six more categories right
we have to add six categories to our
website so what we are going to do is we
are going to write the code for second
category of a movie
so we are going to copy this from here
and we are going to paste it over here
so the class name will remain the same
the class name will remain remain as
service item then we have the inner
class name as service item inner then
inside
this image source what we have to do is
we have to change the image over here
we'll write two dot png over here the
overlay class will remain the same
now instead of western we have to write
here
mystery so we'll write a mystery
so this is a second category now what we
have to do is we have to copy this piece
of code again
so we have to do it for
six categories right so we are we are
already done with two so we'll paste it
four times
fine now what we have to do is we have
to
change the image name over here so we
have three
and
then instead of mystery we have
drama fantasy comedy and
lastly we have animation so this one
will
be
drama fine so we'll write here drama
then we have
here as
four dot png then instead of
mystery what we have here is
fantasy
so we'll write your fantasy and after
fantasy we have this image name as five
dot png
and the category name is going to be
comedy and so we'll write here
comedy
at number fifth and lastly we have
animation so for animation
the image is sex dot png and instead of
mystery we'll write here
animation
fine
so we are done with it
now the categories ends over here so
we have to
close the section tag as well so
basically what we are going to do is we
are going to write here
category section ends so we'll write a
category section ends over here
now what we have to do is we have to
save this program move back to the
browser
and you can see it over here we have
western we have mystery
we have drama fantasy comedy and
animation we have all the six categories
right we'll style them later according
to our needs in the css part so for now
what we are doing is we are creating the
layout of our website so this will
remain the same now let's move ahead and
we'll write the code for next section so
the next section we have is the top
rated section so we'll write here
top rated section
start
now what we have to do is we have to
take the section tag again so we'll
write here section
class is equals to let's say work
work section so this is going to be
the name of our class for top rated
section so we'll write here id as
top now fine
now the next thing we have to do is we
have to write here div
class is equals to container
and then we have div class is equals to
row here fine now inside this div with
class as row what we have to do is we
have to mention the section title the
section title is top rated movies so
this part will remain the same for all
the sections so we'll write here div
class is equals
to
section title so we'll write here
section
title
and after this we'll write here
h1 and then we'll write here
top rated
movies fine
so we are done with the heading now
inside this what we have to do is
we have to mention all the
six different top rated movies we have
right so what we are going to do is we
are going to write here
if
class is going to be row again
now inside this div tag what we have to
do is we have to mention
all the six top rated movies fine so
we'll write
here top rated movies start
now after this what we are going to do
is we are going to take another div
class is going to be work item
and now inside this div tag we have to
write here div
class is going to be
work item in
fine
now inside this we have to add images so
we'll write here img we are going to add
two images basically so
we'll
discuss it later why we are doing so
so we'll write a img src and src is
going to be
img slash
works
and inside the works folder we have
another folder as thumb now we'll
add one dot jpg from here this is
the base file will write here data large
and inside the data lodge what we are
going to do is we are going to write
here img
slash
works slash large
and we have this
one dot png over here so these
two files are basically same files so
they are saved with different names one
is a png file and another one is the jpg
file we'll write here alt
will write here
movie 1 fine
now close this and
after this what we have to do is we have
to create a div tag with class s
overlay and we have to write something
over here we have to write the heading
so
the heading is going to be
fine so this is the heading of our first
movie
now what we have to do is we are done
with the first item so
what we'll do is we'll copy this piece
of code from here we'll paste it here
for
the second movie the second movie we
have
the image as 2.jpg and 2 dot png now
instead of doctor strange the second
movie name is
captain marvel
fine so we'll write here captain marvel
then we'll
copy this and we'll do the same for
almost all the movies right for all the
top rated movies
so we are done with this part
we are done with doctor strange and
captain marvel then we have
three dot png and jpg as the file name
or as the image name so instead of
captain marvel
we have aquaman
so we have all the movies from
repeat so we have movies from marvel
universe and from dc universe i believe
that you guys might be a fan of any of
these universe
so let's
move ahead and instead of
aquaman we have four dot jpg and four
dot png as a next file name and instead
of this captain marvel what we have here
is
x-men
fine
then
over here we have to mention the file
name is
and instead of movie name what we have
to write here after x-men is
guardians of the
galaxy
then the last movie we have is
the arc night so we'll write here the
dark
knight
and we are done with the
top rated movie part as well so the work
section ends over here or we can say the
top rated movie section ends over here
so we'll mention it over here we'll
write here
top rated end
so we are done with the top rated
section as well save the program once
move to the browser
and if we check it over here you can see
we have all the movies we have dark
knight guardians of the galaxy x-men
aquaman captain marvel and
doctor strange so it looks
really simple for now right we'll change
them in the css part as i mentioned it
earlier as well we'll do it in the css
part so don't be so stressed for now
let's move ahead and we'll write the
code for contact us section so we'll
mention it over here
we'll write here
contact section starts
and now we'll start writing code for
contact section
so the first few things will remain the
same we'll write here section
now inside section we'll mention class
is
contact section
now the id is going to be
contact
and we'll write here inside the section
tag
if class is going to be
container
and inside this div tick we have another
div tag with class is
row now inside this we have diff with
classes
img box so we'll write a img box
as class name
now inside this will
write div class is
section title
so this is the section title so section
title is contact us so we'll write here
inside h1 tag
contact us
over here
now what we have to do is we have to add
a form over here so what we'll do is
we'll write it after this div time so we
are done with the heading part basically
now after this we are going to write
here
dip
class is going to be
row
for the form
we'll write here div
class as
contact form
now inside this div tag we have to
create a form so we'll use the form tag
for it we'll write your form
class is going to be form
and then we have to write here div class
is
row
inside this div tag we have to take
another div tag so we'll write here div
class as
left
input
group
this is a class name
then we have label
as
name
we'll write here
input
type is going to be text
and we'll write here placeholder
placeholder is going to be
your name here
and then we have classes input
control
fine
this is a class name
so we have added a placeholder over here
for name now similarly what we have to
do is we have to
add these placeholders for email or
phone and for your message so we'll
write here
div
class is equals
to right this is going to be present at
the right side so we'll write here input
group
now we'll write here label
label is going to be email or
phone
so this is the label for a second
placeholder
now we are going to write here the same
thing we'll write here input
type is going to be text
placeholder is going to be
email or phone here so we'll write here
your email or
phone here
and we'll write here classes
input
control
and that's it so we are done with this
placeholder as well
now we have to write some code for the
text area basically for the message box
we are going to write here
diff class is going to be row again so
we'll write a div class is true
now inside this we are going to write
here div
class is
input group so we'll write here input
group
now we are going to mention the label
over here so we'll write here label and
the label is going to be
message
fine and we are going to write here text
area the text area
class is going to be
it put control once again so we'll write
your input control and then we have
placeholder which says your
message here
and we'll close this text area away
fine so we are done with this part as
well now what we have to do is we have
to create the form button for send
message
so for that what we'll do is we'll write
here
div class is
form button
and inside this div tag we have to take
a button so we'll write your button type
is going to be
button and then we have class is
button button 1
id is going to be
button again then we have the button
name so the button name is going to be
send message
now after this div tag what we have to
do is we have to add a dialog box over
here so we'll write here
div
id as let's say dialog for this dialog
box
then we'll write here
thank you for
contacting us and
we'll get
back to you soon
don't forget
to check your email
fine
so this
is the text that will be present inside
the
dialog box fine
so we are done with it
we are done with the form tag now inside
the section tag we have to mention some
more things so we are going to mention
the things present
after this form so if we move back to
this website over here
you can see we have this form over here
we have the send message button now we
have to mention these three things we
have to mention address phone email and
then we have some icons for facebook
twitter linkedin and instagram
fine so we'll write the code for this
thing only now
so let's move back and now after this
particular div tag what we have to do is
we have to create another div tag we'll
write your div class is
row
now inside this div tag we have to write
here div class is
contact info this is going to be the
class for this particular div tag
now inside this we have to take another
div tag we have to mention the class is
row over here
now what we'll do is we'll write over
here
div
class is equals
to info item and we have to mention
address over here so we'll write a h5
address and
we have to write here address now after
this address we have to mention our
address so we'll mention it inside the
paragraph text so we'll write your p
now mention the address over here we'll
write your sector
let's say
xyz
and
a
website is present in usa so we'll write
a usa then we'll write here
some number so let's say this is our
address now after this div tag we have
to mention the phone number here so what
we'll do is we'll copy this from here
we'll paste it here the class name will
remain the same the heading will change
to
phone and we have to mention the phone
number over here so we'll write here
9 1
and then we'll mention
some number fine
so this is the number and then we'll
copy it from here and
we'll do the same thing for
email list so we'll write here email in
place of phone
now we have to mention the email of our
website so we'll write here
movie menu at the rate
movie dot
com
fine
so this thing ends over here we have all
our div tags ending over here we have
the section tag
but before we close the section tag so
what we have to do is we have to include
the icons for facebook twitter linkedin
and instagram fine so we have to add
them as well
so what we'll do here is we'll write
here
if
class is going to be row again
now inside this will write div
class is going to be social links so
we'll write here
social
links
now inside this we have to mention them
we have to write a anchor tag we will
write your href
href is say hash for now
we'll write your title title is going to
be
facebook
and then we have to add the image or we
can say the icon so we'll write here img
src is going to be
inside the img folder we have this
icons so we'll write your icons and
inside this we have
facebook.svg fine so this is the icon we
have already downloaded we'll write your
alt
alt we have to mention here is
facebook
we have to close the img tag and that's
it we are done with the facebook part
so what we'll do next is we'll copy it
from here
we'll paste it here again four times we
have facebook then we have
twitter linkedin and instagram right so
we'll write your title as
twitter
and we have this file name here as
twitter.svg will change the alternate as
well we'll write here
twitter
then we have the same thing for
linkedin so we'll write here linkedin
the icon name we have here is linkedin
linkedin.svg we'll change the alternate
as well we'll write here
linkedin
and finally we have instagram as well so
we'll write here instagram
the icon name is
instagram.svg then we have
instagram over here as well
so we have added all the icons over here
we are done with the contact section as
well so this is a contact section if you
can see it starts from here we have
added a form wherein we have to put
name email and a message then we have a
send message button over here
and finally we have
these addresses and social media links
fine
so we are done with this part save the
program now
and we'll move back to a browser so here
you can see
at the bottom we have these
icons so the icons are pretty large in
size
we'll
style them later according to our need
in the css part so for now we have these
four icons we have facebook twitter
linkedin and instagram so you can see we
have everything over here we have
address we have phone email and we have
the form we have to write a name message
we have to write a message over here we
have to write an email and then we have
a button for send message
you can see we have written over here
thank you for contacting us we'll get
back to you soon don't forget to check
your email so everything is working
totally fine till now
let's move ahead and we'll write some
more code over here after this
particular section we have to mention
the copyright section as well so for
that
we have to write here
p
class is going to be
copyright so we'll write your copyright
and inside this will write
copy
then we have semicolon it says
2022
india
fine so we'll write here movie mania in
capitals
and that's it we are done with the
footer part as well we are we have
mentioned the copyright as well now the
last thing we have to do is to we have
to mention the light box so the light
box is basically we moved back to our
website and here you can see if we click
on any of these
images from the top rated movies you can
see that particular image getting larger
in size and we can change it right so we
have to write the code for this
particular light box as well so we'll
move back to our html part and we'll
mention it over here we'll write here
lightbox
start
and we'll write here
diff class is going to be light box for
this particular
light box
and then we'll write here
div class is
img box so inside this div tag what we
have to do is we have to take another
div tag we'll write a div class as
light box close
we'll do most of these things in the
jquery part so for that we are taking
all these classes and all so we'll write
here ampersand times
now we have to write it over here like
this and then we have
the image source so we'll write img src
is going to be
imj inside the works folder we have this
large files so we'll write a large then
we'll write here
two dot jpg
then we have the class as
lightbox img so we'll write a lightbox
img and
we have to mention the alternate as well
so we'll write img1
and then we have to mention the caption
as well so we'll write here
dev class is equals to
light box caption so we'll write here
light box
caption
and we have to close this div deck now
we have to write here
div class is
light box
category
we have to close this div tag and we'll
keep this empty for now
fine
we have to do this for all the images so
what we have to do is we have to write
here after
this particular div tag we have to
mention it inside over here we have to
take another div tag we'll write here
diff
class is going to be
light box counter
will write your light box counter we
will close the zip tag
now again what we have to do is we have
to take another div tag over here we'll
write a class as
light box
controls
now we have two icons over here we have
the previous icon and the next icon fine
so we'll write here div class is going
to be
trip for this particular
previous icon
we'll write img
src is going to be inside the images
folder we have this
icons folder now inside the icons folder
we have this file named
trav.svg and we have the
alternate to this as
previous
we'll close this image tag over here
we'll
define another div tag we'll write a div
class is equals to next
and we'll write here img
src is going to be
inside the images folder we have icons
then we have
next dot
svg
fine we'll write here alternate as
next
and we are almost done with the light
boxes so the light box ends over here
well right here
this is slide box and
and that's it
we are done with the html part now save
the program and you can see here on the
web page we have all the website data
present over here we have all the images
and everything present over here the
next thing we have to do is to style our
website using css
for that we have to move to a css file
now and you guys know the drill so here
you can see we are using some fonts for
our website you guys can use the cdn
link from the web and you can use any
font of your choice
so let's start styling our website now
what we'll do is we'll write here
firstly we'll write the code for body
text so we'll write your body
then inside this what we'll do is we'll
write here
margin
so margin is going to be
0
initially now we'll write you over here
line height so we'll write here line
height
line height is going to be 1.5
now after this we are going to write
here background color so we have some
predefined background colors with us you
guys can use any of your choice for now
we'll write here
f3
f
2 f 1 so this is the code this is some
sort of white color we can see now the
next thing we are going to write here is
we are going to write the code for body
then we have the code for input
and we have the code for text area as
well so we'll write a text area
and then we have the code for
button so we'll write your button now
inside this what we'll do is we'll write
your font
family so font family is going to be
a railway and then we'll write here
sense
self fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to write here font weight so
we will write your font weight and the
font fit is going to be
400 now
moving ahead what we'll do next is we'll
write over here
we are done with these
three different tags so
the next thing we are going to write
here is we are going to write here s
trick and
we'll write here border
okay so we'll write here box
sizing so we're right thing here box
sizing and the box sizing is going to be
border box
then we have the margin again and the
margin is going to be
zero
fine
so we'll write here zero the next thing
we have to write here is the code for
the container class so we'll write here
container
then we'll write here max
width max width is going to be
170 pixels and then we have margin over
here so margin is going to be auto
now we are done with the container class
as well the next thing we have to
mention here is the row class so if we
move back to our html file you can see
we have used the class as row for almost
everywhere you can see we have the class
row over here
we have class as row almost everywhere
in a html file right so we'll write the
code for row now
so the class row is going to be
display as flex and then we have
flex wrap so we'll write your flex wrap
and flex wrap is going to be
wrap again
now after this we'll write here
the code for align items class so we'll
write here dot align item
and the class name is align item center
so we'll write here align items at the
center for this particular class
then we
have justify
content between so we'll write here
justify content between so basically we
have used these classes in html
part so we'll write here
inside the justify content between we'll
write a justify content at
space between not space around we'll
write a space between
then after this justify content between
class we have the animation for our
box so we are talking about this
particular box over here you can see in
the website we are talking about this
particular box which is rotating
so for that we'll write here at the rate
keyframes so we'll write here keyframes
then we'll write your ani
zero one
and we'll write here inside this at
zero percent what will happen is
it will
transform itself and it will rotate so
we'll write here rotate at
0 degree fine
we have to mention here 100 as well so
we'll write here at 100
we want to transform it
and what we want to do is we want to
write a rotate at
360 degrees so we'll write here 360
degree
now the next thing we have to do is to
style the section title so for that we
have the section title class so we'll
write your section
title and inside here what we'll do is
we'll write
flex
so flex is going to be
zero comma
zero space hundred percent
then we have max width so we'll write
your max weight at
as hundred percent
and then we have margin bottom so we'll
write your margin bottom is
60 pixels and we have
padding as
0 and 15 pixels fine
now what we have to do is we have to
mention the section title for h1 so if
we move back here you can see so inside
here what we have to do is we are going
to
style the h1 heading so h1 heading is
present inside the section title so
you can see we have the section title
class over here
in a html file so if we move
down to the about section you can see it
over here we have this
class as section title and we have the
heading as about similarly we have this
thing for categories for top rated
movies and for contactors so we'll style
all of them so
what we are going to do is we are going
to write here dot section title space h1
we are going to style the heading one so
we will write here this
play as inline block
so we'll write a display as inline block
then we have font size as
40 pixels
and
color
so color is going to be
black so we'll write here
this
and then we have font weight so font
weight is going to be
700 for the section title
then we have margin as
0
for the section title and we have
position as
relative fine so we are done with the
section title as well now what we have
to do is we have to write here some more
code so we'll write your dot
section title space h1
then we'll write here
before
now what we are going to do is we are
going to write here content
and we are going to write here nothing
then we have box sizing
so we have box sizing as
border box then we have
position as
absolute so we'll write here absolute
then we have left
so for left we have the value as
0
then we have bottom
then bottom value is going to be minus 5
pixels
we have width as well so we'll mention
the width here which is going to be 80
pixels now
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here height
height is going to be 3 pixels
then we have background color as well so
background color is
hash ff9800
so this is the background color
now the next thing we have to mention is
for the button
so we have the class as button
0 1
now inside this what we are going to do
is we are going to write here background
color as
the same will write here 9 0 0 then we
have color
the font color basically so the font
color is going to be
white
or we can say off white so then we have
border
border is going to be 2 pixels
solid
and
transparent fine
we are done with the border we have to
mention the padding as well padding is
going to be 10 pixel and
35 pixels
then we have border radius as well so
we'll write your border radius and the
border radius is going to be 30 pixels
so next up we have
line height
and line height is going to be 1.5
then we have cursor as
point
so what we are doing here is we are
basically
styling the button so the button with
classes button01 will be styled after
this particular piece of code
save it now
move back to the website and
if you can see here if we move back to
the top section you can see our button
as
orange in color and the text inside it
is white in color so if you can see here
we have this button all over here we
have this contact us button as well so
the buttons are ready to use
now the next thing we have to mention
here is the text decoration so we'll
write here text
decoration is going to be none
then we have font size
font size is
going to be 16 pixels
then we have font weight as well
so font weight is going to be 600 then
we have display
so we'll write here display as inline
block
we'll write inline log then we have
transition
transition is going to be all
zero 0.5 second
fine and then we have eve
so we are done with it the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to write
here button 0 1 hover
but if we hover over this particular
button
now on hovering the
background color is going to be
transparent
so we'll write your background color as
transparent border color
border color is going to be the same so
we'll write here ff9800
then we have the color as well so we'll
write your color as
ff
ff9800
so we are done with this save it now
move back to the website and
look for the button over here you can
see we have this button and on hovering
you can see nothing is happening as of
now so let's
see what's wrong over here so
we have forgot to
put the colon over here and now i think
it will work fine save it
and you can see it's working totally
fine now
on hovering the button is changing and
similar thing will happen with this
particular button as well you can see
it's working totally fine
moving ahead the next thing we have to
mention over here is on focus so we'll
write your button 0 1
then we'll write your focus
and we'll change the outline to
none
fine
so we are done with basic css part you
can see the buttons are working fine now
the next thing we have to do is to write
the code for preloader so we'll write
over here
preloader so that it will be easy for
you guys to understand
now for preloader what we have to do is
we have to access the preloader class
fine so we'll write a pre-loader this is
the class name
now we'll write your position
as
fixed
then we have left
as
0
top is
0 then we have right and bottom as well
so we'll write here right as 0 and
bottom is zero fine
background color so we'll write your
background color we'll write your hash
this is the background color so we have
to mention here this it's sort of black
then we have the z index so we'll write
here z index and this index is going to
be 1 0 9 9
then we have the display as
flex
and we have to align the items at this
center
fine
now we have to justify content so we'll
write a justify content at the center
then we have transition again so we'll
write here transition
and the transition is going to be all at
0.6 seconds and it will be ease
fine
the next thing we have to write here is
dot
preloader
dot
loaded
then we have to write here
visibility as
hidden
and we have the opacity as
0
then we have z index again so we'll
write here z index as minus 99
fine
so then we'll write here treeloader
dot
load so
here what we'll do is we'll mention the
height
height is going to be 30 pixels then we
have
width which is going to be 30 pixels
again then we have border
so we'll write your border
border is going to be 2 pixels
solid in color
and transparent
no it's not going to be transparent we
have to write here ff9800
then we have border right
border right is going to be
2 pixels
solid and
transparent so we'll write a transparent
then we have
border radius
and border radius is going to be 50
percent
then we have
animation animation is going to be a n i
0 1
then we have 2 seconds and it is going
to be linear and
infinite
fine
so we are done with this as well now the
next thing we have to do is
we have
to style the header part now so save it
now we'll move back to the web page and
here you can see
the website is working the loader is
working right now
so let's
start trading code again over here
we'll write here
header again so
header
then we'll write your dot header and
we are going to style the header tag now
we are going to write your position as
absolute
and then we have left left is going to
be 0 then we have right
right is going to be nothing because we
have to write here top
so we'll write it top as 0 then we have
width
width is going to be hundred percent
and
we have
a z index again so we'll write here z
index as
99
fine then we have transition
transition is going to be all
0.5 second and
ease
fine
then we have to write the code for fixed
ad so we'll write here dot
header
dot
fixed
so inside this will write background
color as
white so we'll write here
this then we have position
and position is going to be fixed
fine
then we have the header brand name so we
have to style the brand name as well so
we'll write your dot
header dot
brand name
and we have to write here
padding padding is going to be
0 and 50.
fine
so this thing is working fine now the
next thing we are going to write here is
we are going to write here dot header
dot brand name
dot anchor tag
so we will write it a now what we are
going to do is we are going to write a
text decoration as
none then we have font size font size is
going to be
30 pixels
then we have color so we'll write your
color
then we'll mention this particular color
white color
and we have text transform as well so
we'll write here text transform as upper
case
then we have font width so we'll write
your font weight
font weight is going to be 900 then we
have
letter spacing letter spacing is going
to be 2 pixels and
we'll write here transition as
all
0.5 second and
ease
fine
next thing we have to do is we have to
write here
color so we'll write here dot
header
dot
fixed
dot
brand name and then we have to write
here a and we have to write here
color is
black
fine
now we have to write some more code over
here we'll write a header
dot
nav toggle
and we have to write here inside this as
width width is going to be 40 pixels
when we have height
it is going to be 34 pixels
we have the border as well we'll write a
border
one pixel
solid and
white in color
fine then we have
border radius as
three pixels and
cursor as
pointer
then we have display as well we'll write
your display as flex and
will align items at the center so we'll
write here align items at the center
then we have justify content at the
center
finally we have transition here as well
we'll write your transition
all
0.5 seconds and ease
then we have
display as none
fine so let's finish the header part
first we'll write a dot
header
dot
fixed
dot
nav toggle
and inside this will write
border color
and the border color is going to be
black
then we have to write here
dot
header
dot nav toggle
speed span we are going to write the
code for span tag which we kept empty in
the html part we will write a height
height is going to be one pixel and then
we have display
display is going to be block
then we have width
width is going to be 16 pixels
then we have background color so we'll
write your background color as
white
then we have position as
a relative and
transition as
on
0.5 second and ease
fine lastly we'll write here dot
header space
dot nav toggle space span
and we have to write the code for before
and
after
fine so we'll copy this from here we'll
paste it here and instead of before
we'll write here after
we'll remove this comma and now we'll
write the code now what we have to do is
we have to write here content
content is going to be
this then we have position as
absolute
then we have left
we will write your left as
0 then we have top as 0
we have height so we will write your
height
is 1 pixel and
width is
100
fine it will take 100 of the width then
we have background color as
white again
so we'll write here this and we have
transition again so we'll write here
transition and transition is going to be
all at 0.5 seconds and is over here
then we have dot
header
dot
fixed
dot
nav toggle
and span
fine then we'll write here dot header
dot
fixed
dot
nav toggle
and we have to mention it for before
and the same thing for after so we'll
write here
header
then we have
fixed
then we have
nav toggle then we have
this thing for
after
fine so we have
to remove the space from here and now
inside this what we have to do is we
have to write here
background color as
black
and we have to write here dot
header
dot
nav toggle
space pan
we have to write here before
and after this we have to write here
transform
transform and we'll translate it to
minus six pixels so we'll write your
translate
translate it to minus six pixels fine
the same thing goes for after we have to
copy this from here paste it here again
instead of before we'll mention after
over here we'll write it after
after this we'll write a 6 pixel instead
of -6 fine the next thing we have to
mention over here is
dot header
then we have dot
nav and inside this will mention
adding as
0 speeds 15 pixels
fine
now we have to mention the ul tag as
well
so we'll write your dot header again
then we'll write your dot nav
and we have the ul text so we'll write a
un for the unordered list list style is
going to be none
and we have the margin as
0 and we have
padding as 0
and after this we will write here dot
header space dot
nap
inside the ul tag we have to access the
list as well so we'll write the code for
that now we'll write here display as
inline block
so we'll write inline block and we have
the margin left
as 30 pixels
for the list now the next thing we have
to mention over here is
for the anchor tag present inside the
list stack so we'll write your dot
nav
space ul space li
space a now after this we have to write
here
text decoration text decoration is going
to be none
then we have font size so we'll write
your font size as
16 pixels and we have this
font weight is 600
we have color
as
white so we'll write here this then we
have padding
and padding is going to be 25 pixels and
zeal
fine
then we have display as
block and we have transition as
all
0.5 second
and ease value
find will write here
dot header
space dot fixed
space dot
net
uli
e
then we have color is
black and after this what we have to do
is
we have to write a dot
header
dot
fixed
and then we have dot
nav
we have ul we have li
a and then we have to write here hover
after this we have to write here dot
header
nav
ulli a on hover
so we'll write here hover
we have to remove the space from here as
well so we are done
with this now after this what we have to
do is we have
to write here inside this color is going
to be
this one
so we are done with this part as well
save the program and let's check back at
the web
browser if it's working or not you can
see it over here we are not able to find
all these elements for now
so what we are going to do is we are
going to reduce the size over here and
you can see we have all the icons
present we have home about categories
top rated and contact so it's working
totally fine as of now let's move ahead
and now we'll do
the styling part for
header section or we can say for the
home section sorry so we'll write here
home section
and we'll comment this out fine now
let's write the code over here we'll
write your home section first so we'll
write your dollar
dot
home
section and we have inside this
min height min height is going to be
100 viewport height so we'll write your
100 vh then we have background image so
we'll write your background image as
url and
will
mention the url here will write here
dot slash img
inside this we have this
movie bg.png and we have the background
image now so we'll write your background
size and we'll write here cover then we
have background position so we'll write
your background
position so we'll write your background
position as send fine
the next thing we have to do is we have
to write a position as relative then we
have
the z index so we'll write here z index
as one then we have padding so we'll
write a padding as
0 and 15 pixels
and then we have
section
we'll write your home section before
then we'll write your content so we'll
write your content
and content is going to be this again
then we have position
position is going to be absolute then we
have box sizing so we'll write a box
sizing
we'll write in our border box
then we have left
as
0
so we have to write is 0 and here we
have left as 0 then we have top right
and bottom as well so we'll write your
top as 0
write as 0
and
bottom is a 0. fine
then we have background color and
background color is going to be black
then we have opacity opacity is going to
be 0.7
and then we have z index again so we'll
write here z index as -1
and that's it the next thing we are
going to do is we are going to write
here dot home section space dot shape
0 1
so we have that shape present which is
rotating so we'll write your position as
absolute
then we have height so we'll write a
height as 30 pixels
we have width again as 30 pixels so
we'll write your width as 30 pixels
then we have
border so we'll write a border as
2 pixels
solid and
of
this particular color fine now we'll
write here right right is going to be
five percent
and then we have top as well so we'll
write your top top is going to be 20
percent
so we'll write your top as 20 percent
and we have the
animation so the animation name is ani01
we have five seconds we have linear
and we have infinite
fine
so the next thing we have to style is
going to be the home section and then we
have the
row class so we'll write a dot row we'll
write your min height and main height is
going to be 100 view port height so
we'll write here 100 vh
then we have
dot
home section
dot
home content so we'll write your home
section home content
and we have this thing over here and
we'll write your flex
flex is going to be zeros to zero speeds
hundred percent
so we'll write your hundred percent then
we have max width
max width is going to be hundred percent
and then we have text align at the
center fine
the next thing we have is the
heading so we'll write your home
section so we'll write your home
sections space
home content so we'll write your home
content
then we'll write here the heading so hq
is the heading
we'll write your h4 will write your font
size and font size is going to be
60 pixels then we have
the font size is going to be 20 pixels
not 60
then we have the color so color is going
to be
white so we'll
write here this then we have
margin so we'll write your margin is
zero
then we have
to style the h2 tag as well so we'll
write here dot home section space dot
home content
space h2
then we have the font size so we'll
write your font
size and font size is going to be 60
pixels for this then we have
margin so margin we have to write here
as 0 and
color we also have to mention over here
color is going to be white again
then we have text transform
text transform is going to be upper case
and then we have font weight so font
weight is going to be 900
then we have letter spacing
and letter spacing is going to be 10
pixels fine
then we have
to write the code for scroll down if you
guys remember those two arrows so we'll
write the code for
that as well so we'll write your home
section dot
scroll down
then we have inside this we have
position
as absolute fine
we have left
as
50
now we have bottom as well so we have
bottom as
30 pixels then we have height
and width as well so we'll write your
height as 30 pixels and width is
30 pixels fine
then we have margin left as well so
we'll write your margin left as
minus 15 pixels and
we have animation again so we'll write
animation
scroll down
okay we have to write this
crawl down
then we have two seconds and we have is
we have infinite
fine so we'll write here infinite again
now we have to define the keyframes as
well so we'll write a keyframe
then we have scroll down
so we'll write this scroll down we have
to write here zero percent then we have
20 50 80 and 100. so we'll write here 20
50
80 percent
and
hundred percent fine we have to separate
them with commas we'll write here
comma after every
number so we'll write here inside this
translate
translate it
okay we have to write here transform
transform and translate it
to y-axis
and we have to write here 0 fine
then we have to write this same thing
for
40 percent and 60
so we'll write here forty percent
for forty percent we have to write here
transform
translate
y
and then we have to write a minus 30
pixels and
we have to write here 60 percent and
inside this we have to write
transform
translate
y and we have to write here
minus 15 pixels fine the next thing we
have to do is we have to write here
dot
home section
dot scroll down
space img
then we have to write your width inside
this so the width is going to be 25
pixels
then we have display display is going to
be block
then we have margin so we'll write your
margin
margin is going to be 2 pixels auto
then we have this for the home section
only so we are done with the home
section save the program move back to
the website and you can see it looks
more like the original website now so
you can see we have home about
we have categories
and we have
top rated and contact too you can see
this animation for this particular block
is also working fine we have this as
well over here and it's working totally
fine
right
so
you can see over here that this
animation is working
on hovering the mouse over it so
we have to write some code for that as
well but
it's not working as of now in the
original website of us
so you can see nothing is happening on
hovering the mouse over it
now what we have to do is
we'll see it later on
we'll see why this part is not working
the next thing we have to mention here
is the about section so we'll write here
about
section
and we have to write here this
now we'll
access this about section so we'll write
here about section
then we have inside this is padding
padding is going to be 80 pixels
and
0 space 0 so
the next thing we have to do is to write
here about section
about
image so we have to add the image over
here
so we are basically
trying to edit that particular image
that particular image inside the about
section right so we'll write your dot
img
or we can say dot about img so inside
this will write
flex
flex is going to be 0 space zero space
thirty three point three three
percent
and then we have max width so we'll
write here max width as
thirty three point three three percent
and then we have
padding so we'll write your padding as
0 and 15 pixels
and we are done with the image now the
next thing we have to do is to style the
image box so we'll write here dot
about section
dot about image
then we'll write it dot
img box fine so we'll write your dot img
box
inside this will mention the position as
a relative fine
now after this what we have to do is we
have to copy this piece of code from
here
we have to paste it here then we have to
write here dot
shape
0
so basically what we are doing is we are
trying to style the second shape so
we'll write your position as absolute
then we have height
so we'll write height as 30 pixels we
will write your width as
30 pixels then we have border so we'll
write your border as
2 pixels
solid and we'll write here
ff9800 then we'll write your left left
is going to be 30 pixel then we have
top which is again going to be 30 pixels
and then we have animation
animation is going to be ani01
5 seconds
and then we have linear
and
infinite
fine
so we are done with this as well next
thing up we have to write here dot about
section
dot about img
and then we'll write your dot img box
then we'll write your dot img
so we'll write your width
width is going to be 100 percent
then we have display display is going to
be block
and then we have to write your dot about
section
dot
about
content
fine we have to write your flex flex is
going to be
0 0
66.66 percent
then we have
max width max width is going to be 66.66
percent again
then we have padding padding is going to
be 0 and 15 pixels
next thing up we have to write here dot
about section
dot
section title so
we'll write here margin as
margin bottom as 30 pixels then we have
padding as
0
and then we'll write here dot
about section and we'll write here dot
about content so we'll write a dot about
content
then we have to write a piece for the
paragraph tag we'll write your font size
is
16 pixels and we have color so we'll
write a color as
it's sort of gray then we'll write a
line height as
26 pixels and we have margin
margin is going to be zero again
then we'll write your dot about section
not about content
dot stats
dot
stat box fine
now inside this we'll write flex flex is
going to be zero space zero space 25
percent
then we have max width max width is
going to be 25 percent again
then we have padding padding is going to
be
0 and 15 pixels again
then we have to
align the text at the center
and we have margin top so we'll write
your margin top as 30 pixels
fine the next thing we have to do is we
have to write a dot about
section about content then we have
pets
then we have stat box
and we have to mention the heading as
well we'll write your font size as
40 pixels then we have
color as
black
then we have margin
margin is going to be 0 0
and
5 pixels
so we have to copy this from here now
we have to do the same thing for h5
adding text so we'll write here
h5 instead of h2
so we'll write your font
size so font size is going to be 16
pixels then we have color
color is going to be grayed and we have
font weight
font weight is going to be 600 then we
have
text transform
so we'll write your text transform and
text transform is going to be uppercase
for this particular heading
then we have to style the button as well
so we'll write your dot about section
about content
then we have dot btn
so now inside this we have to write here
margin top margin top is going to be 30
pixels for this particular button
save the program because we are done
with the about section save the program
now move back to the browser
and you can see the about a section over
here
so there's something wrong with this
particular section we'll move back to
the css file and we'll see what's wrong
over here
so nothing seems to be wrong over here
inside the css file let's check back at
the index file and here you can see
we have to write about img
save this html file save the css file as
well move back to the browser and
you can see it looks fine now the about
section looks exactly like this
particular section so
we are done with about a section as well
now moving further we have to style the
service section now the service section
means this particular section in the
html file is related to the categories
section so we have to
style this particular section now so for
that what we'll do is we'll write here
categories
comment this out and now we'll write the
code for categories
we have used the class for categories as
service section
so first of all we'll write here
dot
service
section
and now we'll write code inside this so
we'll write here padding
padding is going to be 80 pixels
and
0. fine
we are done with this now the next thing
we have to write here is for the service
item or we can say for the category item
so we'll write a service
section
then we'll put a space and we'll write a
dot
service
item
so inside this we'll write flex flex is
going to be
0 space 0 space 33.33
percent
then we have after flex we have max
width so we'll write your max width as
33.33 percent again
and then we have padding as well so
we'll write here padding
padding is going to be 15 pixels
and after this we have to mention the
inner class as well so we'll write your
service section space
service item dash
you know fine this is another class so
we'll write here
position position is going to be
relative and then we have overflow as
well so we'll write here overflow
overflow is going to be hidden
and that's it the next thing we have to
write here is service
section
so we'll write your service section
space service item in a
space img we are going to style the
image as well so we will write a img
width is going to be
100
and then we have
display as well so we'll write here
display as block
then we have filter
so we'll write your filter as grayscale
then we have passed the value for
grayscale as hundred percent
and we have transition so we'll write
here transition transition is going to
be all at 0.5 second
and it's going to be ease fine
then we have
service section
so we have to mention
that we are
so what we are doing is we are going to
mention the whole thing over here so if
we have a mouse scale over any
category or over any image so what we
want is we want to change that image to
gray so we'll write the code for that
we'll write your service section
dot
service item inner
and then we'll write here
hover
and we'll hover over image
so we'll write a img we'll write your
filter as grayscale
we have to pass the value as 0 over here
then we have transform
so we'll write your transform we'll
write your scale
and we are going to pass the value as
1.1
fine then we have
service section
service item inner
and we have overlay as well so we'll
write here overlay
for the overlay class we have used in
the html part
so inside here we'll write
position as absolute
and we have to mention left over here so
we'll write your left as 0
and then we have top as well we'll write
top as 0
then we have height so height is going
to be 100 percent so we'll write a 100
percent then we have width which is
again going to be 100 percent
now we are done with height and width we
have to mention the background color as
well so we'll write your background
color as
rgb so we are going to pass the rgba
value rgba value is 0 comma 0 comma 0
comma 6
so it's 0.6 over here it's sort of black
in color then we have display as flex
and we have to align these items at the
center
after this we have to justify content so
we'll write your justify content at the
center
then we have transition
transition is going to be all at 0.5
seconds and
ease fine
now inside here what we'll do is we'll
write service section is service item
inner
then we'll write here
hover
and we are going to write here
dot overlay
fine now we'll write the code inside
curly braces we'll write your background
color as
transparent
so we'll write your background color as
transparent we are done with this part
next up we'll write here dot service
section
space service item inner
then we have to write a dot overlay we
are going to use the overlay class
present inside service item in a and
that service item in a class is present
inside service section so we'll write h3
for heading 3
then we have to write here color color
is going to be white and then we have
font size so we'll write your font size
as 30 pixels
and then we have margin margin is going
to be zero then we have text align so
we'll align this text at the center
and then we have transition so we'll
write your transition
transition is going to be all at 0.5
seconds and ease
fine then we have to transform the text
we'll write your text transform and
we'll write here capitalize
next up we'll write your service section
space
service item in a and then we have
overlay so we'll write here overlay and
this time we are going to write it for
h4 heading so we'll write here h4
and we have to write a translate
so we'll write here translate
okay we have to write a transform
actually so we'll write your transform
and inside this we have to translate it
to x axis and we'll write here
30 pixels fine
next up what we have to do is we have to
mention the opacity as well so we'll
write the opacity as zero fine so we are
done with this categories as well save
the program move back to the browser and
here you can see our categories so
the hovering effect is still not working
over here we'll see why this is not
working so let's do one thing what we'll
do is we'll remove the space before
over here
we'll do the same for this over as well
and if we have any
effect again
we'll do it for that
so save it now move back to the website
and you can see it's working now
so it's working totally fine
if we move back to our original website
you can see we have all these images
over here inside the categories section
so it's working totally fine in our
website now
now the next section we have to style is
the top rated movie section so here are
our top rated movies so we have to style
this section now
what we'll do is we'll write here
after this
we'll write here
in comments we'll write here
operated
i will write the code for top rated
section so the class is work section so
we'll write here dot work
section and now we have to write the
code for this we'll write your padding
padding is going to be 80 pixels and
0 and 0. fine
now we have to write here dot
work section
space dot work item
so we'll write here dot work item as
well and then we'll write the code
inside curly braces we'll write your
flex
flex is going to be 0 0 and 33.33
then we have max width so we'll write
here max width as
33.33 percent again
and now we have padding as well so we'll
write your padding as 15 pixels
fine
the next thing we have to mention over
here is we'll write your work section
space walk item
so we'll write here
work item inner now so we'll write your
work item inner then we have to style
the images so we'll write here img we'll
write your width width is going to be
100 percent
then we have display display is going to
be block
so we'll write a display as block then
we have transform transform is going to
be scale
and the value is going to be 1.1
then we have transition transition is
going to be all at 0.5 second and
is fine
and then we have dot
work section
we'll add here dot
work item inner
so after this we'll write here hover
and on holding over the image we have to
style it so we'll write your filter
filter is going to be grayscale again so
we'll write a grayscale the value is
going to be hundred
we'll write here transform and transform
what we are going to write here is scale
as one
fine now after this what we have to do
is we have to write here dot work
section space
work item inner
and
now what we have to do is we have to
write inside it position position is
going to be relative then we have cursor
cursor is going to be
okay
then we have cursor cursor is going to
be pointer and
overflow as well so we are going to
write your overflow as hidden
fine the next thing we have to write
here is dot work section inside the work
section class we have this
work set work item inner class and we
have to write the code for overlay
classes
so we'll write your overlay then we'll
write your position as absolute
and left is going to be 0 so we'll write
your left as 0
then we have top as 0 so we'll write it
top as zero height
height is going to be hundred percent
then we have
width as well so we'll write your width
as hundred percent
and then we have padding so padding is
going to be
15 pixels again so we'll write here 15
pixels display is going to be flex and
then we have a line item so we'll write
a align items at the flex end
then we have transition so we'll write a
transition as
all
0.5 second and
ease fine then after transition we have
the background color so we'll write your
background color and the background
color is going to be
zero comma zero comma zero comma zero
point
six fine
then we have the opacity so we'll write
here opacity and opacity is going to be
zero okay
we are done with this section as well
and we'll write here dot
work section then we have
dot
work item inner then we have
hover so we'll write your hover
and what we are going to do is we are
going to write here overlay so on
holding the overlay section what we want
is we want the opacity to change to one
so we'll write the opacity as one
and then we'll write your dot work
section again then we have
dot
work item in a
and we'll write here dot overlay now we
are writing the code for headings so
we'll write here h4 now
inside this we are going to define the
color as white
then we have font size so font size is
going to be 20 pixels for this and then
we have margin so margin is going to be
zero again
then we have transform
so we'll write your transform and we'll
write here translate x so inside
translate x we have to write it 30
pixels
then we have to mention the
transition again so we'll write a
transition all
at
0.5 seconds and
ease fine
now we are good to go the next thing we
have to write here is the work section
so the work section is
here then we have to write your work
item inner then we have to write here
hover and after hover we have to write
the code for overlay inside overlay we
have to write the code for h4reading
fine so we have to write here transform
translate x to 0
and we are done with the work section as
well save the program move back to the
browser and here you can see we have all
the top rated movies working totally
fine we have
all these movies over here the whole
effect is working fine click on any and
it's not responsive as of now because we
need to go to the jquery part for that
so we'll do it later on now let's style
the light box first now so we'll write
here light box
and
we'll write here
dot
light box
so we'll write your dot light box then
we have to write your position position
is going to be fixed
and after position we have to mention
the z index z index is going to be
1 0 9 9 and then we have left left is
going to be
left is going to be zero again then we
have top as well top is going to be zero
then we have
right as well right is going to be 0
again and we have
bottom is 0. fine
we have to mention the background color
background color is going to be
a little bit darker so we'll write here
rgb a instead of 0.6 we'll write here
0.7
fine then we have to mention the display
as flex over here
and we have to align the items at the
center so we'll write here align items
at the center justify content at the
center then we have
cursor so we'll write here cursor
we have to write here zoom out
and then we have display display is
going to be none
then we have dot light box
dot open so we'll write here the code
when the light box will open we'll write
here display as
flex
and after this we have to write the
image write the code for images present
inside the light box so we'll write here
light box and then we have to write here
light box
img so we'll write here light box dot
img
and then we have
okay so we have to put a
dash over here now inside this we'll
write display as flex
and then we have width
which is going to be auto
then we have height height again is
going to be auto according to the height
of the image we have so we'll write your
height as auto
then we have max width max width is
going to be 100 percent
and we have padding as well we'll write
your padding as 40 pixels and zero
now what we have to do next is we have
to write here dot
light box
dot
image box so we'll write here dot image
box then we have to write here position
as relative
and cursor as
auto
fine so we'll write here auto
now we are moving ahead and we'll write
here light box
so we'll write here light box
dot
light box close we have to write here so
we'll write here light box close
okay so let's check it once if we have
to write here light box
open now we have to write here
light box close so
inside this what we are going to do is
we are going to write here height height
is going to be 30 pixels then we have
width width is going to be 30 pixels
again
and after this we have the display as
block
now the next thing we have is the
position as absolute
so we'll write your position as absolute
right is going to be 0 again then we
have
top as 10 pixels
after top we have the font size so we'll
write your font size as
30 pixels and we have the color as white
so we'll write here
hash ff six times so we'll write a text
align at the
center and we have
line height so we'll write here line
height as 26 pixels
and after this we have to write here
cursor
as
zoom out fine
now the next thing we have to mention
here is
light box caption so we'll use the light
box caption class
so we'll write your light box
caption
now we'll write inside here color is
going to be white again then we have the
font size
so we'll write here font size font size
is going to be 16 pixels
and we have font weight as 600 so we'll
write your font weight as 600
then we have position as absolute
and after this we have left as 0 so
we'll write here left as 0 then we have
bottom as
10 pixels
so we have the bottom as 10 pixels and
we have the display as flex
then we have justify content will
justify content as space between
fine so we'll write a space between then
we have the width
as hundred percent
fine
now we'll write a dot
lightbox
dot light box caption
and we'll write your dot light box
category so we'll write here category
and now inside this will write
padding right padding right is going to
be 50 pixels
so after this what we have to do is we
have to write the code for previous and
next so we'll write here dot light box
then we'll write here dot
lightbox controls so we'll write here
lightbox controls
then we'll write here dot
trip
so this is another class
we'll copy it we'll paste it again
instead of trip we'll write here after
and we'll remove this comma
so not after we have the class name is
next over here we'll write here next
position is going to be absolute
then we have height
height is going to be
calc so we are calling a function over
here 100 percent
minus
80 pixels fine so we'll write a 100
minus 80 pixels then we have
top as 40 pixels and we have cursor as
pointer
then we have display as flex
and after display we have to align items
at the center
we are good with it we'll write here
light box
dot light box controls so we'll write
your controls then we'll use the priv
class again
now we'll write here left
left is going to be zero then we have
width
width is going to be 50 percent then we
have to justify
content as flex start
now after this we have to write the code
for next as well so we'll write here dot
light box space dot light box controls
then we have to write here next
dot next we have to write actually
then we'll write the code inside curly
braces for next we'll write here right
right is going to be 0 then we have
width which is going to be 50 percent
again
and after which we have to justify the
content as
flex end
we have the padding over here padding is
going to be
for padding right so we'll write your
padding right as
5 pixels
fine
next up
we have to set the controls again for
previous image and for next image so
we'll write here dot
light box dot light box controls
then we have dot trif
so we'll write here hover on
prevail right here img
comma we'll write the same piece of code
for
next as well now instead of prev we'll
write here next
and we'll remove this comma from here
we'll put curly braces will write your
background color background color is
rgba and instead of 0.6 we have 0.5 over
here
and i think we are good to go but we
forgot to mention over here some more
controls so we'll write here dot
light box space dot light box controls
then we'll write here dot ref and we'll
write here img fine we'll put a comma
we'll copy this from here
we'll paste it here
and
now what we'll do is instead of dot trip
we'll write your dot next again and
we'll remove this comma off from here
and we'll put curly braces over here
we'll write your width width is going to
be 30 pixels
and then we have height
height is going to be 30 pixels again
then we have padding so we'll write your
padding padding is going to be 5 pixel
and we have to mention the border radius
as well so we'll write your border
radius is 2 pixels
and we have to write here
transition so transition is going to be
all
0.5 seconds
fine
so we are done with
the light box as well save the program
move back to the browser and
you can see the light box is
isn't available at the moment because we
have to write the jquery part for that
so for now it looks fine now the next
section we have to work on is the
contact section
so we'll write here
contact
and
now we'll write the code for contact
section
now for contact section we'll first
access the contact section class so
we'll write your contact
section
and what we'll do is we'll write here
padding so padding is going to be 80
pixels
and we'll write here 80 00 and 80 pixels
again
fine
then after this what we'll do is we'll
write here
the code for contact section image so
we'll write here dot contact section dot
contact img
now we'll write your flex
so flux is going to be 0 comma 0 space
100 percent then after flex we have the
max width so max width is going to be
hundred percent again
then we have padding so we'll write your
padding padding is going to be zero and
15 pixels
we are done with the image part as well
next thing up we'll write here dot
contact
section
dot contact image then we'll write your
dot img box so
we are writing the code for image box
now we'll add the image for contact us
page inside this particular
box so what we'll do is we'll write here
padding as 200 pixels and
0. fine next up we'll write your
background image background image we
have to provide the url url is
we have to write here dot dot then we
have to access the images folder so
we'll write images
then after images we have this contact
dot png over here so we'll
click on it and here we have the contact
image
now we'll write over here
background size background size is going
to be cover so we'll write here
background size is cover then we have
the background position background
position is at the
center so we are done with adding the
image now we'll write here dot contact
section then we have to write here dot
section title
now we have to write here
text align so we'll write a text align
at the center
so we have to write here center
now after this we have
to style h1 tag so we'll write your dot
contact section space
section title space h1
so we'll write inside here color as
white so we'll write here this
then we have to write here contact
section so we have to write your contact
section space
dot section title
then we have to write here h1
before
now after this
we have to write here inside background
color is going to be white
and then we have left as 50
so we'll write here left as 50
and after left we have the margin left
as minus 40 so we'll write your margin
left
as minus 40
pixels
and
now we'll write the code for contact
form so we'll write your contact section
space dot contact form
so we'll write your contact form
now we'll write inside it flex as
zero space zero space hundred percent
then we have max width so we'll write
your max width as 100
and we have padding as well so we'll
write your padding as 0 pixel and
65 pixels
now we'll write the code for form tag so
we'll write your dot
contact section space dot contact form
space dot form
fine so we'll write here background
color is going to be hash f3 f2 and f1
then we have the padding over here we'll
write your padding as 55 pixels and
40 pixels fine
now we'll write here margin top so we'll
write your margin top as
minus 150 pixels
and we are done with this part
so next up we'll write the code for
labels so we'll write here dot contact
section
then we have dot contact form then we
have dot
form now we have to style the label text
so we'll write here label
and inside this will write color color
is going to be black
then we have font weight so we'll write
your font weight as 500
now
the display is going to be block
and the margin is going to be
zero zero and
five pixels fine
next up we'll write here dot contact
section
then we'll write here dot contact form
and then we'll write your dot
form
and after this we'll write it dot input
group
so we'll write a input
group
and inside this we have to write
flex flex is going to be
0 space 0 space 100 percent then we have
max width so max width is going to be
100 percent
and we have padding as well so we'll
write your padding as 0 and 15 pixels
and then we have to mention the margin
bottom margin bottom is going to be 30
pixels
and then we have
dot contact section dot
contact form
space dot form
dot input group
then we have to write here left fine
we'll put a comma over here we'll do the
same thing for right group as well so
we'll paste it over here now we'll write
here right
instead of left now we'll put curly
braces and inside here we'll write
flex flex is going to be 0 0 space 50
and then we have max width max width is
going to be 50
now we'll write here
dot contact section
dot contact form
and then we have dot form
then we have input control so we'll
write here input
control
we'll write here width
width is going to be 100 percent
and after which we have the height over
here so we'll write your height as 45
pixels
we have padding over here we'll write
your padding as
6 pixels is
0 pixels
then we have color is going to be
black
then we have the font size so font size
is going to be 16 pixels
and we have background color as
transparent so we'll write your
background color as transparent then we
have border as none
and we have border bottom as well so
we'll write your border bottom as one
pixels
solid and the color is going to be
hash
off white kind of
then we'll write here dot
contact section
dot
contact form
dot
form dot
input control then we have
to write your focus
we have to write here outline outline is
going to be none then we have
to write here
again so we'll write a dot contact
section
contact form
then we have to write your form space
form button so we are writing the code
from
font
so we are writing the code for form
button now so we'll write your form
button
and we have to align the text at the
center for this fine
next up we have to write the code for
contact info so we'll write your contact
section dot
contact info now we have to write the
code for this we'll write your flex as
0 0 and 100 percent
fine
we'll write max width over here so max
width is going to be 100 percent
then we have dot
contact section and we have contact info
so we'll write your contact info
then we have info item
fine so we'll write it info item
and now inside curly braces we have to
write here flex
flex is going to be zero space zero
space thirty three point three three
percent
and then we have max width max width is
going to be
33.33 percent again
then we have to write here text align
text align at the center
and then we have to write here padding
padding is going to be 0 and 15 pixels
then we have margin bottom
margin bottom is going to be 40 pixels
and then we'll write here dot
contact section
dot contact info
then we'll write here
dot info item
and we have to write here h5 fine
we'll write your font size
is 16 pixels
we have to write your font weight
font weight is going to be 600
and then we have to write here margin
margin is going to be zero again
now what we'll do is we'll write here
dot
contact section
we have to write your dot social links
so we'll write your dot social links we
have to mention flex over here as well
we'll write your flex is zero zero and
hundred percent
then we have max width max width is
going to be hundred percent
then we have
padding so we'll write here
padding padding is going to be
0 and 15 pixels then we have text align
text align at the center
now we'll write here
dot
contact section then we have to write
here dot social links
then we have to write here a and img
fine
so we are basically accessing
the anchor tag first so we will access
the anchor tag first then we'll access
the img tag so we'll write it a for now
we'll write here text decoration
so we'll write your text decoration text
decoration is going to be none
display is going to be inline block
so we'll write a inline block then we
have margin margin is going to be
0 pixel and 5 pixels fine
then we have to write here dot
contact section
dot
social links space a space img now we
are accessing the image present inside
the anchor tag we will write your width
as 28 pixels
reducing the size of our images we'll
write a display as
block
so we'll write a display as block we'll
write here transition transition is
going to be all at 0.5
seconds and ease fine
now we have to write here dot
contact section then we have to write
here dot social links then we have to
write here a
on hovering over the image basically so
we'll write here hover img
and we'll change the opacity now we'll
write your opacity as 0.5
and we are done with this contact
section as well
now we are left with the copyright
section and the responsiveness of a
website so let's check it once save the
program move back to the browser and
here you can see
it looks fine now right
so the contact us
thing is working fine
now if we move back to the actual
website
you can see the image is not present
over here properly
so the image is not over here what we
have to do is we have to move back and
we have to check
what mistake we did over here so nothing
seems to be wrong here but
there's a mistake in our program let's
move back to the html part and we'll see
[Music]
okay we have mentioned the class name
wrong here so we have to write a contact
img save the program now save the css
file as well once again
move back here and you can see it's
working fine now
so this is our website the contact us is
working totally fine we have three
placeholders over here we have a text
area basically for message we have a
name
email and phone number so these icons
are also working fine on hovering over
them you can see them working
the address phone and email is also fine
now we have to work on this footer part
we have to work on this 2022 movie menu
copyright part
so we'll move back to the css file and
we'll write here dot
copyright
and we'll write the code for copyright
as well we'll write your border
top so what the top is going to be 1
pixel
solid
end of
this color will write here c5 c5 c5
fine gray color sort of then we'll write
your padding padding is going to be
25 pixels and
15 pixels
then we have text align at the center
we'll write a text align at the center
and we have color as well color is going
to be black
or gray right great is
so we'll write your font size font size
is going to be 16 pixels again
save the program move back to the
browser and you can see it's working
fine now
you can see it over here the copyright
area is working fine now
so we are done with the website
basically now the only thing left here
is for the responsiveness repeat
now the only thing left here is the
responsiveness of our website so we have
to write the code for that as well so
we'll mention it over here first we'll
write here
responsiveness
and we'll comment it out
now we'll start with at the rate media
and then we'll define the width so we'll
write here min width
min width is
768 pixels so we'll write is 768 pixels
and now we have to write here dot
header
dot
nav
and we have to write here inside this
display
display is going to be block
important we have to mention it over
here
now the next thing we have to do is
we have to write after this at the rate
media
and the min width is going to be
and width is going to be
767 pixels
we have to write here
dot
header
then we'll write here
padding padding is going to be 7 pixels
and 0 then we'll write your position
position is going to be fixed
then we'll write here dot
header
dot
nav toggle
and we'll write here display
display is going to be flex
we'll write here margin right margin
right is going to be 15 pixels
now we have to write here after this dot
header
dot nav
now inside this we have to write
flex flex is going to be
zero zero and hundred percent
we are done with flex we have to write a
max width max width is going to be
hundred percent
then we have background color background
color is going to be white so we'll
write here this
then we have padding so we'll write your
padding as 0
and then we have display as none
and then we'll write here dot
header again then we'll write your dot
fixed
then we'll write your dot nav
fine now we'll define the border top so
we'll write your border top
as one pixel
solid in nature and off
this color grey color basically right
and then we have dot
header we have to write the code for ul
and li now so we'll write here dot
header dot nav then we'll write a ul li
and now we'll style them so we'll write
a display
display is going to be
block
and then we'll write here margin right
so we'll write your margin right margin
white is going to be 25 pixels
and we have to mention here dot header
space dot fixed
space
dot
nav
then we have ul li a
then we'll put a comma and we'll write
here dot
header
then we'll write here dot nev
ul l i
and a
now inside here we'll write
color so we'll write your color and
color is going to be black
then we'll write your padding padding is
going to be 15 pixels and zero
so we are done with this as well now we
have to style the home section for this
particular screen size so we'll write
here dot
home section
and we'll write here dot home content
then we have to write here h1
heading is going to change the font size
is going to change to 40 pixels now
then we have to do the same thing for
about section so we'll write about
section then we'll write here about
image image is also going to change
we'll write here margin bottom margin
bottom is going to be 30 pixels
then we have to write here
about
section
dot
about content then we'll put a comma
we'll write a dot about section again
then we'll write your dot about img so
we'll write you about img
we have to mention flex over here
flex is going to be 0 0 and 100 percent
then we have the max width max width is
going to be 100 percent
and after this we have to write here
dot
work section so we'll write your work
section
then we'll write your dot work item
we'll do the same for service section
and service item as well we'll write
your service section dot
service item and we'll change the flex
over here we'll write your flex and
we'll write here 0 0 and
50
fine
we'll change the width as well we'll
write your max width and the max width
is going to be 50 now
and we are good to go with that now we
have to do the same thing for 575 pixels
as well
so we'll do it for 575 we'll write here
at the rate media and we'll write here
inside this
max width max width is going to be
575 pixels
and we'll put curly braces over here
we'll write here dot home section
then we have dot home content so we'll
write your home content then we have the
h1 tag so we'll write your h1 will write
your font
size font size is going to be 25 pixels
and then we have letter spacing so we'll
write a letter spacing as five pixels
then we have the about section so we'll
write here about section space
about contents
paste that
then we have ted box as well so we'll
write your stats and stat box both
we'll write here flex flex is going to
be 0 0 and 50 percent
then we have to write here max width max
width is going to be 50 percent
and after this we have to do the same
thing for contact section work section
and service section so basically for
contact section categories and top rated
moves
so we'll write your contact section
then we'll write here contact info
then we'll write here
info item
now after a comma we'll write here
dot contact section again then we'll
access
dot contact form
then we'll access dot form
then we'll access input group
left fine we'll write it input group
left
and we'll do the same thing for right
input group as well so we'll write here
input group
right
then we'll write here dot
work section and we'll write here dot
walk item
then we have to do the same thing for
service section as well we'll write your
dot service section dot service item
now we'll write inside
curly braces we'll define the flex over
here flex is going to be 0 0 and 100
percent
and max width as well max width is going
to be 100 percent again
then we have
contact section again we'll
use contact form from here
and we'll define the padding for this
part we'll write your padding as
0 pixels and 35 pixels
fine
then we'll write here dot contact
section
dot contact form
and then we'll write your dot form
and we'll define the padding for
this one as well padding is going to be
55 pixels and five pixels for this one
now we are done with this
styling of the website is done now
save the program move back to the
browser
and you can see
the styling is almost done there's
something which is not correct over here
so it's not working correctly as of now
we'll see what wrong we did over here
there's nothing wrong over here so let's
save it once again and we'll see if this
thing works again or not move back to
the website so the website is doing good
over here
and reduce the size and it's working
fine now you can see we have this
website and it's working totally fine as
of now
so we are done with styling a website
that's all what we need to do with
styling
now the last remaining thing here is to
add responsiveness to this website that
will do with the help of jquery and
jquery ui
you can see the website seems beautiful
as of now and let's do the remaining
part quickly as well
let's move on to the javascript file so
this is a javascript file
and we'll write the remaining code here
only
so here we are in the javascript file
before we move on further let's discuss
all things we need to do on our website
to make it look more interactive to the
user the first thing we need to do is to
add the preloader to our website a small
animation will take place before the
website opens
the next thing we have to do is to make
the web page workable for smaller
windows here if i show you this thing in
the website itself if we move back to
the original website you can see on
zooming out the chrome browser you can
see the website adjusts itself according
to the size of the browser the
navigation menu is changed to burger
menu and the layout of the whole website
is changed accordingly
some more changes we need to make are
related to fixed header smooth scrolling
to all the links slide box and the
dialog box on button click that's all
we'll do for this particular website
let's start the code for the preloader
so what we'll do is we'll
write here
let
index is equals to zero
and
we'll write here
const
total
work items
fine so we'll write your total work
items
and we'll access them so we'll write a
dollar
we'll write here the class name so the
class name is work item so we'll write
your work item
dot
length fine
we'll need this part of code later on so
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to write here dollar
then we'll write your window
dot
on
we are going to use the load event so
we'll write a load
comma
function so we'll create a function now
inside this function what we'll do is
inside the body of this function will
write
dollar will access the preloader class
so we'll write here dot
preloader
then we'll write here add class so we'll
add a class over here
we'll add classes loaded
we have already written the css part for
this loaded class
now
we are done with this part save the
program and
we'll open this website with live server
again and you can see
the preloader is not here as of now we
will move back to the css part we have
commented it out so that it will be easy
for us to work on
the
other css parts so we'll remove this
comment from here
we'll paste it here fine save the
program now
save the js file as well so here you can
see we have the preloader over here
now the next thing we need to do is we
need to write the code for
nav toggle so we'll write here dollar
again we'll write here document
then we'll use the ready function so
we'll write here ready then we'll write
your function
so what we'll do is
we'll keep all this code inside
document.ready function
so we'll paste it over here first save
it now
let's see if
this thing works or not
so here you can see the preloader is we
are getting it again and again so it's
not stopping as of now what we'll do
next is we'll
move back to the javascript file and
we'll write the code again here
now
what we'll do here is we'll write here
the code for nav toggle so we'll write
here dollar then we are going to access
the nav toggle class we'll write in nav
toggle
then we'll write here click
then we'll write your function
and inside the body of this function
we'll write dollar
we'll write dot
header
space dot now we are going to access two
different classes then we'll write here
slide
toggle
fine so we'll use the slide toggle
function from jquery
then after this what we'll do is we'll
write here
dollar then we'll again access these two
classes along with the anchor tag so
we'll write here dot
header then we have dot
nav then we'll access the anchor tag
then we'll write here dot
click we'll create a function for this
we'll write your function
and
now what we'll do is we'll write it if
we'll write here
dollar then we'll write inside this
window
dot
width
and if the width is going to be less
than
768
what will happen is
the
header and the navigation bar will
toggle they will slide toggle again so
we'll write here dot header dot
nav
then we'll write here dot slide toggle
again we'll call the slide toggle method
once again here
so we are done with this part save the
program
for now what we'll do is we'll
save the css file and the index file as
well
we'll access this with live server again
and here we are in the website
reduce the size and
you can see the slide toggle method is
working totally fine we have about
we have this category section over here
we have top rated and we have contact so
each section
is working according to our need
so the website is working totally fine
as of now
the next thing we have to write here
inside
a javascript file is for the fixed
header so what we'll do is we'll
write a comment over here we'll write
fixed header because we are going to
write the code for fixed header now so
we'll write here dollar
then we'll use the whole window then
we'll
write here scroll
we'll create a function over here now
inside this function now inside the body
of this function basically what we'll do
is we'll write it if
doll
then we'll use this
dot
scroll top
so we have to write a scroll top
and
this is a method so we'll write here if
scroll top is greater than 100
what will happen is we'll write here
dollar
then we'll again access the header so
we'll write here header
and we'll write here add
class so we are going to add the fixed
class over here we'll write your fixed
and we'll write the code for else part
as well fine so we'll write here else
what happened inside the else block is
going to be dollar
then we have to write here
inside this dot
header
then we have to write here
dot
remove class
and we have to remove the
fixed class fine
so we are done with this part as we are
done with the fixed header part move
back to the website
and you can see the header is fixed
now so you can see
the header is over here in all the pages
so it's working totally fine as of now
now let's move ahead and now we'll write
the code for smooth scrolling to all the
links fine so we'll write here dollar
will access the anchor tag so we'll
write here a inside double inverted
commas then we'll write here on
we are going to use the click event
we'll write a click will create a
function again
we'll write your function now inside the
body of this function
what we have to do is we have to make
sure that
this dot hash has a value before
overriding default behavior so if we
write here if then we have to write here
this dot hash
not equals to
and we have to put a space over here
then inside this we have to prevent the
default anchor click behavior we'll
write here event
dot
prevent default so
this is a predefined function
now what we'll do is we'll store the
value of hash inside a variable so let's
say we are using the where hash
now will write here is equals to this
dot
hash
now we have the
hash variable present inside hash
so we have the value of hash basically
present inside the hash variable
now we'll use jquery's animate method to
add smooth page scroll
so the optional number which is 800 it
specifies the number of milliseconds it
takes to scroll to the specified area
so for that what we'll do is we'll write
here
dollar
will write here html
comma body so we are going to use these
two tags then we'll write here animate
so inside this animate function what we
have to do is we have to define the
properties as well so we'll write here
scroll top scroll top is going to be
dollar then we have to access hash over
here then we'll write here offset
we have to call this offset method will
write your dot talk
fine
now we have to pass the timer as well so
we'll write 800 milliseconds and we have
to create another function over here
inside this function
now inside this function will have use
hash to url when done scrolling so
default click behavior basically so
we'll write here
window
dot
location
dot
hash
fine
is equals to hash
okay so we have to write your function
so the spelling mistake we have over
here so
we are done with this the if statement
ends over here
now what we have to do next is we have
to set light box image max site so
for that what we'll do is
we'll write here
we'll take a constant we'll write a
const
w height so
let's say this is a variable we'll write
here dollar then we'll access the whole
window we'll write a dot window
then we'll write your dot height
and we'll call this method
then we'll write here dollar
will access the lightbox image class so
we'll write here dot
light box
image so we'll write here light box dot
image will use the css property so we'll
write yes dot css then we'll write your
max height
so we'll write your max height
and we'll write here
w height
plus
pixels fine so we'll write your pixels
inside double inverted commas
now we have to do this for light box as
well so we'll write here
after this
dollar again
we'll write here
dot
work item
so basically we are taking the top rated
movies
the inner part from so we'll write a dot
inner then we'll write here dot
click we'll create a function for this
so we'll write your function
now inside the body of this function
what we have to do is we have to write
your index
index is going to be dollar
this
dot parent
and inside here we'll mention the work
item class so we'll write your work
item
then we'll write your dot index
and in the next line we'll write a
dollar
light box again
so we'll write here dollar dot light box
then we'll write here dot
add class so
we'll add the open class over here
so we'll write here dot open
and we have to call a method now so
we'll write here dollar slide
box slide show
and we are good to go with it in the
next line what we have to do is we have
to write the code for previous and next
button so we'll write here dollar
we are going to access
the light box
prep class so we'll write here dot
lightbox dot prep
then we'll write here dot click on
clicking the button what we have to do
is we have to call a function we'll
write your function now inside the body
of this function
we'll write here if
index
is equals to 0
then what will happen is we'll write
here
index
is equals to total work items minus 1 so
we'll write here total work items
minus 1 so we have taken this variable
initially if you can see here the
initial value of this items was the
length of the work item
so we'll mention it over here now we
have to mention the else part as well
we'll write it else
and inside this will write index minus
minus
fine
now after this what we have to do is we
have to call the light box
slideshow method again
and we are done with the previous part
now we have to do the same thing for the
next part so we'll write here dollar
dot
light box
and then we'll access the next class
then we'll write here dot click
we'll call a function
we'll create this function now inside
the body of this function we'll write if
index is equals to is equals
to total work items
minus 1
then index is going to be
0
and we'll write the else part as well
we'll write here else and inside else
will
increase the value of index will write
your index plus plus and once again we
are going to call this light box slide
show method
over here
fine now we are done with these two
parts what we have to do is we have to
close the light box as well so we are
going to write the code for that now we
will write here dollar
will write here
light box
then we'll
use the lightbox close class over here
we'll write here dot click
we'll create a function for this
and inside here we'll write
dollar
we are going to remove this class
basically we are going to remove this
open class so we'll write here dot
lightbox
dot
remove class
which class we are going to remove is
the open class fine
so what we want to do next is we want to
close the light box when clicked outside
of the image box as well so we'll write
the code for that part as well we'll
write your dollar
and we'll write here lightbox
we'll write your dot click
we'll write here function
we are going to create an event now so
we'll write here event
now inside the body of this function
we'll write if
dollar
event
target
dot
has class
light box so we'll write here dot
light box
we have to create the body so we'll
write here dollar
this
dot
remove class
we are again going to remove the class
as open
so we are done with this as well
now the next part is to create the
function lightbox slideshow fine so for
that we'll write here
function
lightbox slideshow this is going to be a
function and we are going to create it
we'll write here const
img src
is equals to
dollar we'll write here
dot
work item so
we'll write your work item
then we'll write a dot
eq
index
so basically we are taking the index we
are going to find the image we'll write
here dot find
we'll write img inside this and then
we'll write
attribute over here so we'll write
attribute attribute is data launch
fine so we'll write here data large
and
then we have to take another constant so
we'll write here const
category
category is going to be
dollar
then we have to access the work item
class again so we'll write your work
item
then we'll do the same thing again we'll
write your dot eq index
then we'll write here dot
find
now inside find we have to mention h4
over here
then we have to write
html
fine
now after this
what we have to do is
we have to write here dollar
then we have to write your dot
lightbox
img
dot attribute so we'll write here dot
attr then we are going to write here src
comma
image source so we'll write here img src
now
fine the next thing we have to do is we
have to write here dollar
we are again going to access the
lightbox category so we'll write here
lightbox
category
then we'll write here dot html
category
and after this we have to write here
dollar
dot
light box
counter
fine
we'll write a dot html
now inside this we'll write here total
work items
plus
and we are going to write here plus
index plus
1.
so we are done with this part as well we
are done with the light box part now the
last thing remaining is the dialog box
on button click
so let's check it out if this thing is
working or not save the program move
back to the website
click on any movie and you can see the
top rated movie section is working fine
the light box is working fine basically
click on out of it
and you can see it's working
fine
click on
the image you can see the image changing
click on the cross over here you can see
the light box closing it's working
totally fine
one thing which is not working over here
is on clicking outside of this image the
light box is not closing
so what we have to do is
we have to remove this
dot from here save it now move back to
the website click on an image click of
outside damage and you can see it's
working totally fine now
fine we are done with the light box now
the last thing remaining is the dialog
box fine so let's write the code for
dialog box as well
we'll write here after this
dollar
so we have to access the button so the
button id is button then we'll write
here dot
click
we are going to create a function we are
going to use jquery ui for this
you can add more interactions or we can
say more widgets to this but for now we
are going to use the dialog box widget
so we are going to write here
dollar then we are going to write here
hash
dialog
and
then we'll write here dot
dialog
will pass open over here then
it fine now the next thing we have to do
is
to write a dollar then we are going to
access the dialog box again we are going
to write here dot dialog
again so we are going to write your dot
dialog now we have to define the
properties of this dialog box widget so
we are going to write here
title
title is going to be
thank you for
contacting
then we have
close on escape property so we'll write
here close
on escape
we'll write here false
for close on escape then we have model
as well so we'll write here model as
true fine
we'll do one more thing we'll set the
auto open property to false for now
we'll write your auto open
and we'll write here
false fine
so here we are done with the website
save the program and let's do one thing
let's open this whole thing again with
live server and we'll see if our website
is working so you can see the preloader
thing is working now fine
and we have this about us section we
have the category section for our movies
it's all working totally fine then we
have the top rated movies over here it's
working fine as well
then we have the contact us section over
here we'll write a name over here again
we'll write your caution
email is going to be caution at the rate
gmail.com then we'll write some message
over here we'll write thank you
send message and you can see it says
thank you for contacting will get back
to you soon don't forget to check your
email
so this thing is also working fine the
title is thank you for contacting if we
try to click on any of these
placeholders now you can see we are not
able to do it because of the model
property
so the website is working totally fine
all the icons and everything is working
fine if you remove reduce the size of
our browser you can see the burger menu
as well it's working fine as well
and it looks good right
and with that we come to the end of this
full course tutorial if you enjoyed
watching the video do give it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and our
experts will answer them for you thank
you so much for being here watch out for
more videos from us until then keep
learning and stay tuned to simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you